prezentovali.
Vážené dámy,
vážení pánové, zahuji dnešní
28. řádné zasání
zastupitelstva města Zdína.
Netene vás všechny, srdečně vítám.
Vzle prezence je přítomen
dostatečný počet členů,
aby zase zastupitelstvo mohl usnášet.
Omluvení jsou pan Martín Pášma,
paní Zuzana Píšerová,
pan Josef Kocháň a pan Pavel Sekula.
Pozdější příchod nahlásil
pan Tomáš Dudák a pan Bronislav Janda.
V distanční účasti
se nepřilásil žádný
pardon, žádný
z členů zastupitelstva
a vítám tímto i pana Tomáši Dudáka,
který zvládl dorazit včas,
takže za to moc krát děkuju,
že preventivně nahlásil,
ale nakonec všechno stihl,
takže jsem za to rád.
Tak, k ověření zápisu z dnešního zasedání
určitýtočně zastupitelstva,
a to pana Zdeňka Lacinu
a pana Stanislava Skálu.
Zápis z 27. zasedání
zastupitelstva
ze dne 18. června
2026 byl bez přípomínek
ověřen a podepsán.
Vážení členové zastupitelstva,
nyní provedeme volbu
návrhové komise.
Do návrhové komise
návrhové tytočně zastupitelstva,
a to jako představkyní
paní Moniku Špalkovou
a jako členy pana Pavla Simkoviče
a pana Lubomíra Trauba.
Máte k tomu to návrhu?
Někdo připomínky?
Nikdo se nehlásí,
takže prosím, pojďme hlasovat
o návrhové komise tak,
jak jsem ji navrhl.
Pro 32.
Návrhové komise byla schválená
a náměstek Merech Alánek
se ještě hlásí,
že teda hlasovat také pro,
aby byl 33.
Každopádně na hlasování
to nic nemění.
Návrhové komise byla schválená
a do zápisu to bude uvedeno.
Tradiční technická připomínka
vzhledem k tomu,
že zjednání zastupitelstva města Zdína
je pořizovan
audiovizuální záznam,
který je online přinášen.
Žádám všechny diskutují,
s ohledem na příslušná zákon
na ustanovení o ochraně osobních údajů,
aby ve svých projevech
neuváděli,
po případě minimalizovali
používání osobních údajů
a pouze na tento odkaz
se odkázali přímo do materiálů.
Jako dalším bodem
je vystoupení občanů,
takže předávám teďka slovo
panu tajemníkovi,
který nás provede tímto bodem.
Děkuji, pane primátore.
Dobré ráno,
vážené dámy, vážení pánové.
Dle jednacího řádu
zastupitelstva města Zlína
od stavce dvě článků
sedm vystoupení občanů,
sděluji, že máme celkem
čtyři osoby přihlášené
z veřejnosti k vystoupení
k tomuto bodu.
Chci jen upozornit,
že délka jednoho vystoupení
jsou čtyři minuty.
Prvním vystoupením je pan Hruza,
požádám ho k mikrofonu
na téma ohodnocení činnosti
zastupitelstva města Zlína
na konci volebního období.
Dobrý den, dámy a pánové,
dobrý den, pané primátore.
V dnešním vystoupení bych chtěl
pohodnotit činnost
z desedícího zastupitelství,
ale mě bych chtěl poukázat
na nejnesplněné sliby.
Tak mezi to počítám
již dříve řadu let
požadovaný přechod
z ulice Zámecké
k dvou zastávkám
na zastávku MHD.
Takže to tam není
do dnešního dne,
územní plán to obsahoval,
ovšem do toho zasáhla
komise městní části,
která vyhledla jiné místo,
že takže potnikateli vyhověla,
tak proč ne,
když dával dovolev
dvakrát dvěsta tisíc.
No a takže ten přechod
tam není,
protože tam,
jak se oni domnívali
a udělali
pro to, jako úpravu
těch chodníků a tak,
tak to neplatí,
protože to neschvalila policie.
Dále pak,
do dnešního dne,
tady není
Česká obchodní inspekce.
Ona tady bývala ve čtvrtek,
vždycky, ale jenom občas.
Takže nakonec
to zrušili úplně.
Takže tady ve Zlíně není,
v krajském městě je Brně.
Tak já myslím,
že to není dobré.
Tady, když občané se nemůžou
na Českou obchodní inspekci obrátit,
že to nahrává nějakým šmejdům
a podobným lidem,
kteří nechtějí,
aby nad něma byla nějaká kontrola,
tady fungovala.
No, dále jsem tady slíbil
už před dvěma lety,
že připomenu před volbama
ty, kteří odsouhlasili
zvědnutí těch domovní daní.
Já jsem platil
na začátku v roce
2354 Kč.
V dnešní době
a to podotýkám,
že před rokem to potom snižovali,
platí jim 3177.
Je to enormní nárůst,
nejvíc v celé republice.
Takže to není dobré pro tady občany.
Já myslím, že ten,
kdo si postaví svoje vlastní bydlení,
že je přínosem pro obyvatele.
Co si budeme vykládat?
Kolik se toho staví?
Kdo tady postavil ty jižní zvahy?
Sídliště Podhoří,
sídliště Malenovice,
Kvítkovice.
I to bylo bitvu,
to postavili bolševici,
to si musíte přiznat.
Kdyby tyto stava tady nebyla,
tak kde by ti lidé bydleli?
To byste nemohli z toho zlína dělat,
krajské město.
A teďka co stavíte?
Staví se především tady
fabriky pro nezaměstnané.
Do toho počítám hlavně ty školy.
Já nevím, kam je budete dávat.
Je velký nadpočet úředníků,
ten by se měl snížit
minimálně o jednu třetinu.
Víte, jaký to je rozpočet,
co to všechno se bere?
Všady to má dopad na to.
No a místo, abyste tady podporovali ty lidi
a vy tak dáte akorát,
tak už to padlo ta odměna,
když si napíše bydliště.
No tak já už o tom nechci
tady dále stále mluvit.
No tak já s tou dopravou také.
Tak hustá doprava je úplně neskutečná.
Postavili jste sice velice pěkné dětské říště
tam pod ulicí.
To je Sokolská pokračování.
Ovšem je to v dolině
a ve špěré ty spodiny jdou dolů.
No a jinak by to bylo pěkné.
No a nic děkuji za slyšení
a končím s pozdravem
bývalým hrůz.
Nesmím zvedat ruku, aby neřekli,
že hajluju hrůza na ranici.
Tak děkuji.
Dalším vystupujícím poprosím
pana Antonína Zelinku
ve věci plánování dopravy.
Dobrý den všem přítomným.
Všimněte si prosím,
že město Zlín až dosud
zkapacitňuje svůj dopravní skelet.
Toto má stejný tragický konec.
Vyčerpání rezervních ploch
pro dopravu
a 20 let chybějící vnější
dopravní obslužnost obchvat.
A to jsme my
ve Zlíně právě teď.
Máme až 17 průdé křižovatky,
ale od obchodního domu
na Otrokovice musíme kolem kostela.
Máme tež vybouraný roh budovy,
aby se vyhnuli dva dětské kočárky
a nějaký ten chodec v patě křižovatky.
Víme také, co dělat,
ale celá desetiletí
to ignorujeme.
A já žádám o odpověď proč.
V platné strategii města Zlína
do roku 2030
z úkolu D1.2
plyne mantra
řešení dopravy.
Dopravu města Zlína
řešne novou obslužnou komunikací
mimo město
na náklady Hřosedl
a to od studie
po kolaudaci.
Proč nejdeme touto cestou,
když Hřosedl preferuje
obchvatý měst,
aby zachránili lidem životní prostředí.
Také v generálu dopravy
města Zlína
je uvedena varianta C
Zlínka.
Tuto poctu
jsem si nezasloužil
zhruba
třicetinásobným
trápením se u tohoto pultíku.
Zpracovatel
generálu dopravy
by bez mé varianty
musel vracet
honorář.
Varianta A
totiž byla
technický omyl
v podobě městského tunelu.
Varianta B
tvořila
čtyřproudá
nadzemní pravobřežka,
kterou před
18 lety
zařízlo
ministerstvo dopravy
s tím,
že by vytvořila
další průtah městem
bez atributu obchvatu.
Dopravní zatížení
v této variantě
střídy Tomáše Batí
mělo přejít
na pravobřežku.
Z tohoto pohledu
ztrácí
a také
ztratila také
poštenská příčka
90%
své původní
důležitosti.
Jak to,
že dopravní
odbor
magistrátu
přišel
s předvolebním
prioritou
první etapou
pravobřežky.
Přejmenování
nábřežní ulice
na pravobřežní
při zachování
počtu dopravních pruhů
dává záruku,
že skavba
bude mít
nulový vliv
na současnou
dopravní,
současný dopravní
skelet města.
Moc mne mrzí,
že se ani
jeden z vás
nepostavil
a
nepostavil tomu
a řekl
dost
dopravnímu
zpoždělání města.
Děkuji za pozornost.
Děkuji za
dodržení času.
Odpovíme samozřejmě
do 30 dnů,
tak jak je
uvedeno na přihlášce
k vystoupení.
Třetím vystoupící
pan Šaur,
rozšíření
parkovacích míst
z ubytového domu
v ulici Věžové domy.
Prosím,
máte slovo.
Vážený pane primátore,
vážené paní zastupitelky,
vážení páni zastupitelé,
dovolte mi dnes
vystoupit
problému
parkování
věžových domů,
konkrétně
v domu
číslopopisné
861.
Jsem rád,
že po měsících
jednání
už konečně máme
v ruce něco
konkrétního,
a to studií
proveditelnosti.
Za tuto studii
městu děkuji.
Obyvatelé
domu 861
při tom od začátku
nepožadovali
nic nereálného.
Předložili jsme
konkrétní návrh,
konkrétní místa,
situační plán
a také podporu
22 z 29
bytových jednotek,
který 76 %.
A nyní máme
výsledek odborného
posouzení.
Studie nabízí
dvě varianty.
Varianta dvě
přináší
sedm nových
podelných
parkovacích míst
a vyžaduje
kácení
čtyř stromů.
Varianta jedna
přináší
patnáct
nových
parkovacích míst
a vyžaduje
kácení
šesti stromů.
A právě tady
bych chtěl
zastupitele požádat,
aby se na věc
podívali také
prakticky.
Těch současných
sedm
podelných
míst
v podstatě
odpovídá tomu,
co obyvatelé
v tomto prostoru
už nezdělají.
Auta
zde podelně
parkují
i nyní.
Problem je,
že při otáčení
a najíždění
musí zasahovat
na chodní.
Varianta dvě
tedy podle
našeho názoru
především
legalizuje
a stavebně
upravuje
stav,
který už
v určité
podobě
existuje.
Varianta 1 je
něco jiného.
Ta skutečně přináší
15 nových
parkovacích míst
a podle
samotného
závěru studie
je z hlediska
parkovací kapacity
výhodnější.
Ano,
varianta 1
znamená
kácení
šesti vzrostlých stromů.
To nespochybňuji.
ale právě
proto podle mě
nyní není správnou
odpovědí
variantu 1
rovnou zamítnout.
Studie
sama říká,
že rozhodující
bude stanovisko
odboru zeleně.
A také
uvádí,
že při předběžném
projednání
neznesla
policie
České republiky
k žádné z variant
zásadní připomínky.
Proto vás
dnes žádám
o jednu
konkrétní věc.
Nenechávejme
variantu 1
v této fázi
skončit.
Prosím,
aby město
zadalo
její další
projektové
zpracování
a nechalo
přesně
prověřit,
jak lze
minimalizovat
zásah do zeleně,
jak ochránit
okolní stromy,
jaké jsou
přesné možnosti
v souvislosti
s inženýrskými
sítěmi
a jaké
budou
skutečné
náklady.
Teprve potom
můžeme udělat
odpovědné
konečné rozhodnutí.
Podle studie
je orientační cena
varianty 1
přibližně
962 tisíc
korun,
včetně
DPH.
Za tuto částku
bychom získali
15 nových
parkovacích míst.
To samozřejmě
není malá částka,
ale dovolte mi
připomenout,
že se bavíme
o problému,
který se netýká
jednoho člověka,
ani jednoho auta.
Týká se
celého domu
a širší lokality
věžových domů.
Proto vás dnes prosím,
dejte variantě
1 šanci.
Ne schválením
kácení stromů,
ale schválením
jejich
dalšího
odborného
zpracování.
A dovolím si
položit
poslední otázku.
Může nám
dnes
vedení města
slíbit,
že varianta
1 nebude
odložena
do šuplíku,
ale bude
bez zbytečného
odkladu
dále projektově
připravována
tak,
aby o její
případné
realizaci
mohlo
být skutečně
rozhodnuto.
Děkuji.
Děkuji vám
za dodržení
časového
limitu.
Pan primátor
v Koste
určitě vám
nebude mít
slibovat,
to asi tady
v současné,
že mám dneska
poslím zastupitelst
města Zdína,
to asi není
úplně to zprávné.
Každopádně
to, co vám
můžu určitě
deklarovat,
je to,
že ty varianty
byly dány
z důvodu toho,
aby se všechny
vyhodnotily,
takže nemyslím si,
že varianta číslo 1
bude hozená
jako do šuplíku
nebo prejď.
Bude to všechno
vyhodnocovat,
ale samozřejmě
je to otázka,
jak se k tomu
postaví také
životní prostředí
a jiné orgány,
které vlastně
potom povolují
tu stavbu.
Takže jenom
ta deklarace
určitě je
a uvidíme,
jak to nás
nebude vyhodnoteno.
Děkuji.
My studií
považujeme
za začátek
další etapy,
nikoli v konec
našeho požadavku.
Děkuji vám.
Chtěli bychom,
a rozhodneme o ní
až na základě
dokončeného projektu
všech potřebných
stanovisek.
Děkuji.
Děkuji vám.
Poslední přihláškou
je pan Pavel Veverka
k změně územního plánu.
Chcete vystoupit teď?
Ten bod změny
územních plánů
je zařazen
v řádném programu.
Chcete vystoupit teď?
Dobře.
Máte čiři minuty.
V programu
vašeho zastuptelsa
jsou tři změny
územního plánu.
Jedna změna je
podali jsme
žádost o změnu
územního plánu
z plochy
pydlení
jako rezervy
na plochu pydlení.
Podle informací,
které mám,
tak snad by se to
mělo zamítnout.
Jedná se o lokalitu
Příruky Pančava
na ulici
Želechovická.
Já jsem celou dobu
vlastně,
když se zpracoval
územní plán,
žádal o tuto změnu.
Bohužel
vždycky bylo zamítnuto
s tím, že tato naše ulice,
která vlastně běží
mezi zahrádkama,
tak zahrádky
nad touto ulicí
jsou stavební
a my,
kteří jsme po cestou,
pořád máme,
jsme měli
charakter zahrad.
Z hlediska
urbanistického si myslím,
že se nejedná o žádný zásah.
Dá se to i technicky vyřešit
připojení domu na vodu
i na kanalizaci.
Elektrika tam je,
takže si myslím,
že to zamítnutí
této žádosti
je podle mě
zcela zbytečné.
To je vlastně
všechno,
co bych chtěl říct.
Já si říkám,
deset let snažím
o tuto změnu,
ale bohužel
je to jako peřina.
Když do ní boucháte,
tak se nic neděje.
Čili
jestli je možné
se na to ještě znovu
podívat
a zkusit,
zkusit třeba
udělat tu změnu,
že by se tady
tento pozemek
mohl změnit
na pozemek
stavební.
Tak to je asi všechno.
Děkuji moc.
Já jenom,
abychom si srovnali,
co schvaluje
zastupitelství
města Zína
dneska.
My z pozice
zastupitelství
města Zína
nemáme v gestci
a nemáme
zákona pravomoc
měnit územní plán,
jakože bychom
my tady řekli
toto ano,
toto ne.
My aktuálně
doporučujeme,
co projektant
má,
když to řeknu,
zvážit,
bych to řekl,
že my řekneme
doporučujeme
k zapracování,
ale co bude
zapracováno,
už je potom
na projektantovi.
Každopádně
stav je ten,
že samozřejmě
jsme si ty
jednotlivé lokality
vyhodnocovali,
na mnoha lokalitách
jsme fyzicky byli,
ať už
pan náměstek,
který má
v současné
bev gesty
územní plán
nebo přímo
pracovníci
daného odboru
a na základě
toho padla
doporučení,
jestli teda
ano nebo ne.
Já bych tím to
chtěl rovnou říct,
a to už
sice předbíhám
těm bodům,
stav je ten,
že my máme
dohodu aktuálně,
že co se týká
změny územního plánu
číslo 7,
která je rozdělená
na ABC,
s tím, že
A se změní textová část,
za B jsou tady
ty jednotlivé změny
od občanů,
případně firm,
které nám došly,
to je to,
co jsme schvalovali
vždycky jako více
netradičně tady
na tom zastupitelstvu,
tak vlastně tam
i změna 7C,
která je
jakoby koncepční změnou
toho územního plánu.
A dohoda je ta,
že budoucí projektant,
kterého vlastně
musíme například
ještě vysoutěžit,
tak dostane
jak samozřejmě
ty změny 7B,
tak dostane také
všechny aktuálně
nedoporučené změny,
které v 7B dáváme
jako, že nedoporučujeme.
Případně změny,
které došly teďka,
jakž to řeknu,
ještě v tom mezidobí
a nejsou dnešní,
nejsou vůbec
najednání zastupitelstva.
A protože,
když bude dělat
koncepční změnu,
tak aby se na to podíval,
jak vůbec lidé
tady uvažují,
co vlastně požadují.
A tím pádem,
pokud dneska
je v 7B
něco dáno
jako nedoporučeno,
tak není vyloučeno,
že v rámci
koncepční změny 7C
se bude řešit
vlastně celá ta lokalita
a může nastat ta změna,
ačkoliv my jsme v Bčku
řekli,
že to nedoporučujeme.
Takže tím bych chtěl jenom říct,
že víceméně to,
co jsem chtěl říct
a já se dívám,
že tady ten bod váš
máme jako nedoporučeno.
S tím,
že jak říkáte,
je tam lokalita
rekreáčních zahrádek
a ona,
jako ta rezerva,
pardon,
rezerva na bydlení,
kde jsou vlastně
aktualné zahrádky
a ona se tak jako postupně
ještě řekl ze všech stran
jako odebírá
a postupně se mění
na to bydlení individuální.
To znamená,
z našeho pohledu
nebo z pohledu odboru,
který si to vyhodnocoval,
tak aktuálně bylo,
že je tam prostě ta,
bych řekl,
zahrádkářská kolonie,
bych to nazval,
prostě je tam tady
tento stav,
který je tam vhodné zachovat,
ale vzhledem k tomu
samozřejmě nějakým způsobem
se tomu postaví
ta koncepční změna,
tak je možné,
že se to změní jako celek,
jako když se chce
celá ta lokalita.
Nikoliv pouze ten jeden váš pozemek,
protože té koncepční změny
se opravdu řeší
nikoliv jednotlivé pozemky,
ale celkový přístup.
A může se stát,
že vzhledem k tomu,
že tady opravdu je to obklíčené
bytovým bydlením individuálním,
že místo toho jedné parcely
se změní všechny,
aby to dávalo smysl
v té koncepční verzi.
Takže tím jenom za sebe říkám,
že dneska to máte
v materiálu 7B
jako nedoporučeno
z důvodu toho,
že vytrhávat jeden pozemek
není úplně logické
a je to nějaký vstup
vlastně vůbec do té kolonie,
ale v 7C je otázka,
jestli ten projekt tam postaví
a vzhledem k tomu,
jak já to vidím,
tak ta pravděpodobnost,
že se to změní,
rozhodně není malá.
Takhle to řeknu.
A poprosím ještě náměstka
pán Hlavare Lutví,
který má v gesti.
Dobré dopoledne všem.
Já bych možná nám řekl
několik slov k tomu.
Ze strany stavební komise
tento pozemek nebyl doporučen,
probíhala ohledně toho
samozřejmě diskuze
a již to,
co zmínil pan primátor,
že by se měla koncepčně
přistoupit v celé lokalitě,
tak to bylo řečeno
i na té stavební komisii.
A včera byl pravděpodobně
někdo od vás,
se se mnou potkával
a já jsem jim řekl to tež,
že tady to docela dává smysl
a nicméně nemůžeme
ten pozemek vydělit
jako jeden pozemek
a ostatní nechat.
Takže je třeba k tomu
přistoupit koncepčně,
dát samozřejmě podněty
ze strany ostatních majitelů
a v nějakém dalším návrhu
územního plánu.
Po případě teda,
pokud by to bylo součástí
těch našich koncepčních změn,
tak by to bylo možné
jako zařadit.
Já jsem říkal,
kdyby se o tom jako vědělo
a připravilo se to
souhlas dalších
jako vlastníků pozemků,
tak byla reálná šance,
že se to mohlo změnit.
Ohledně tohoto pozemku
konkrétně probíhala
dlouhá diskuze
na stavební komisii
a vzhledem k tomu,
že to je vydělána
jenom jako jednotlivá část,
tak proto to nebylo doporučeno.
Děkují.
Prá, děkujeme.
Tímto vlastně byl
poslední vystupující,
takže budeme pokračovat
dále v programu,
kdy dalším bodem je
schválení programu
dnešního zasedání zastupitelstva
a v úterý 15. září
byl uvolněn aktualizovaný
doplněný návrh programu
o dva materiály,
takzvaně na stůl.
Jedná se o zprávu
kontrolně výboru zastupitelstva
a materiál týkající se pozemků.
Tyto materiály
jste spolu s ostatními
obdrželi v elektronické podobě
a v programu jsou
očíslovány tak,
jak byly dodatečně zařazeny.
Chce bych se tedy tímto zeptat,
jestli má někdo
k navrženému programu
návrhy nebo připomínky.
Nikdo se nehlásí,
takže prosím,
pojďme hlasovat
o dnešním programu
tak, jak byl navržen.
Pro 26.
Program dnešního zastupitelstva
byl přijat.
Navazujeme tedy bodem číslo 4,
což je zpráva
o úplnění rozpočtu
statutárního města
z dína k 30. 6.
a poprosím náměstka
Mirka Chalánka
o úvod k tomuto materiálu.
Dobrý den,
vážené kolegyně,
vážení kolegové.
Já pár slov
k tomuto materiálu.
Pokud bude debata,
diskuze,
samozřejmě budeme reagovat.
V tuto chvíli
máme
za sebou půlroční plnění,
takže
asi ty nejdůležitější
informace jsou,
jak se nám
týkají vlastně
plnění toho rozpočtu
z hlediska příjmů.
Ty nás asi zajímají
v tuto chvíli nejvíc,
jak vypadá situace,
protože to je věc,
kterou nemáme úplně
ve svém moci,
takže tady jsme
odkázaní vlastně
na rozpočtové určení
daní,
to, co nám dává,
jak se vůbec
zdaří ekonomice
naší republice.
Dobrá zpráva je,
že to plnění
je v souladu
s tím,
jak jsme si to naplánovali,
což je opravdu
jako dobrá zpráva.
Je to plnění
rozpočtu
30.6.
Já můžu říct,
že my samozřejmě
ten vývoj toho rozpočtu
sledujeme
i v každém
následujícím měsíci,
takže teď jsem schopen
doplnit ještě informace
týkající se července
a srpna
a ta zpráva je příznivá
v tom,
že vlastně
to plnění
opravdu
tak, jak trošku
ze začátku
a v průběhu
hlavně
ten červen
vypadalo,
že začínáme
ztrácet dech,
tak ten červenec
a srpen
byly velmi dobré,
hlavně z hlediska
vývoje DPH
a jsme
prostě na té trajektorii
kterou potřebujeme.
Já jenom,
když se na to podíváte
z hlediska toho
meziročního srovnání,
tak vidíte,
že je tam nárůst
co se týče
toho daňového příjmu,
ale je potřeba vzít
v úvahu,
že rok
2025 a 2026
má jednu základní
rozdíl
a to je,
že nepedagogický pracovníci
jsou dneska
vlastně zhrazení
z provozních výdajů
a my na ně dostáváme
prostřednictvím příjmu
peníze.
To znamená,
že to je těch 187 milionů,
které tam jsou.
Obecně bych řekl tak,
jako jestli chceme mít
meziroční nárůst
zejískat daňových příjmů
na sdílených daních
4%,
tak my potřebujeme
ten meziroční různí
kde na úrovni
minimálně 17%,
což v tuto chvíli
se daří
a vypadá to tak,
jako že by to bylo
naplněné a splněné,
což je pro ten rozpočet
strašně důležité,
protože to je
největší částka
toho příjmu.
My máme na sdíleních daních
přes 2 miliardy,
takže každá desetina procenta
tam hraje velkou roli.
Co se týče
potom té výdajové strany,
takže z líska provozních výdajů
jsme někde tam,
kde jsme chtěli být,
nějakých 40 milionů.
Měli jsme tam,
pardon, 49% plnění,
měli jsme tam nějaké
více náklady
spojené jako s růstoucí cenou
pohony hmot,
kdy jsme museli dofinancovat
technické služby,
takže nějaký náklad,
více náklad se nám tam projevěl,
ale z líska těchto
procentického plnění
jsme pořád tam,
kde bychom měli být.
Potom je záležitost
investičního,
investic vlastně tak,
jak se nám daří plnit,
takže já si myslím,
že to číslo někde
na úrovni 30%
k tomu terminu
30.6.
To znamená,
že to jsou ty peníze,
které už jsme opravdu zaplatili,
tak není špatné samozřejmě.
Teď budou ty rozhodující měsíce,
hlavně říjen, listopad,
které už budou určovat,
jak se nám daří ty investice
realizovat a jak to funguje.
Takže to je jen takový krátkej úvod,
pokud budou samozřejmě nějaké dotazy,
tak zodpovím.
Děkuji za ten úvod
a otvírám diskuzi
k tomuto bodu.
Tak, do diskuzi se hlásí pan Dudák,
takže poprosím pana Dudáka.
Dobré ráno, dámy a pánové.
Já se omlouvám za ty zmatky
s tím pozdním příchodem.
Já jsem původně měl jiný program,
ale vzhledem k tomu
čtvrtečnímu mailu,
kdy jste nám zadali práci,
tak jsem musel program změnit,
proto tady jsem šťast.
A teď je k bodu,
kterém se bavíme.
My jsme to řešili na finančním výboru.
Já fakt jsem velmi rád,
jak se pro mě až nepochopitelným způsobem
vyvíjí ekonomická situace
České republiky,
že ty příjmy z výběru daní
jsou lepší než...
My jsme předpokládali respektive
náš poradce města,
takže jsem rád,
že město drží konzervativní linku
a ta realita je lepší.
Ale musíme si taky říct,
to nejsou úspěchy,
za které by měly být korunovány
naše hlavy.
To jsou prostě příjmy peněz
daňových poplatníků na straně příjmu.
Pro mě je to skvělá zpráva,
ale není to naše zásluha.
Já tam bohužel stále nevidím
dostatek na té stránce výdajové
nějakých úspor.
My se sice držíme rozpočtu,
to je fajn,
ale stále náš názor je,
že by ten rozpočet
v některých mandatorních výdajích
hlavně osobních nákladů
nebo větších provozních nákladů
měl být na příští rok
více střídmi.
To je za nás.
Děkuji.
Tak já jenom.
Kdybych to chtěl trošku odlehčit,
tak jsme,
a nemyslím, že nějak ve zlém,
tak jsme slyšeli už
názor občana,
že máme od třetinu snížit počty.
Tak možná to je ta cesta,
ale ne to už říkám trošku z nadsázku,
protože víme samozřejmě,
že my se snažíme
tu optimizaci dělat průběžně
a pan témník na tom úslovně pracuje
a proto jsme také už schvalovali
na radě v tomto roce
několikrát úpravy
vlastně oprů podoby magistrátu.
Takže samozřejmě ty rezervy,
co můžeme říkat,
i v těch personálích
nebo optimizacích procesů,
jsou, budou vždycky
a musíme je postupně odstraňovat
s tím a prosto souhlasím.
Ale poprosím o reakci ještě
náměstka Mirka Chalánka,
protože samozřejmě jsou i věci,
které my neumíme ovlivnit.
Vy, to, co se na nás ještě chystá,
změna tabulek
a další věci,
které vlastně seřejmě
nám zase ten provoz navýší,
protože je to rozhodné
vláda
nebo jiný nadřízený orgán.
Poprosím ještě náměstka Mirka Chalánka.
Děkuji.
Děkuji, pane primatore.
Já jenom krátká reakce
na pana Dudákova.
Ano, já s tím souhlasím.
Tento materiál je o tom,
jak se nám daří plnit to,
co jsme si naplánovali.
Můžeme mít samozřejmě
různej názor na to,
jak ty položky z hlediska
toho provozu mají vypadat.
Dneska dobrá zpráva pro nás je,
že prostě se ten příjem
daří plnit.
Čili to, co jsme si naplánovali,
s tím můžeme počítat.
Pro tu ekonomiku je strašně důležitý
kontinuita a jakási předvídatelnost,
což teďka
taky je potvrzeno,
což je dobrá zpráva.
Pro ty, co budou sestavovat
rozpočet příště,
že můžou se o něco
nějaké meziroční srovnání
a tak dále pracovat s těmi daty.
Samozřejmě můžeme se líšit v názoru,
co tam má být zahrnuto a co ne.
To si myslím, že je debata
potom v prosinci ohledně
sestavení rozpočtu na další období.
Já si myslím, že pro tuto chvíli
je strašně důležité opravdu
jednak pracovat,
řekl bych,
konzervativně
s těmi příjmy,
protože
přece jenom ta situace
je trošku taková turbulentní.
A druhá věc je,
vzhledem k tomu,
že nás čekají nějaké výdaje,
hlavně z ohledně dopravy,
tak aby jsme byli schopni
předvídatelně
ten rozpočet nastavit
minimálně v nějakém středně dobém horizontu,
což jsou 4-5 let.
Děkuji za tu odpověď
a nikdo další
se do diskuze nehlásí,
takže já poprosím,
pojďme hlasovat
o materiál číslo 4.
Pro 25,
materiál číslo 4 byl přijat.
Materiál číslo 5
jsou rozpočtová opatření,
navýšení a přesuny,
jsou k tomu dotazy.
Poprosím Janu Bazilovou.
Dobré dopoledne,
dámy a pánové,
já teda nemám žádný dotaz,
jenom bych chtěla nahlásit
střed zájmu ve všech bodech,
které se budou týkat
společnosti STESA
v dnešním programu.
Děkuji.
Dobrá, děkuji.
Níkdo další se do diskuze nehlásí,
takže prosím,
pojďme hlasovat materiál číslo 5.
Pro 25,
materiál číslo 5 byl přijat.
Materiál číslo 6 je poskytnutí
finančního daru
zboru hasičů.
Konkrétně se bavíme
o našich hasičích,
tady ne krajských,
to znám,
co se týká stanice ve Zlíně,
kdy po požáru 34. budovy
jsme s nimi vstoupili do jednání
a dohodli jsme se,
že s třeším
pomůžeme
nicméně napravit techniku
nebo vlastně věci,
které jsou v současné době
pro mě s otazníkem,
jestli budou mít hrazeny
z ministerstva
a samozřejmě bereme
a ta dohoda zní,
že pokud se ty věci
podaří jim získat
z rozpočtu státu,
tak tento dar jim samozřejmě
zůstane zachován
a bude použit
na nákup
provozních potřeb,
jako jsou například
ochranné obleky
nebo jiné pomůcky
pro sbor hasičů
tady na naší
Zlínské stanici.
Poprosím pana Dudáka.
Děkuji za slovo,
pane primátore.
Já jenom
technickou otázku mám.
Tam se hovoří
v těch dvou bodech,
že je to příspěvek
na techniku,
která byla poškozena
během toho zásahu,
kde jistě odbědli
skvělou práci.
Plně tomu nerozumím,
jestli jim vznikla
nějaká škoda
způsobená
nějakým
činitelem.
jestli bychom tu škodu
neměli vymáhat
potom,
kdo ten problém
způsobil
nebo jestli se to
nekryje z pojistky.
Ten stav je ten,
že by tam zbyla
nebo nějaká
výrazná škoda.
Je potřeba říct,
že na 34. budově
dle mých informací
první jednotka,
která na místo dorazila,
tak byly naši městčí
jako profesionální hasiči.
To znamená převážná
většina hadíc
a podobných věcí,
které tam zůstaly,
tak byly z našich
hasičář,
nebych to řekl.
A to je věc,
kterou jsme řešili
v rámci rady
do vybavení
jak naší
profesionální jednotky,
tak našich
dobrovolných hasičům,
kteří následně byli.
A bavíme se o část
kolem 2 milionů korun,
které jsme na to
vlastně uvolnili
jak na náhradu
té techniky,
tak na celé do vybavení.
K tomu vlastně
řešíme tady opravdu
krajské hasiče,
kteří samozřejmě
odvedli velký kus práce
a jsou tou prioritní sílou,
která vlastně potom
samozřejmě
celý ten požád
zase řešila.
A jsou tam
vlastně položky,
které jsou,
když to řeknu pro ně,
relativně standardní
pro zásah,
to znamená
více mě ten zákon
nebo respektive
jejich postupy,
principy počítají s tím,
že by to měly dostat
nahrazeno.
Ale je tam pořád
ten otazník,
protože jsou v té situaci,
kdy samozřejmě neví,
jestli to opravdu
reálně dostanou
nebo to prostě jim
bude řečeno,
tady si to odepište
a v nějakém příštím roce,
až budete řešit
provozní rozpočet,
jak si to dovybavte
a podobně.
Proto my jsme vlastně
zareagovali tímto způsobem,
že chceme,
aby ta jednotka
byla,
pro vož,
řeknu,
akce schopná
na 100%,
bych to řekl,
nebo jak se říká
na 110%,
protože seřejmě
na 100%
musí být pořád,
ale chtěli jsme,
aby ty věci
na ně nemuseli čekat,
nemuseli mít
s otazníkem.
Tím pádem
jsme se dohodli,
že ten dar
tady vlastně
jim dáme,
ale zároveň
proto jsme v tom daru
vlastně uvedli
a udělali jsme
ten druhý bod,
což je vlastně
na provozní potřeby
a to znamená,
že jsou schopni
vlastně za to
nakoupit věci
na dovybavení
těch hasičů,
kteří vlastně
na té stanici jsou,
například
třívrstvými obleky
a nebo nějakými
ochrannými pomůckami.
To znamená,
v případě,
že si jim to podaří
na ministerstvu,
případně
na jich nadřízných orgánech
opravdu získat
ve krátké době
ty finanční prostředky,
které by nahradili
ty věci,
které potřebují
z důvodu toho požáru
na 34. budově,
tak ty finanční prostředky,
které my dneska darujeme,
tak budou využity
ve prospěch vlastně
vybavení
naší stanice ve Zlíně.
Jsou k tomu
nějaké další dotazy?
Prostě jim
pana náměstka Vlofa.
Já bych chtěl poděkovat
panu privátorovi,
ale vy jste teďka
komentoval druhý bod,
který přijde až
s darem pro HZS,
tady tenhle bod
vlastně číslo šest
je poskytnutí daru
našemu sboru
dobrovolných hasičů.
My jsme už vlastně
během rady,
jasně po tom zásahu
té 34. budovy,
schválili odměnu
pro naše
dobrovolné hasiče
z města Zlína.
Tam byla částka
asi 800 tisíc
a většina těch jednotek
splňovala tu částku,
která se dala
odsouhlasit na radě.
A pouze štípa
má tu částku výšší,
protože tam byly
dlouhou dobu,
ten zásah byl dlouhý,
střídali se tam vlastně
u cisterny pouze
hasiči,
takže to je poslední
zbytek z těch darů,
který ještě nebyl
dořešený
a je potřeba
to tady dneska schoválit.
Moc káro děkuji
za tu opravu,
já se moc ovlouvám všem,
já jsem přišel
nadpis dar hasičů,
tak jsem automaticky bral,
že to je tady ten
pro krajské,
takže moc káro děkuji
za to doplnění,
takže toto je vlastně
ten dar,
který,
jak jsem říkal,
že jsme uvolenili
našim hasičům
z toho částku
zhruba s kolem
dvou milionů korun,
tak toto je jedna
z těch položek,
kterou vlastně
my jsme nebyli schopni
schválit v radě,
protože,
jak říká pan náměst,
tak už to bylo vlastně
výšší než
na co má rada gesty,
takže tento bod
číslo šest je
týkající se tady
tohoto,
řeknu tady
tohoto do vybavení
a bod číslo sedm
mě to,
co jsem já komentoval,
to je vlastně
ten dar
těm krajským hasičům,
omlouvám se
za mou chybu.
Poprosím ještě
náměstka
Mirka Chalánka.
Tore,
já jenom v rychlosti,
určitě se tím
budeme zabývat,
jestli tam vzniká
nějaký pojistný nárok
jako v těch věcech.
Jinak ten rozklad,
rozklad komu
na co dáváme peníze
je rozpočtové opatření,
které jsme schválovali
tabulka číslo 13,
nás, rozpočtové opatření
34, tak se tam vidíte
ten rozklad jako
co na co je
i s komentářem
na co je to použité.
Morská děkuji za to doplnění
a jsou k tomu nějaké dotazy?
Do diskuze se nikdo nehlásí,
tak teda prosím pojďme
hlasovat
bod číslo 6.
pro 35.
Materiál číslo 6
byl přijat.
Materiál číslo 7
je poskytnutí
finančního daru
tentokrát už,
jak jsem říkal,
z Asickému záchrannému zboru
z Línského kraje.
Tak vysvětlení
už máme za sebou.
Tak poprosím,
jestli jsou k tomu
nějaké dotazy.
Poprosím pana Mitáčka.
Děkuji, pane primátre,
za slovo,
drahé kolegyně Kulagové.
Já jsem si to chtěl nechat
v to vystoupení svoje
k oběma bodům,
samozřejmě jenom jednou,
abych se pořád
nepřihlašoval.
Tak jenom tady
doplnění předchozí diskuze,
samozřejmě vyslaná jednotka
zasahující pod jednotným
velením hasičského záchranného zboru,
to znamená jednotka
i dobrovolných hasičů,
tak její zásah
samozřejmě žádné pojistce
nepodlejá a škody,
které vzniknou,
jsou na úkor
toho zásahu státu
nebo města.
Jenom taková technikália.
Nicméně teď se ale vrátím
k tomu,
jakým způsobem
se přistoupili
k podpoře těch hasičů
a protože
k němu připojili
svůj komentář
a připojujete
i své finance,
tak musím na to reagovat.
Vývoj pro mě osobně
vzhledem k tomu,
co jsme tady měli
na minulém zastupitelstvu
a následně město
bylo vystaveno
vlastně
událostí,
která je natolik mimořádná,
že nemá v historii
této země obdoby,
to znamená požár
výškové budovy
a následně její zřícení,
nemáme takovou zkušenost,
tak už v době
toho zásahu
jsem byl ve spojení
s panem Hejtmanem,
s ředitelem
hasičů krajských
a snažil jsem se pro ně
získat finanční podporu
a mým cílem bylo
získat podporu
ve výši jednoho milionu korun.
Město k tomu přistoupilo
a přistupuje dnes
s návrhem
poloviny této částky.
Hejtmanství na sebe
vzalo ten zbytek
do toho jednoho milionu korun
s tím, že ještě k tomu
připočítávám ten příspěvek,
který byl na minulém zastupitelstvu.
A protože to není malá částka,
je to velká symbolika
a velký dar,
tak je na místě vám poděkovat samozřejmě.
Nebudu dneska vůbec komentovat to,
jakým způsobem ten proces proběhl,
nezaslouží si to dnešní
poslední zastupitelstvo
ani ta důstojná chvíle toho,
že pro někoho je to možná
poslední zastupitelstvo
v jeho politické kariéře.
Proto mi dovolte,
abych vám tedy poděkoval
za tento přístup,
děkuji za podporu hasičů,
za náhradu věcí,
které tam nechali,
ztratili a nebo byly poškozené.
V skutečnosti je to,
co jste už nastínili
v tom popisu toho procesu,
že ano, hasiči mohou být
sanováni za ztrátu této techniky
nebo vybavení,
nicméně ten proces je poměrně dlouhý,
bývá až součástí
následných rozpočtů a návrhů.
To znamená,
tento náš přístup,
tato rychlá pomoc
je vlastně sanace a možnost,
aby si tu techniku pořídili
a dovybavili se co možná nejdříve.
Takže ještě jednou za mě poděkování.
Jsem rád,
že se pro mě osobně
i pro hasiče podařilo naplnit
ten slibovaný dar
v té výši toho jednoho milionu korun.
Bavím se o profesionálních hasičích
a poděkování tedy
jak radě města,
tak radě žlínského kradě.
Potažmo dnešním zastupitelům BOKUT.
Toto schválíme.
Děkuju.
Morská děkuju za ten přístup.
Každopádně,
abych jenom chtěl říct,
že vlastně o tom jenom zastupitelstva
se řebně uběhla ještě nějaká doba
včetně kusů práce.
To znamená,
byli jsme také jednání s hasičem
a nějakým způsobem
jsme si vyříkali ty věci,
které probíhaly.
Takže myslím si,
že ta situace je
mezi městem a krajskými hasiči
na konstruktivní,
stabilní úrovni.
A je potřeba říct si,
že krajské hasiče
jsme například v loňském roce
potvořili také částkou
kolem milionu korun a tak dál.
To znamená,
myslím si,
že město Zlín vůči krajským hasičům
vychází dlouhodobě vstříc,
minimálně v tomto hlavním období,
kdy ty částky jsou pravidelně,
pravidelně prostě v minimální část,
takovým těch 500 tisíc
a letos to v tom součtu
bude vlastně také.
Takže myslím si,
že ta spolupráce je dobrá.
Prostě některé věci se,
když to řekl mu,
neúplně povedly,
na druhou stranu jsme si je vyříkali,
takže za mě pokračujeme
normálně konstruktivně dál.
Takže myslím si,
že je to jedině správně.
Poprosím pana Juráše.
Dobrý den, dámy a pánové.
Děkuji panu primátorovi za slovo.
My si samozřejmě vážíme
té podpory ze strany města,
kterou poskytuje
hasičskému záchrannému zboru,
ať už jeho profesionální části
nebo zboru dobrovolných hasičů,
které financuje město Zdlín.
Zásah byl z naší strany
vnímán jako velmi profesionální,
byl dobrý.
Ta zmínka o náhradě škody,
já si snad dovolím drobně
pana Mitáčka poupravit.
Protože to není tak,
jak říká v zásadě.
Ano, samozřejmě,
že si platíme daně právě proto,
aby jsme tam nelítali z křížbary vody
a nehasili tu věc sami,
ale známe také excesici protiprávnost.
Inými slovy, zapálíš-li si to sám,
pak po tobě budeme chtít tu škodu,
kterou jsi způsobil.
Skočíš-li do rozbouřené řeky,
aby jsi si zaplaval,
tak po tobě budeme chtít ty náklady,
které nám vzniknou
z hlediska integrovaného záchranného systému.
Zde to ještě rozlišeno nemáme.
To znamená, nevíme,
zda asi, či budou žádat
z hlediska té protiprávnosti
nějakou náhradu,
která byla způsobena případně excesem,
ať už vlastníka budou výčin
některého z těch uživatelů.
A to je jenom to doplnění.
Děkuji moc.
Děkuji za to doplnění.
Já možná mám pro vás informaci.
Vyšetřování samozřejmě probíhá,
jsou vyšetřovány různé scénáře
a předpoklad je,
že nebude to vyšetřování
ukončeno dříve než v březnu příštěho roku,
protože samozřejmě ta situace
není úplně jednoduchá.
A vlastně tím,
že se ta budova zřítila,
tak samozřejmě jakékoliv důkazy
jsou v těch sutinách
a o to víc těžko prokazutelné
u případného soudu.
Takže situace není úplně jednoduchá
v tomto hledu,
každopádně za mě to hlavní je,
že se nikomu nic nestalo,
což považuji nikoli za malý,
ale za velký zázrak
a myslím si,
že za to zaslouží všichni
velké poděkování
a i poděkování,
jak se říká,
trošku tomu štěstí,
že v těch situacích,
kdy padaly kusy objektů,
že to nikomu netrefilo,
takže myslím si,
že velké poděkování na místě
a věřím tomu,
že zase nás to všechny
posune o kousek dál
až už přístupu
mnoha věcem
a věřím tomu,
že se v budoucnu
s takovým požáry nepotkáme,
že se asi nepřijeme nic jiného.
Vyská děkuji.
Poprosím
náměstka Mirka Chalánka.
Já děkuji za slovo,
paní primátore.
Já jenom,
protože vlastně
v tomto,
v této sestavě
tady sedíme
naposledy,
tak si dovolím
takovou bilanci toho,
protože minulé jsme se bavili,
kdokoliv dává peněz
krajským hasičům
a tak dál.
Tak v momentě,
kdy schválíme tento materiál
zahrnujících 500 tisíc,
tak za toto volební období
jsme krajským hasičům,
krajským hasičům
poskud ty dary
vyvýšit
1 372 tisíc korun.
Dobrá, děkuji za to doplnění,
což potvrduje to,
co jsem říkal,
že jsme rozhodně víc
než na půl milinu ročně
a takže si myslím,
že určitě nemáme
za co stydět.
Poprosím,
pana,
ještě poprosím nám
jezka pan Hlavrát,
jenom zkazatechnickou.
Dobré odpoledne,
já jsem jenom hlasoval,
jsem samozřejmě
pro tento dár
a jenom se to nezaznamenalo
v tom záznamu,
takže prosím,
aby to můj
můj souhlas samozřejmě
s poskytuním tohoto daru,
aby to bylo upraveno
v tom hlasování.
Děkuji.
Jo, to se týká
bodu číslo 6,
prosím,
že se to asi
dáme si pozorat,
co to zaznamená,
případně,
že by tam nějaká
technická závada,
tak to určitě budeme řešit.
Poprosím,
pana Česmíra Vančuru.
Děkuji, pane primátore,
já myslím,
že v tom děkování,
že bychom mohli poděkovat
nebo měli poděkovat
také občanům,
kterých si ten požar dotknul.
Některý poměrně výrazně
omezili jich podnikání.
Myslím,
že to v celku
zvládli dobře,
takže určitě patří
i jim uznání.
Děkuji.
Určitě ano,
já si myslím,
že my bych chtěl
to děkování
mít cožká toho požaru
z celé té čtvrté budovy.
Já si myslím,
že je na místě.
můžeme s lidícem se podívat,
no se rád děkovali to,
že už ta budova je úplně dole,
že už to nikoho neohrožuje.
To taky můžeme říct,
že je tak velice dobře,
že to se to půjde
za tak krátkou chvíli.
Myslím si,
že té práce odvedené
od začátku
až do současné doby
je tam opravdu hodně.
A věřím tomu,
že já vždycká jsem se vyjadřoval
i do těch médií,
když se na to všichni měs čišní ptali,
tak já říkám,
že jediné, co si přeji,
je, aby tím,
že už se nikomu nic nestalo,
za což jsem rád,
takže v této lokalitě
nevznikne další prluka
a bude tam co nejdříve
opravdu nějaká stavba,
která bude ku prospěchu
rozvoje města Zlína,
ať už občanů,
tak podnikání.
A poprosím náměstka
pana Wolfa.
Děkuji.
Já bych možná ještě doplnil
tu podporu HZS,
není jenom ta finanční,
peněžní,
ale aktuálně máme
před memorandem
z lesama města Zlína,
které budou vlastně
moct hasiči využívat
při kurzu
vlastně na motorovou pilu,
takže je to docela náročné
jak časově,
tak na počet těch zhozených stromů,
na počet instruktorů,
takže je to takový
jeden z těch věcí,
co my se jim snažíme víc říct,
aby nemuseli jezdit někde
na kromě řízko
nebo na hostínské vrchy,
ale budou vlastně tady ty kurzy
dělat přímo ve Zlíně
na našich lesích okolí vlastně,
jak kdyby té jejich centrální stanice.
Dobrá, moc krát děkuju
za potvrzení
a za informace,
jak hledám potvrzení to,
že ta spolupráce funguje.
My jsme za to rádi
a myslím si,
že nikdo si nepřeje nic jiného,
než aby ta spolupráce
se složkama
integrovanou záchrannou systému
byla velice dobrá
a zároveň,
abychom je ideálně
nikdo nikdy nepotřebovali.
Tak,
nikdo další se diskuse nehlásí,
poprosím,
pojďme hlasovat
o materiál číslo 7.
Pro 36.
Materiál číslo 7
byl přijat.
Materiál číslo 8
jsou výsledky
hospodaření
obchodních společností
a obecně
prospešných společností
s majetkou účastí
města Zlína.
Jsou k tomu dotazy.
Nikdo se do diskuze nehlásí,
prosím,
pojďme hlasovat
materiál číslo 8.
Pro 25.
Materiál byl přijat.
Materiál číslo 9
jsou výsledky
hospodaření
k 30. 6.
2026.
Příspěchových organizací
s řizovaným,
s řizovaným
statutárním
městem Zlínem.
Jsou k tomu dostazy.
Poprosím pana Dudáka.
Děkuji za slovo,
pane primátore.
Má největší obava
je logicky
hledně dopravního podniku,
který je náš
největší,
finančně nejvíce
podporovaná společnost.
Vidím,
že se letos
ten hospodářský výsledek
zmenšil
o 9 milionů
vůči
prvnímu polovětí
roku
25.
pět
a při tom
výnosi
rostly
asi o nějakých
pět procent.
Významně tam
rostou osobní náklady.
Já jsem
úplně sem nedohledal
teď
informací,
kolik
my jsme tam
dali tu naši podporu,
ať formou
příspěvku,
nebo
dokrytí
prokazatelné
ztráty,
jestli je stejná
jako v prvním
polovětí
loňského roku,
pak když
tomu tak je,
tak jestli je tam
nějaká aktivita
na úspory,
protože úspory
vidíme
v pohledu
investic,
že na energie
klesla
zhruba
4 miliony,
což je
pravděpodobně
dané
elektrofikaci,
prostě
elektrickým
pohonem,
několik
těmi
spalovacími
motory,
ale úspory
jiné
tam nevidím.
Děkuji.
Já poprosím
náměstka
Mirka Chalánka.
My v tuto chvíli
to bereme
jako průběžné
hodnocení
těch
toho
hospodářského
výsledku.
Já bych řekl,
že nepočítáme,
že by stráta
se pohla
mimo schválený
rozpočet
a v tuto chvíli
ani nemáme
takové indicie.
Dobrá,
moc krát
děkuju
za to doplnění.
Níkdo další
se do diskuze
nehlásí,
tak
prosím,
pojďme hlasovat
materiál číslo 9.
pro 27,
materiál číslo 9
byl přijat.
Materiál číslo 10
je změna číslo 11
z řizovací listiny
naší ZOO.
jsou k tomu dotazy.
Níkdo se do diskuze
nehlásí,
tak prosím,
pojďme hlasovat
materiál číslo 10.
Pro 35,
materiál číslo 10
byl přijat.
Materiál číslo 11
je projekt
podpora řízení
IT a jazlínské aglomerace.
jsou k tomu
další dotazy.
Níkdo se do diskuze
nehlásí,
tak prosím,
pojďme hlasovat
materiál číslo 11.
Pro 25,
materiál číslo 11
byl přijat.
Materiál číslo 12
týkající se
implementace
integrované územní
strategie
zlínské aglomerace
a tradiční materiál,
který tady mýváme,
jsou k tomu dotazy.
Nikdo se do diskuze
nehlásí,
tak prosím,
pojďme hlasovat
materiál číslo 12.
Pro 26,
materiál číslo 12
byl přijat.
Materiál číslo 13
je jeden z prvních bod
týkající se
změny územního plánu
číslo 7,
kdy tímto bodem
rozhodujeme o rozdělení
vlastně té změny,
kterou my jsme schvalovali
na minulém zastupitelstvu,
že schvalujeme,
že se změna udělá,
to znamená,
schvalovali jsme pořízení,
ale vlastně my jsme to
jako v celku,
takže teďka rozhodujeme
o tom,
že se to rozdělí
na jednotlivé části
ABT.
Jsou k tomu dotazy?
Nikdo se do diskuze nehlásí,
tak prosím pojďme hlasovat
materiál číslo 13.
Pro 30,
materiál číslo 13
byl přijat.
Materiál číslo 14
je účení zastupitele
ke spolupráci
s pořizovatelem
pro pořízení změny.
Já bych tady jenom poprosil
o drobnou změnu
v usnesení,
protože vzhledem k tomu,
že máme poslední zastupitelstvo
a blíží se nám volby,
tak my v současné chvíli
tam máme napsané,
že se to má týkat
konkrétně
pana náměstka Pavla Brady
a já jenom poprosím,
aby se to zobecnilo
do té podoby,
že to bude člen
zastupitelstva,
který bude mít právě
to dané pověření,
abychom to pak nemuseli
se hned měnit
na všem dalším zastupitelstvu.
Takže jenom poprosím,
myslím si,
že je to logické
a že se to takto zobecní
a není to nic proti ničemu
a uvidíme,
kdo to bude mít
v tom další
vloubní období v gesty.
Poprosím pana Juráše.
Děkuju, pane primátore.
Já to jel odlehčím.
My jsme si taky říkali,
jestli víte něco,
co nevíme my
z hlediska nadcházejících voleb,
ale třeba zpřeba Pavloji
se to podaří
i vzhledem,
myslím na kandidátce.
Jak bude to pověření vypadat?
Jako vybere ho rada
nebo budeme znovu
o tom hlasovat
jako zastupitelstvo?
Vypadá to tak,
že vždycky
na ústavujícím zastupitelstvu
se schvaluje
vlastně,
se schvalují
jednotlivé posty
v radě,
včetně gestí.
Takže tím pádem
vlastně u někoho,
některého člena rady
potažmo se může stát,
že může být dohoda,
že to bude některý ze zastupitelů,
tak vlastně v rámci
tady té dohody
té budoucí koalice
se řekne,
kdo bude mít věsty
územní plán
a jenom říkám obecněji,
není to,
pokud vím já,
jenom svázané
s vyloženě přímo
se členský v radě,
ale
bude o tom hlasovat
potom budoucí zastupitelstvo
města Zína
a ta geste
vlastně bude přidělená
zastupitelstvem.
Poprosím,
jestli jsou k tomu
nějaké další dotazy.
Nikdo se v diskuze nehlásí,
tak prosím,
pojďme hlasovat
materiál číslo 14
tou úpravou,
která jenom
zobecní
toho,
říkám,
toho člověka
budoucího
tady to my v GESCI.
Pro 33,
materiál číslo 14
byl přijat.
materiál číslo 15
je schvální zadání
změny číslo 7a.
7a,
jak jsem už říkal,
v rámci diskuze občanů
se týká pouze
textových částí.
Jsou k tomu dotazy.
Nikdo se v diskuze nehlásí.
Poprosím,
pana Jandu.
Mohl bych tam mít
střed zájmu,
tak hlasím střed zájmu,
prosím.
Jo,
já si myslím,
že střed zájmu
bude až v tom dalším materiálu,
ale to nevadí,
prostě obecně to,
obecně beru,
že je nahlášen střed zájmu
k bodům týkajících se
územního plánu.
Děkuju moc.
Tak,
nikdo další se do diskuze nehlásí,
tak prosím,
pojďme hlasovat
materiál číslo 7a.
Pro 26,
materiál číslo 15 byl přijat.
Materiál číslo 16
se týká
schvální zadání změny číslo 7b,
to znamená,
to jsou ty jednotlivé podněty,
které nám došly od občanů,
případně firm,
a jenom tady předem
hlásím,
že se nám tady stala potom chybka
při překlápění materiálu,
to znamená,
jak bych poprosil,
že my máme v usnesení,
že bod římská 7
zamítáme,
tak tento bod,
prosím,
jenom upravíme
v rámci materiálu zastupitelstva,
že tento bod máme schválit,
jedná se o městský pozemek
východně od Ližarského svahu,
abyste viděli,
o co se konkrétně jedná.
Takže ten vlastně byl
celou brán,
že bude schválený
k té změně,
ale s nějakým nedopatřením
se nám tady stalo,
že v rámci návrhu usnesení
je, že se zamítá,
takže prosím,
jenom tady ta římská 7
se přesouvá do usnesení,
které schvalujeme.
Poprosím,
jestli jsou k tomu nějaké dotazy,
nikdo se do diskuze nehlásí,
tak poprosím ještě
náměstka panu Labradu.
Ještě jednou dobré dopoledne,
tak jenom doplním pana primátora
v těch materiálech,
které jste dostali do zastupitelstva.
Je to na straně 214 a 215
bod římským 7
a je to v zájmu města Zlína
plocha u Hližarského areálu,
kterou měníme
na plochy smíšené obytné centrální.
Dobrá, děkuji.
Poprosím pane Juráše.
Pane primátore,
já nemám nic k tomuto bodu,
jenom jsem chtěl,
zaznamenávám,
že i po čtyřech letech
ostřílení matadoři
začínají využívat
procedurální poznámku
k tomu,
aby se dostali do diskuze.
Tak prosím,
procedurální poznámka
slouží k tomu,
že to je poznámka k proceduře.
Jiným slovy,
mám technickou poznámku,
není to správně
podle jednacího řádu,
nebo chci ukončit diskuzi,
přednikam nevede.
Jinak prosím,
přihlášení se hlasem
respektujeme pouřádí
přes řečníků.
Děkuji moc.
Jasné,
já si myslím,
že už to dneska
určitě všichni zvládnou správně.
Tak,
nikdo další
se do diskuze nehlásí,
takže prosím,
pojďme hlasovat
materiál číslo 16.
Pro 24,
materiál číslo 16 byl přijat.
Materiál číslo 17
je materiál schvální změny
územního plánu číslo 7c,
to znamená,
tam se jedná
o tu koncepční změnu
vycházející ze strategie z lín 100
a věřím tomu,
že to bude změna,
která opravdu
bude výrazně
ku prospěchu
a řekne rozvoje
a investic
na území našeho města.
Jsou k tomu dotazy.
Nikdo se do diskuze nehlásí,
takže prosím,
pojďme hlasovat
materiál číslo 17.
Pro 24,
materiál číslo 17
17 byl přijat.
Materiál číslo 18
se týká pozemku
majetkoprávních úkonů.
Jsou k tomu dotazy.
Nikdo se do diskuze nehlásí,
takže já vás
poprosím,
pojďme hlasovat
materiál číslo 18.
pro 24,
materiál číslo 18
byl přijat.
Materiál číslo 19
se týká rozvoje lokality
Březnická,
kdy k dnešnímu dní
je smlouva podepsána
ze strany
navrhovaného vítěze
s tím,
že vlastně
začínáme
právem stavby,
to znamená,
jsou tam pojistky
k tomu,
aby v případě,
že se cokoliv
bude
v budoucnu dít,
tak abychom
ten pozemek
neprodávali
hned v dnešnímu dní,
ale až potom,
co samozřejmě
ta stavba
se začne realizovat.
Je to jedna z nejvýznamnějších
v současné době
vlastně investit
s externím subjektem
na území města Zdýna
a cena
v současné chvíli
je
356 milionů korun,
pokud si pamatuju správně,
včetně DPH.
Investor
aktuálně
tvrdil,
že do pěti let
bych chtěl mít hotovo.
Tak uvidíme,
jestli se mu to podaří.
Držím za sebem,
držím palce,
protože ten povolovací proces
nebude jednoduchý.
Otvírám diskuzi
tady v materiálu číslo 19.
Poprosím Pavla Simkoviče.
Pěkné dopoledne
vám všem.
Já možná na úvod
jenom takovou zmínku,
kterou jsem neměl
u programu,
protože jsem nechtěl zdržovat,
ale už samotné materiály
v řádném programu
byly celkem náročné
na prostorování zvládnutí
za 14 dnů.
V zápěti tam přistane
desátého materiál
na velké kino
pro studování.
Včera znovu přistane materiál
kontrolního orgánu.
Nemyslím si,
že tohle je šťastné
a pro poslední zastupitelstvo
už vůbec nešťastné.
Možná něco z toho
mohlo klidně počkat
až po volbách
nebo k tomu slad.
Třeba další zastupitelstvo.
Co se týká březnické,
tak já možná na úvod bych řekl,
že rozumím tomu,
že rozvoj města
bez nějakého
seokromého kapitálu
investorů
asi není úplně možný
a vidím,
dajadu už toho skutečnost,
protože samozřejmě doba,
ve které se nacházíme,
je hodně turbulentní
a ta změna,
kterou tady chceme realizovat
na pozemcích města
je celkem velmi významná
a v principu jsem
v podstatě proti rychlému
se zbavování možná majetku
a pozemků obzvlášť,
tak ale na druhou stanu chápu,
že možná jiné cesty,
dejme tomu, není.
Ale o to více,
pokud se na to vrhneme,
bych byl rád,
kdyby ty pojistky byly
co nejlepší, maximální
a takové,
aby to město
v tomto ohledu bylo kryto,
protože zkušenosti s torzy
a s různými nedostavenými stavbami
a podobně,
zvlášť na našich pozemcích
a v lokalitě Březnické
máme celkem velké.
A já úplně si nejsem jistý,
jestli se to takhle stoprocentně děje.
Je to jedna z věcí,
která mě k tomu například vede,
je to, jak se změnila
smlouva o smlouvi budoucí,
která byla původně ve výzvě
a jakou teď máme schvalovat
tam nějakých 21 změn
a z těch 21 změn 19
je velmi silně ve prospěch investora
nebo pardon toho kupujícího
a některé takové,
že v podstatě dávají im možnost
si ještě rozšířit
a vylepšit tu situaci,
která připodně u té výzvy byla,
protože jsme tam nějakým způsobem
zrušili omezující prvek
na co se týká plochy,
rozšíření plochy z 5% původně.
Pokud by to bylo navíc,
tak to bylo za úplatu.
Teď to posouváme někam dál,
což mě trošičku nějak překvapilo.
Budu upřímný.
Já bych poprosil tady pana Hermana,
protože to je vlastně jednatel
z lindského rozvoje společnosti,
kterou jsme vlastně řídili
za účelem právě té komunikace
s těmi developery,
aby se nám více dařilo
rozvíjet tady
ty soukromé investice,
protože tak, jak bylo řečeno,
my se určitě nebráníme do budoucna,
ať už se bude si dokoliv,
aby město investovalo samo,
proto jsme právě tuto společnost
také zřídili,
ale tady by to byl napoprvé,
když to řeknu,
obrovský krajíc,
jak se říká,
takže proto jsem tu i tu důvodu
toho času,
abychom tady vůbec nečekali
pořád na to,
až se něco stane,
tak jsme svolili tuto cestu
vlastně stejní důvody
u toho bojněckého rybníka,
když předběhnu
na ten další materiál.
Každopádně já poprosím
pana Hermana,
aby vám sdělil informace
vlastně k tomu,
k těm změnám,
tak, jak bylo řečeno,
jestli tam jsou limity,
nebo nejsou limity,
co se říká nějakého toho zvětšení,
jak si tady řekneme,
protože my jsme celou tu soutěž
výrazně svazovali k tomu,
aby tam nevzniklo něco,
co my nechteme,
a v rámci těch jednání
potom určitým změnám
došlo,
ale nikoliv takovým,
které by vlastně
něco umožňovaly
v nějaké volné ruce,
takže každopádně
poprosím pana Hermana,
ať nám to upřesní,
jak to máme,
ať to tady zazní,
tak jak to tam je
a to, co vlastně
ten developer v případě může.
Morská děkuji.
Dobrý den, dámy a pánové.
Já možná nejprve řeknu
takové ta vůbec
ty obecné ochranné mechanizmy,
které tam máme,
aby se s tou nestala,
tak jak tady padlo nějaká,
abychom neměli druhé torzo,
když to tak řeknu.
To znamená,
zaprvé vůbec
u samotného výběru,
s kým to budeme dělat,
jsme měli velmi přísná
jak finanční,
tak vlastně i
know-how kritéria.
To znamená,
rovnou jsme to měli
vlastně nastavené tak,
aby to v podstatě,
aby ta kritéria splnil
urbanistický developer,
který něco podobného
už dělá.
To znamená,
rovnou vlastně
v těch kvalifikační kritériích
jsme vyloučili ty,
kteří by na to
buď to finančně neměli,
ale zároveň i ty,
kteří nemají,
vlastně s urbanistickým celkem,
kteří nemají zkušenost,
protože opravdu
development solitárních budov
a development urbanistických celků
jsou opravdu dvě úplně jiné disciplíny
a my jsme vlastně chtěli někoho,
kdo na tom finančně nevykrvácí,
někoho, kdo má takovou reputaci,
že umí narejzovat ty peníze
vlastně i od těch
profesionálních subjektů
a někoho, kdo už má dneska to know-how.
Aby nám tam nevzniklo něco
úplně jiného, než co chceme,
tak vlastně my ani nepřevádíme
vlastně celé ty pozemky.
My vlastně převádíme
jenom ty stopy
vlastně nadzemních a podzemních staveb
a všechno to, co je vlastně mezi tím,
kde my chceme, aby se stavělo,
to znamená tam, kde nechceme,
aby se stavělo,
tak to zůstává městu.
Za další, my potom vlastně
i samotné ty převody těch pozemků
vlastně uskutečňujeme teprve v okamžiku,
kdy už se ty jednotlivé stavby,
kdy jsou odsouhlasené,
myslím jako z hlediska stavebního úřadu,
a kdy už vlastně
jsou i v určité stádiu výstavby.
To znamená, když už je vlastně jasné,
že tam opravdu vznikne
to, co tam vzniknout má.
Další věc, kterou si tam velmi
jako striktně hlídáme,
tak je vlastně ten celkový urbanismus,
protože ten urbanismus,
když se podíváme na to,
já to nazývám pracovně nové centrum,
protože jsme opravdu jako blízko centra,
tak vlastně my si tam hlídáme
velmi striktně
ty základní věci,
které vzešly samozřejmě
jako z hlav urbanistů a architektů.
A sice hlídáme,
jestli si vybavujete,
jak je ulice u zimního stadionu,
tam si vlastně velmi hlídáme
klasickou uliční čáru,
to znamená, tam jsme v přímce,
protože to dává nějakou logiku.
Zároveň tam vlastně
klesáme s tím terénem,
s těmi budovami,
a zároveň, ačkoliv už nemusíme,
podle aktuální legislativy,
tak sklápíme fasády.
To je zase kvůli oslunění,
protože všichni jsme to kritizovali,
ono to jako trošičku logiku to dávalo,
teda ta předchozí právní úprava.
Co se týče urbanismu
směrem k ulici Březnické,
tak tam naopak je ta uliční čára,
protože jak samotná ulice vlastně zatáčí,
tak tam ta uliční čáru
zase ale v pravidelném rytmu vlastně
jako měníme,
tak abychom vlastně takovou,
jak kdyby teďka to vyzní jako zvláště,
takovou jako uskočenou uliční čáru,
abychom tam prostě dodrželi,
protože to vlastně bude ta brána
do toho města
a tam vlastně potom ta hmota i graduje,
tak aby vlastně bylo vidět,
že opravdu výždím do nějakého
jako významného sídelního celku.
Co se týče těch možností
na nějaké navýšení ploch,
tak v té smlouvě je tam jedna změna,
která ale je celkem logická
a sice, že my jsme tam chtěli
spoplatnit vlastně v tom původním textu
nějaké navýšení plochy,
ale na druhou stranu
dneska se mění technologie
a to navýšení těch ploch
totiž může vzejít i vevnitř
těch perimetrů, těch budov.
A toto by nebylo spravedlivé,
abychom my zkasírovali,
protože vlastně to není naše zásluha.
Toto je vlastně zásluha know-how
toho developera a jeho architektů,
statiků a jeho stavebních dodavatelů,
protože pokud prostě tam najdou
svoji jako další plochu
z hlediska jako výpočtu HPP,
to znamená, že to je z hlediska
konstrukčních prvků,
tak to je prostě know-how toho dodavatele.
My jim neprodáváme víc,
než za co je kasírujeme teďka na začátku.
Vím, že kroutíte hlavou,
tak povídejte.
Já bych ještě jenom poprosil
o dovětek k tomu,
jakým způsobem máme ochráněné
případně rozšíření těch budov.
Jestli tam je limit teda,
nebo ta budova může být do 10 metrů širší
a vznikne, jestli tam má monoblog a podobně.
Ne, monoblog tam opravdu
v žádném případě vzniknout nemůže,
protože tam je závazek
dodržovat ty perimetry.
Není tam vůbec možnost
třeba vykročit směrem
k těm, směrem vlastně
k ulici Úzimního stadionu
nebo k ulici Dřeznická.
A je tam vlastně jenom možnost
zase tak, aby to
navýšení nemohlo být bráno
jako an-blok na
vlastně celý ten celek,
tak je vlastně to rozděleno
na jednotlivé budovy.
Tak, aby tam vlastně
ten případný technologický,
protože takhle zase,
proč to tam je vždycky důležité,
to je vlastně ta,
rávníci to znají,
ta otázka, kvůj bono,
protože my se dneska blížíme
vlastně do nové éry stavebníctví.
Aby se vůbec mohlo stavět
do budoucna,
tak se zase bude stavět modulárně.
Logicky, protože nejsou
a nebudou lidé,
kteří by sdíli přímo na té stavbě,
ale budou prostě spíše stroje,
kteří budou chystat prefabrikáty
v továrnách
a ty se budou na té stavbě
už potom jenom kompletovat.
To znamená,
ale že potom zase to bude
v nějakých standardizovaných rozměrech.
To znamená,
k tomu určitá flexibilita
být musí,
ale myslím,
že je tam velmi mírná,
protože zase pořád
je ten základ,
že vlastně tam,
ačkoliv by to bylo,
samozřejmě by se tam dalo
dát mnohem více metrů čtvereční,
kdyby to byly monobloky jednoznačně,
ale to není ta vůle města.
To znamená,
proto je tam pořád vlastně
kladený důraz
na ten středový prostor,
takovou tu podlouhou pět setů
a kladený i na to vlastně,
aby ta oblast byla průchozí
i v tom východozápadním směru,
když to tak řeknu.
Dobrá, děkuji.
Já poprosím ještě pan Cimíkovi
ještě reagovat?
Já s vámi souhlasím,
že v rámci uliční linie
územního stadionu
je to ošetřeno velmi silně,
u Březnické už méně.
Zméně já tam čtu,
že při navýšení
mimo stávající půdorys
o více než 5%,
můžu oplatit pokutu.
A pak jenom ještě navíc za část,
která je nad těch 5%.
Původně tam bylo 9 000 za každý nárůst,
takže to jsme vyšli v stříst.
A nic jsem se nedočetl o limitu,
takže co když to bude o 20%,
technologie to umožňují
a dráme z půdorysu.
V posledním patře to můžu rozširit
možná až 2,5x, 3x?
Je to ošetřeno?
Myslím si, že ne.
Takže tady rozhodně dáváme
velkou výhodu tomu investorovi.
Navíc, když půjdu dál ještě,
tak jsme ustoupili velmi silně od pokut.
Nebo od, řekl si, pateb.
Kdy se dostáváme na maximální částku 15%
a navíc součet všech pokut.
To znamená, když to přeženu
a chtěl by být jako...
A já to se vás nechci podsouvat
ani vnucovat, nic.
Žádnému člověku, někomu,
kdo to chce stavit.
A do extrému, když půjdu,
tak já za 15%
si v podstatě tam trošičku
můžu vytěžit výrazně více,
než kolik bylo v té nabídce.
A možná, kdyby tohle věděli
více investoři úvodně v té nabídce,
tak by se možná jich přihlásilo více.
A možná i s jinými podmínkami.
Tak proto se ptám,
proč jsme ústopovali takhle daleko.
A to ještě nemluvíme o tom,
že jsme tam snížili indexaci cen,
to znamená, že jsme zvýhodnili
ve získa z plátek
a ještě jsme to zastrpovali
v 5% inflací.
V době, kdy netušíme,
co bude za 5 let za 6 let z inflací.
Takže ptám se,
proč jsme šli takhle výhodně na ruku.
Tak odpověď je celkem jednoduchá.
Když jsme dělali první...
Protože my jsme tuto soutěž
jsme dělali ve dvou kolech.
V prvním kole jsme vlastně dávali
tvrdé smouvy
a odpověď z trhu byla taková,
je to pro nás příliš svazující,
máte tam příliš silné sankce,
z tohoto důvodu se nepřihlašujeme.
Proto jsme vlastně dali tu možnost
do toho druhého kola.
Zvýšili jsme tam teda minimální cenu,
protože jsme tam jako rovnou,
jsme tam dali už potom tu minimální cenu přes...
Respektive dali jsme minimální cenu
300 milionů korun.
Ale zároveň už jsme tam právě dali tu možnost,
dobrá, pojďte nám dát
strukturální připomínky ke smouvě,
tak, abychom prostě mě...
Tak, abychom mohli se spolehnout na to,
nebo mohli mít nějaké odůvodněné očekávání,
že dostaneme nabídky
nebo nabídku, která bude
nad těch 300 milionů korun.
Samozřejmě, že když jsme
toto nabídku dostali,
byly tam ty strukturální připomínky,
tak jsme se o nich museli i bavit.
Já se přiznám, že mám docela dlouhou praxi
z hlediska uzavírání dlouhých smluv
a přiznám se, že třeba
nějaké to grace period,
takové to období odpuštění té inflace
je naprosto standardní věc
a zakepování roční inflace
na 5%,
samozřejmě bylo to jedno z těch
sporných bodů, o kterých jsme se
dlouhou dobu bavili.
Na druhou stranu, těch 5%
je vlastně nějaký kompromis,
ke kterému jsme došli, protože
cíl Národní banky
je kolem 2%,
když se podíváme historicky,
ale když se to zprůměrujeme
i z hlediska vlastně těch výkivů,
které byly ať už po roce 2008
nebo kolem roku
2001,
tak vlastně jsme
ani v těchto velkých výkivech
jsme nezažívali nějakou
hyperinflaci, která by šla
tady nad
tuto procento.
To znamená, ano, byl to
kompromis, protože zase
díváme se na to, dostáváme
cenu, ze kterou jsme
spokojeni, protože ta cena opravdu,
bych řekl, že
odpovídá
opravdu jako velmi
prestižním
pozemkům.
To znamená,
udělali jsme tento
kompromis, abychom byli schopni
vůbec tu transakci dotáhnout.
Dobrá, děkuju.
Poprosím pana Vančuru.
Děkuju, pane primátore.
Já přepustím svojom nejdříve
mému kolegovi, aby jsme udrželi
kontext. Děkuju.
Dobrá, děkuju. Tak pověstním
pane Ibráše a potom dám
slovo panu Vančurovi.
Děkuju, pane primátore, za slovo.
Já děkuju panu Simkovičovi,
že to téma otevřel.
Nás na tom trápí trochu
jiné věci, než
o kterých mluvil.
Já to zjednoduším a
budu se snažit být co nejvíce
srozumitelný, to téma
není jednoduché.
To znamená,
15 let fixujeme
4-stránkovou smlouvou
o právu stavby.
To samo o sobě ve mně trochu vyvolalo údiv,
tak jsem se začal dívat nad tím,
jak tu situaci řešíme.
A my máme trošičku dva problémy.
Ten první problém říká,
že nijak neomezujeme
samotný převod práva
stavby jako věcného práva.
Jinými slovy současný investor
může to právo stavby
převést sám,
bez dalšího, my ho v tom nijak neomezujeme.
Tím, že převede právo
stavby, přestávají vůči němu
působit závazky ze smlouvy o smlouvy
budoucí.
To je číslo jedna.
Číslo dvě.
V právu stavby si nijak nevyhrazujeme
změnu účelu stavby.
Jinými slovy,
to, co se uvnitř toho práva stavby,
u té bubliny hmotně postaví,
to nesixujeme.
Takže situace,
jak já bych tam postavil jinou věc,
kde by byl limitovány jenom územním plánem,
no prvně bych to převedl
a pak bych si tam udělal varianty podle sebe.
To se mi klidně může stát.
Nemám to dostatečně zajištěno.
Třetí věc,
kterou mě tam trošku trápí,
je,
že my se zavazujeme
v jakémkoliv případě,
kdy selže ten projekt
odkoupit za plnou náhradu.
Ale nemáme tam ten mechanismus,
kdy říká,
no co když to selže
na straně investora.
To znamená,
neměli bychom to pak kupovat
s nějakým jako sankčním fee,
které k té dispozici tam je.
To budeme i tehdy,
když to nedostaví
a mám tam to rozhovek
na jižních svazích,
to kupovat
za plnou hodnotu toho,
co ten investor do toho vložil.
To mě promiňte,
nedává smysl.
V neposlední řadě
kontrola.
To znamená,
je nám jedno,
kdo to dělá,
nebo
jsme rádi,
že to vyhrál tenhle subjekt.
Když si jsme rád,
že to vyhrál tenhle subjekt,
tak bychom si měli říct,
jestli ho nějak
jako svazujeme v tom,
aby u toho vždycky byl
ten konkrétní subjekt.
Nesvazujeme.
Prodám podíl
ve vlastní meseročku,
umožním vyvést
celý ten projekt
mimo svoji kontrolu.
S tím já mám problém,
tož nám trošku brání
dneska proto zvednout ruku.
My tam máme
ustanovení
právě ve slově
o slově budoucí
vlastně o tom,
že tam trikája,
že to je vlastně
ten vítěz,
že vlastně
je stále ručitelem
tady za
tyto závazky.
To znamená,
ta trikája jako taková,
ona s tam má
jako útéct nemůže,
protože zase,
ale teďka
jako jaká je praxe,
protože jinak to ani nebude.
Samozřejmě,
že ty jednotlivé objekty
bude stavit nějaké
takzvané
SPVčko,
neboli
projektová společnost,
která bude úplně čistá,
která nebude mít
žádnou historii,
protože jenom tak je
vlastně akceptovatelná
pro
financující subjekty,
ale nad ní bude
vlastně vždycky
ta trikája
a ta trikája
nikdy ani neuteče,
z toho
SOSBčka
ona nemá
jak útéct,
to znamená,
ona vlastně
tam,
já jenom to dokončím,
to znamená,
že ona tam
prostě pořád je
v úloze té
smluvní strany,
pořád je tam
v úloze
toho ručitele
a pokud by došlo
k tomu vypořádání
někdy,
prostě,
že by ten
proces celý
zhavaroval,
tak pokud je to
z důvodu
na její straně,
tak zase ta smlouva
tam stanovuje
sankce
na trikáju.
Dobrá, děkuji,
paní Bráš,
co reagovat?
Já děkuji za ten komentář,
já jsem si vědom
těch závazků
z té obligace
smlouvy o smlouvě
budoucí,
ale vy mi neodpovídáte
na to,
co jsem řekl já.
Já vyvedu to právo
stavby jako právo věcné.
Tím pádem
ten nový nabývatel
už nebude vázan
z té smlouvy
o smlouvě budoucí
a bude s tím
nakládat samostatně.
V tom ho, prosím,
nějak nelimituji.
Funcionovat tu trikáju
na bázi smlouvy
o smlouvě budoucí.
Proto jsem navazoval
na pana Simkoviče,
kde jsou ty postihy
a zda se to vyplatí
nebo nevyplatí.
Před tuto variantu
já jsem nechal otevřenou.
Zase ta smlou,
ona vám neumožňuje.
Jako jestli máte
jako obavu,
že by tam vyrostlo
jako něco úplně jiného,
než co chceme,
nebo to je,
to je, to je,
to je všechno.
Já jsem,
já vysvětlím,
ještě jednou, jo.
Dívejte,
zkusím být opravdu
srozumitelný
a nechci to dělat
nějak extra mentorsky.
Smlouva o smlouvy
budoucí je obligace,
jejíž součástí je smlouva kupní.
Právo stavby je právo věcné,
nevstavuje se ke straně,
ale k pozemku
a bude tam váznout navždy.
A já to věcné právo
mohu samostatně převést,
pokud to nezakážu,
bez ohledu na jiný
závazkový vztah
s smlouvu o smlouvy budoucí,
který jsem sjednal.
To je problém.
Tak a pokud přivádím
právo stavby,
tak stejně neuteču
ani předtím SOSB,
protože koneckoncu
tady máme i interpretační klauzuly,
že i v případě
i rozporu mezi SOSB
a smlouvou o právě stavby
má přednost ustanovení toho SOSB,
takže já si jako nemyslím,
že...
Hermane, omlouvám se,
vy mi nerozumíte,
když to převedu,
to právo stavby,
tak se vymaním
jako nový naběvatel pozemku
ze smlouvy o smlouvě budoucí.
Pak by ale vlastně znamenalo,
že kdybych toto udělal,
když se říká bavíme
o tomto scénáři,
to znamená,
já ho udělám tehdy,
když jsem majitelem
nebo statutárem trikáji,
tak v podstatě ale potom
musím položit i tu svoji,
abych z toho utekl,
tak musím položit
i tu svoji mateřskou firmu,
tu svoji trikáju.
Protože jinak já,
protože já jsem pořád
v té smlouvy o smlouvě budoucí
a pořád jako tam
neplním ty věci,
které plnit mám
a podlehám těm sankcím.
Omlouvám se za tu polemiku
a nechci zdržovat zastupitelstvo
a ani co dělat bramboračku.
To nevím,
jestli bych ji položil,
ale co vím,
že když ji položím,
tak mi město poskytne
plnou náhradu
bez ohledu na to,
z jakého důvodu
jsem to položil.
Dobře,
ale asi budu muset
položit tu svoji firmu,
protože to město
na mě zase pak
bude uplatňovat ty sankci,
protože já v tom případě
jsem neplnil to,
co podle SOSB plnit mám.
Pane Hermane,
další varianta.
Nechci se k tomu vracet.
Tak to jen podíl prodám.
A bude to někdo jiný,
úplně nějaká osoba třetí,
mě neznámá,
třeba nějaká
kyperská společnost zajímavá.
Zrovna teda kyperské společnosti
tam máme vyloučené teda.
My tam máme omezené samozřejmě
tady tyto převody.
Ale zase na druhou stranu,
ale moment,
ale ať se teď bavíme reálně.
Tady asi nenastane to,
že by se převádělo ven,
ale dá se očekávat,
že tam bude třeba
přistoupení cizího kapitálu.
To je zase naprosto reálné
a to tam upravujeme,
ale také.
Známka k tomu přistoupení kapitálu,
což město nevyužilo.
Město se zavazuje
v té smlouvy o právu stavby,
že bude bez dalšího souhlasit
se zastavením toho práva stavby.
Je to tak?
Je to tak.
Finanční, ale finančnímu...
Ne, ano, ano.
Je tam zase,
aby to prostě nebylo právě,
že přijde nějaký oligarcha,
ale musí přijít
nějaká finanční instituce.
Ať mějí banka.
Ano, ano.
Ať mějí korektní.
V pořádku přijde banka.
Jenom to, co nám uteklo je,
že když zastavujeme právo stavby,
tak současně
tomu zástavnímu věřiteli
náleží i náhrada
z toho odkupu práva stavby.
Jinými slovy,
město financuje cizí dluh
v případě,
že bude chtít
to právo stavby,
když za něm bude poskytovat náhradu.
Odstoupení od smlouvy budoucí,
například, jo,
plná náhrada,
tak ty peníze jdou rovnou bance.
Žádná výhrada.
Právo to umožňuje.
Tak pokud,
zase na druhou stranu,
pokud by nastala
tato situace
a na naší straně byla povinnost
nějakého vyplacení,
tak prostě to,
že budeme vyplácat
případně financující bance
a nikoliv jinému subjektu,
to zase taky si myslím,
že je docela standardní postup.
No byl by,
kdyby ta náhrada nebyla ve 100%,
v případě jakoukoliv
selhání toho projektu.
Jo, protože vlastně my si tady
ty náhrady si potom bereme,
ano, na základě SOSB
od toho vybraného investora.
Dobrá, děkuju.
Já poprosím teda pana Vančuru,
který vysvál se před
panem Jurášem.
Děkuju, pane primátore.
Já jenom k tomu
ten dnešek
se myslím,
sledeckaté
toho velkého množství projektu
opravdu bude ještě náročný
a myslím si,
že je na místě její úvaha,
zdá u tak velkých projektů,
které třeba
zranu číslo dvě na pásce
nemohli přizvat
k některým konzultacím
dříve, než ten materiál
vlastně pro
zastupitelstvo je
připraven.
Nám by se to velmi líbilo,
kdybychom mohli
nejenom vám radě,
ale i případně kolegům
sdělit některé
případná pochybení,
které k tomu máme.
V té stavbě
nebo k tomu případu
samotnému
my máme
dobré reference
o firmy
teka a tak věříme,
že se to nakonec
dobře zvládne.
Objevila se tam
nicméně
jedná taková zvláštnost,
že
vlastně ve stejný den,
kdy jsme
přijali vlastně
tu vylášku
o
té kontribuci,
tak této společnosti
když jsme to odpustili,
nepochybujeme o tom,
že k tomu byl
reálný důvod,
ale poprosil bych,
aby zase
v případě,
že to budeme
chtít opakovat,
aby dříve,
než se tak
rozhodne,
tak aby zastupitelstvo
o tom
bylo informováno,
protože
nedává to
samozřejmě
potom příliš velkou logiku,
že
dlouze jsme o tom
diskutovali,
že přijímeme,
že je to potřebné,
abychom
takovou vylášku přijali
a pak se zrodí
takový
paradox.
To je všem,
děkuji za pozornost.
Já to jenom v kostce řeknu,
proč to tam je,
ten stav je jednoduchý,
my točí říkáme,
a co dobu ta vyláška,
tak to byla vlastně brána,
že stavíš-li někde
cokoliv,
chceme nějaké
finanční prostředky,
abychom mohli,
řešit to okolí,
nebo dodělat
nějakou infrastrukturu
a tak dále,
kterou prostě
potřebujeme v té lokalitě
dělat kvůli,
dá se říci,
i kvůli tvojí stavbě.
V tomto projektu
tu infrastrukturu,
ta společnost dělá
už na základě přímo té smlouvy.
Takže proto vlastně
my jsme řekli,
ano,
tady můžeme dát výjimku,
protože celá ta,
ono vlastně staví
nejen ty jednotlivé objekty,
ale vlastně
kompletně
celou infrastrukturu
v té lokalitě
a tím pádem
ty finance,
když to řeknu,
vyplačila dvakrát.
Jakoby tak v té logiky
toho,
to, co jsme my vlastně
v té vyhlášce.
Takže proto vlastně
se řeklo,
tento projekt
to již obsahuje
a tím pádem
to nemusíme
na to uplatňovat.
To jenom
to byla ta logika.
Poprosím pana Vančuru
ještě o reakci.
Děkuju,
pane primátore.
Tak souhlasím,
ale o to,
víc by tom
takovouto informaci
zastupitelům
měli dát,
aby na tom
investorovi
neolupívaly
něco,
co tam nepatří.
Jo, děkuju.
Jasné,
rozumím tomu.
Tak,
další zhlasí
pan náměstek
Pavel Brda.
Tak ještě jednou
dobré dopoledne všem.
Já jsem chtěl
jenom dozhrnout,
já to považuji za,
že je správně,
že se o tom tady bavíme,
protože samozřejmě
je to velká transakce
a z pozice města
a tato transakce
je to největší
transakce
v historii města.
Možná zhrnou,
že neprodáváme
celou plochu,
ale reálně
prodáváme
pouze 8 953 metrů
čtvereční,
dosažená cena
40 845 korun
z DPH
a plus
peníze do infrastruktury
15 438
na metr čtvereční.
Jsou to pro nás
rekordní částky.
V lokalitě by mělo
vzniknout až 400 bytů,
600 parkingu
plus 500 parkingu
v parkovacím domu města.
Možná ještě
pro pana Simkoviče,
to jsme zmiňovali,
bavíme se o tom,
předměsto si stále
nechává dva pozemky,
jeden vlastně
bude určen
pro parkovací dům
se sportovní halou
a jeden pro případnou
bytovou výstavbu.
Můžeme se pak
do budoucna ještě bavit
co dál s tím,
jaké jsou možnosti,
uvidíme.
Znalecký posudek
byl vypracován
na částku 197 milionů,
takže ta dosažená cena,
která je
z DPH
365 milionů
a plus
87 milionů
do infrastruktury,
tak za nás je
velmi dobrý výsledek.
A co se týče
nějaké
kredibility toho investora,
tak na ně jsou,
jak zmiňoval pan Mančura,
velice dobrá.
Prně vybudovali
několik čtvrtí,
pokud jsme se s nimi potkávali,
tak jejich záměr
je tady použít
vlastně nějakých
dánských vzorů,
kterou používat
obklady cílných pásků,
vysoká kvalita
veřejného prostoru,
samozřejmě
útržitelný způsob,
staveb.
Jak bylo zmíněno,
bude to modulární výstavba,
takže já jsem přesvědčený,
že to přinese kvalitu,
která ve zlíně
do té doby nebyla.
A ještě k té debatě
o tom, jestli by to mělo
postavit město.
My jsme se samozřejmě,
ty úvahy tady samozřejmě byly,
ale jak zmiňoval
pan primátor,
my nemáme v tento moment
adekvátní aparat
takovou velkou čtvrtě připravit
a samozřejmě
ani finanční možnosti
a vzhledem k rozpočtovému
určení daní
a finanční možnosti města,
projekt řádu 3 až 4 miliardy
je v tento moment
nereálný.
Takže jsme vycházeli,
že pokud se tato stavba
ze strany soukromého investoru
realizuje,
tak to přinese další
daňové příjmy pro město,
budou se tady dělat
různé transakce,
výstavba,
firmy dostanou práci
a další příjem
bude výnosu daně
z nemovitostí.
Takže jsou to,
to je podobně
i u Boněckého rybníku,
že to bude mít
velmi pozitivní dopad
ještě na další
dodatečné příjmy města.
Důležité ještě zmínit
tady ty indexace,
taky jsou to indexace,
které ještě v historii
jsme ani neuplatnili
za předchůdců
a i v době stanu
se nic takového
nikdy neudělalo.
Já potom samozřejmě
to zmíním
i u Boněckého rybníku,
že byly úplně
jiné částky
a žádné takové
klauzule tam nebyly,
takže já jsem rád,
že jsme to poprvé použili.
Myslím si,
že ta práce
tady byla odvedena
jako zásadní,
připravovala to
prestižní kancelář
v Praze
advokátní Vilsons,
takže potom samozřejmě
nějaká debata
co se týče právní stránky
s panem Jurášem
určitě je možná
o některých ustanoveních
a po případě
z advokátní kanceláři Vilsons.
Takže já jenom jsem chtěl
za mě,
já jsem spokojený,
jak ta transakce proběhla
a mám důvěru v investora
a samozřejmě je v pořádku
se bavit o případných
rizicích k té transakce,
ale myslím si,
že to je důvěryhodný partnera
a podle jejich vyjádření
by ta stavba měla vzniknout
do pěti let,
takže za mě to je
velice dobrý výsledek.
Takže i panu Hermanovi
děkuju za odvedenou práci.
Dobré, moc krát děkuju.
Další slásí, pan Simkovič.
Já děkuji panu Brnovi
ještě za výsvětlení
a možná na poznámku.
Nemyslím si,
že bychom někdy dělali
za doby stanu projekt,
který bude zavazovat město
na sednáct, patnáct let,
takže možná proto
tam ty indexace nemuseli být
a neřešili se.
Já bych ten obráz
zahledal.
Já budu strašně rád,
když se ten projekt provede
nakonec,
když to bude přistavěno,
když to bude za těch pět let,
bude to fantastické.
Zméně, jak jsem říkal,
sednáct,
ale strašně dlouhá doba.
Ta ekonomika je
vysoce turbulentní
a já vůbec nepodezírám
kupujícího,
že bych chtěl dělat
něco nekalého
na druhou stanovnější vlivy,
které jsou.
Prostě se mohou dostat
do situace,
které nebudou pro nás
jako pro město komfortní
a proto tam vnímám
ty pojistky,
které jsme ještě změkčili
z té původní spolouvy
pro město.
a tak to říkali pany Uráž,
někde mírně výhodné
a odpověď na to,
jestli mohu rozšířit
tu plochu nad rámec 5%
ve vyšších patrech,
jsem odpověď nedostal.
Mě ta smlouva
s mnou budoucí říká,
že mohu
a nic z toho pro město
v podstatě nebude
a urbanisticky to je jistý
komfort a problém
a v kombinaci s tím,
že to vyvedu tu společnost
na někoho jiného
a podobně,
tam pořád toho riziko vidím,
takže za nás
to nemůžeme,
tento projekt
takto v této podobě
díky těmto pojistkám,
kde si myslíme,
že by mohly být
trošku přísnější.
Jestli ten investor
to chce udávat do pěti let,
tak by se těch pojistek
asi neměl bát.
V okámežiku,
kdy dostanou
na 20 změn
a všechny jsou
ve prospěch
toho kupujícího,
tak mě to trošilinku
zneklidnilo.
Dobrá, děkuji.
Další se hlásí
panáměstek
Měoslav Kavánek.
Děkuji, pane informátore.
Já jenom jirchlou o reakci
na pana Simkoviče.
Děláme projekt,
který jsme z hlíska
významu
zasažení vlastně
toho města
nikdy nedělali.
Takže když stan dneska říká,
jako nikdy jsme nezavázali
město k něčemu takovému,
no proto,
protože jste nikdy
tak velkej projekt nedělali.
To je ten důvod,
jako jo.
Ta březnická už je tam
deset let, jako odkoupena.
Nikdy jste ten projekt
jako nenastartovali,
neudělali.
Čili, já chci jenom
k tomu říct,
víte,
je to věc,
která je tady
z hlíska té velikosti
a těch konotací
prostě mimořádná.
Já si myslím,
že jedinou věc,
co poučení do budoucna
je, aby se tyto věci
v tomto rozsahu
prostě lépe komunikovali,
ať se k tomu můžeme
opravdu i v průběhu
připravit těch projektů
všichni scházet
tam být informace
a samozřejmě
přispívat tomu,
protože je to zájem.
Já jenom chci říct,
jakože jistotu
takových projektů
nebudete mít
100%.
Nikdy,
jo,
vždycky ponoseme
určitý díl rizika
té celé transakce.
Myslím si,
říct, že bavit se tady
o tom,
jestli,
jako máme
rate cap
na 5%
inflace.
Já vám můžu říct,
že pokud bude
10 nebo 12%,
tak to tam nikdo
stavět nebude.
Jo, prostě to zastaví,
jo,
protože z líska
přístupů
k kapitálu,
jako,
nedovedu si představit,
kolik by měl stát
dluhopis nebo
financování toho
projektu na peněžním
trhu, jako,
jo,
to si nedovedu představit,
jako,
jo,
a kolik by potom
měl státem být,
jo.
Takže to jsou všechno
takové věci,
které nějak vypadají,
ale ta realita
je potom trošku
jako jiná.
Já si myslím,
že máme projekt,
o který se někdo
přihlásil,
ty reference na tu firmu
jsou jako kvalitní
a dobré,
i ta spolupráce
vlastně z líska
toho přípravy
a vlastně
komunikace kolem
přípravy tohoto
projektu byla,
si myslím,
na vysoké úrovni
i ze stany
Trichai,
takže
já věřím tomu,
že se nám to prostě
podaří dotlačit
do dobrého konce
a že budeme mít
dneskou čtvrt
ve zlíně,
která tam patří
a která tam
do nějakých
šesti, sedmi let
zvíkne.
Dámská, děkuji.
Poprosím,
pane Juráše.
Já moc děkuji
za vystoupení
pana Chalánka.
Já bych nechtěl,
aby to úplně
vyznělo tak,
že jsme proti
rozvojovým
investicím ve městě
probu chráň,
tak to není.
Jsou zatím
určité stovky
hodin práce
a dobrý záměr.
To, co
připomínáme,
jako vždycky,
je skutečnost,
že pokud
opravdu
řeším projekty,
které přesahují
dekádu,
o to více
přemýšlím
nad tím,
jak to dobře
provést.
To, co mně
se přiznám,
ne ani
zarazilo,
spíš bych řekl,
při tom
promýšlení
standardně,
když za vám přijde klient
a začnete
identifikovat
ty rizika,
tak se díváte
na to z pohledu
statutárního města
z lina
spolu toho investora
a říkáte si,
kde by to mohlo být.
Tam trošku
vyčítám,
pane Hermane,
při vší úctě,
ten tržní standard,
práva staveb,
tam není tak
kvalifikovaně
dodržen,
jak my jsme zvyklí.
A to je celé,
co k tomu mám,
proti té investici
samou sobě samozřejmě
vůbec nic.
Děkuji za to upřesnění.
Tak, jak bylo řečeno,
samozřejmě vnímáme,
že to je velký projekt,
projekt, který tady
více měně,
jak jste tady nebyl.
Samozřejmě,
tak, jak říkáte,
a plně s vámi souhlasím
je snahou snížit
jakékoliv rizika
a proč se rady
ty zkušenosti
na území města z dína.
Už máme
a na základě toho
taky jsme vlastně
vždycky začali
potom následně dávat
nájmy,
nikoliv hned prodeje
a podobně.
V současné době
se jde cestou práva
stavby nikoliv nájmů,
protože ten institut
je trošku jiný
a na to to je,
že to řeknu,
hodnější.
Každopádně,
myslím si,
že ta diskuze je správná,
myslím si za sebe,
že je potřebná.
Zároveň si myslím,
že na základě této diskuze
se může vyvolat
celé další debata
o nějakých případných
dodatcích
se společností trikája,
pokud nějakým způsobem
bychom tam našli
opravdu nějaké věci,
které nám
výrazněji vadí,
to znamená znova
si to zanalizovat
i ty body,
co tady pana Juráš,
vy jste například zmíněval.
Myslím si,
že ta debata s nimi
byla vždycky seriózní
na všech jednáních,
takže nevidím
nějaký zásadní problém,
proč by případně
nemohl znikl
nějaký dodatek
tady nějaká
třeba příklad
i blížší
specifikace
těch jednotlivých limitů,
tak jak tady dneska zaznělo,
aby to bylo
více pro vás
všechny konfortnější
a pro tu budoucí
zastupitelst
posáříme také.
Takže já za to
moc krát děkuju
a tak jak už bylo řečeno
asi na všech stranách,
myslím si,
že všichni budeme jedině rádi,
pokud to vznikne
a logicky se chceme
co nejvíce chránit
z tomu,
kdyby se něco
po té cestě pokazilo.
Takže moc krát vám děkuju
za ty připomínky
a věřím tomu,
že i ve Zlíně
bude možné,
že soukromý investor
postaví něco většího
než jeden objekt.
Poprosím ještě
Kateřinu Francovou.
Dobré dopoledne všem.
Já za nás
za klub Stán
musím říct,
že se zdržujeme.
Není to proto,
že bychom chtěli
bránit rozvoj města.
Naopak,
my jsme byli tady,
když jsme se snažili
ty pozemky vykupovat,
uvědomujeme si ty rizika,
mojíme se toho
a je to materiál,
který jsme dostali
opravdu ve velmi
krátkém čase na to,
abychom to všechno
nastudovali,
abychom to pročetli.
Trápí nás,
že k tomu možná
nebyl prostor
k větší debatě.
Takže to je důvod,
proč se zdržujeme.
Já za sebe určitě říkám
co a otevřeně,
že mě za ty roky znáte,
že jsem se snažil dělat
těm větším projektům,
aspoň nějaké semináře,
abychom si ty věci probrali.
Na druhou stranu,
toto je trošku jiná situace,
já nemyslím to nějak ve zlém,
ale prostě je to otázka toho,
že vy se snažíte jednat s partnerem
v rámci nějaké smlouvy
a je to nějaký uzavřený proces.
To znamená,
my bychom určitě mohli dělat seminář,
ale ten seminář by proběhl ve stylu,
tady máte tuto smlouvu
a pojďme si řešit, co dál.
Takže ano,
to vlastně s vámi,
že by to tomu prospělo.
Na druhou stranu si myslím,
že když to schválíme v té podobě,
jak je to dneska předloženo,
tak je to určitá jistota
pro všechny strany,
ať už pro tu společnost,
který kájí,
tak pro město Zlín.
A nic nebráním tomu,
abychom ty obavy,
které tady dneska zazněly,
případně jakékoliv dalších,
které ještě se vyskytnou,
se právě za mě
s výrazně seriózním partenem
nepodařilo prostě nějakým dodatkem vyřešit.
Takže já za to právě moc ká děkuju
a rozumím tomu.
Rozumím tomu,
ale prostě jsou ty věci,
tak, jak se potkáme v dalším bodě,
co jsme vlastně přidali,
je i velké kino,
tak mi vlastně v rámci soutěže,
která vlastně do doby,
než my to dneska schválíme,
dá se vždy zprobíhá,
tak my vlastně nemůžeme
nějakým způsobem do toho vstupovat
a začít jako vědnat
a už vůbec neměnit smlouvy,
které by součástí té soutěže.
Takže zase ten zákon
nám něco umožňuje,
něco více, něco méně
a snažíme se ty kroky
výsledku udělat tak,
aby to naopak ty soutěže
nebyly ohroženy.
A na druhou stranu,
proto říkám,
že nikde nic nebrání tomu,
aby se dojednali nějaké dodatky
s kýmkoliv v rámci
tedykoliv projektů
a myslím si,
že toto je ten případ,
že na základí těch informací
z dneška,
těch vašich obav,
si myslím,
že do těch jednání
bychom měli dál vstoupit
a vlastně,
abychom ty jednotlivé obavy,
ať už tyto,
nebo ty budoucí,
jí teméně potlačili.
Takže za to moc káč děkuju.
Poprosím ještě náměstka
Pavla Bradu.
Já ještě takové jenom
doplnění.
Já samozřejmě
považuji za důležité,
že probíhá diskuze
a že ten projekt
samozřejmě
i na stavební komisi
byl diskutovaný
co se týče té zástavby
historické v radě,
takže nebylo určitě,
že by s tím,
že jsme vás nechtěli
s tím seznámit.
Tady se to dostávalo
do vysoce odborných
specializovaných částí
z oblasti práva,
takže do budoucna
určitě zvážíme
případně u tak důležitých smluv
nějaký speciální seminář.
Ta naše historická slušenost
byla, že dorazili většinou
jeden, dva lidi,
tak i tak se pokusíme
něco příště zorganizovat.
A možná jsem ještě chtěl říct
něco k výkupu tomu pozemku.
Já jsem si samozřejmě nechal vět,
jaká byla historie toho pozemku
a ono myslím,
že kolem roku 2006
ještě znevořil.
Bylo ten pozemek
prodaný developerské skupině ECM
a v podstatě v té smluvi
bylo ustanovení,
že město v případě,
že nebude realizovan záměr,
tak město může si vyžádat
ten pozemek
nebo v podstatě právo zpětné koupě
tohoto pozemku
a na základě tohoto vlastně
v éře stanu bylo koupeno,
takže tam nebyla žádná zásluha výkupu,
ale pouze bylo aplikováno
ustanovení o právu zpětné koupě
v případě,
že se developer dostane do insolvence
za takovou cenu,
za kterou to město prodávalo.
Takže to jsem jenom chtěl říct ještě
k tomu,
že by stan měl nějakou zásluhu
na získání toho pozemku
pouze aplikovali právo zpětné koupě,
které té smlouvě
historicky bylo tak tolik,
já jsem takový dovětek.
Dobrá, děkuji za to upřesnění
a nikdo další se do diskuze nehlásí,
takže prosím pojďme zastovat
materiál číslo 19.
Pro 25,
materiál číslo 19 byl přijat.
Materiál číslo 20
se týká
také pozemku,
také rozvoje lokality,
tentokrát Boněcký rybník
a myslím si,
že je tam spousta věcí
podobných
v tom, co bylo v předchozím bodu,
to znamená,
já to nebudu dál
prodlužovat
nějakou úvodu,
protože
myslím si,
že ten projekt znáte,
protože se byl několikrát
i medializován a podobně.
Jenom řeknu,
tak už jak jsem říkal,
i tady máme
z pozice
nejvyšší nabídky
mozájemce,
který podal nejvyšší nabídku
smlouvu
z jejího z jeho strany
podepsanou,
takže
by neměl být
nějaký problém
to, co tady
jsme například řešili,
že například,
že bychom my tady
schválili nějakou
stanovení smlouvy
a následně
vlastně
by
ta druhá strana
řekla,
že tam potřebuje něco
upravit,
nebo respektive,
jestli nesouhlasí,
že odstupuje
a tak dál
a vlastně musel by se
přistoupit
na to druhého
zájemce,
takže
v současnej chvíli
z této strany
je to také připraveno
a otvírám k tomu diskuzi
tím,
že jenom řeknu,
že vlastně soutěž
byla by soutěž
tak, jak máte
v materiálu
za
256,
tím, že je to 210 milionů
bez DPH,
takže
z DPH,
tím, že je to
v nákladech je to
plus další
financ
do té infrastruktury
to takové se baví
na 105 milionech,
takže
jenom ať ty informace máte,
děkuji za to doplní
odporné náměstka,
jestli mi tu radí
těch číslech,
že to má před sebou,
já ne,
takže děkuji za to
a otvírám diskuzi
v materiál číslo 20.
Tak, poprosím
pana Vybráše.
Tak
nebudu rekapitulovat
předchozí bod,
ty smlouvy jsou
jemálně upráva stavby
zrcadlem,
těch,
to je březnické.
A k tomu přistupují
další dvě věci,
chtěli jsme zmínit,
proč se zdržíme
stejně.
Platba za kontribuci,
je tam stejná výjimka,
to znamená,
schválíme sice pravidla
pro postup z investory,
ale hned na dalším projektu
uděláme výjimku.
Druhá věc,
co bych chtěl zmínit,
snad nad rámec
i pro pana Hermana,
poprosím,
tentokrát ty práva stavby
jsou tam čtyři,
jestli jsem to pochopil
ke čtyřem pozemkům
a provázanost
není úplně dobrá,
to je jenom zase technická
a třetí nebo čtvrtá
drobná,
ať už dobře
nebo špatně,
na tohle ty AI nástroje
jsou fakt jako dobré.
Máte tam chyby,
máte špatně ič,
máte tam překlepy
v pozemcích,
máte špatně označený
katastrální území,
jo, prosím,
projděte si znovu
ty dokumenty,
jsou tam prostě zjevné
písařské chyby.
Děkuji moc.
Morská děkuji
za ty připomínky,
vlastně šepana Hermana,
ono chtěl reagovat.
Možná jenom ještě řekl,
ať to vezmeme postupně,
tak jak to pan Juráš
zmiňoval,
ohledně vlastně toho
poplatku z té
plánovací smlouvy,
protože tím pachatelem
té myšlenky jsem já tutiž.
Tak ne, tak je to prostě
fér, abych na to odpověděl já.
Já vám řeknu rovnou proč,
protože ta úvaha byla taková,
že prostě tady bude
nějaký tok peněz
od investora
směrem k nám
a ten investor,
on to nemá jako nějakou
vedlejší kategorii,
tady ten příspěvek.
On prostě,
aby mu vyšla
excelovská tabulka,
tak prostě v tom vstupu
má nějaké množství peněz.
A buď to nám jedá
v jednom titulu,
to znamená
v kupní ceně,
anebo je nám,
nebo prostě stejnou částku
vlastně rozdělí
do dvou titulů,
s tím, že navíc
se to ještě platí později,
to znamená,
z hlediska našeho cashflow
je to o trošičku lepší,
v obou těch projektů,
protože vlastně smyslem
vůbec těch poplatků
dle plánovací smlouhy
je to,
aby město mělo
nějaké peníze
na infrastrukturu
a tady my vlastně
v obou dvou těch projektech
nechceme potom investorov,
jenom udělejí si to
nejbližší okolí,
ale vlastně vždycky chceme
vybuduji i něco navíc.
V případě Březnické
je to vlastně celá rekonstrukce
ulice Uzimního stadionu,
plus se tam vlastně staví
úplně nová spojovací silnice
stadionu, včetně vlastně
i veškerých zálivů,
protože vlastně tam bude
ta konečná trolejbusu.
V případě Boněckého rybníka
tak tam se vlastně buduje
jako velmi,
jako bych řekl,
finančně náročné propojení
vlastně od Broučkovy
na Dřevnickou.
To znamená,
tam totiž tak jako tak,
tam jsou nadstandard,
to znamená,
to je jako pro to odůvodnění,
jako byly morální,
to znamená,
že stejně po nich chceme
velké investice do
na vlastně majetku,
který pak bude používat
a brz sloužit z línu
a zároveň pak tam bylo
i to cashflowové vlastně
zdůvodnění,
jestli to bylo takto dostatečné.
Vlastně děkuji za tou předsení,
poprosím ještě pana Vybráše.
Už tvítíme.
Děkuji.
Děkuji, kdybych použil anglický výraz
fair enough,
ale vyvolává to mě další otázku,
proč ty pravidla pak máme.
Jo, jako máme nějaké pravidla,
které říkají standardizaci právě,
abychom nedělali ty výjimky
a teď to stavíme na tom,
že v rámci biznes modelu investora
si to vybereme v kupní ceně.
Jo, ten poplatek.
Já jestli vám fakt můžu říct,
jak to bylo,
totiž tady tato myšl,
protože já jsem byl u toho,
když se vymýšleli vlastně
vůbec ty plánovací smlouvy
a ještě v procesu toho vymýšlení
jsem tenkrát řekl,
ale pojďme s toho výjmout
tady tyto dva projekty.
Jenom ať když se o tom bavíme,
prostě to vždycky to má
jako nějaké,
to rozhodnutí má vždycky
nějaké zázemí.
Ten rozdíl je v tom,
že je v celku logický.
Je o tom,
že pravidla pro ty investory
respektive developery,
které máme nastavená,
tak jsou vlastně
na ty skutečnosti,
které se více mě ve změně dějí,
to znamená jednotlivý objekt,
případně dva objekty
a tak dál.
Tyto dvě soutěže,
ať už toho materiáčí jsou 19,
nebo teďka ten materiáčí jsou 20 je,
že my soutěžíme
celou rozvojovou lokalitu,
včetně té infrastruktury.
Takže ono tam dává logiku,
že chceme i tu infrastrukturu
nikoliv pouze ty objekty,
tak jak vlastně to staví někde jinde.
A já ze sebe jenom říkám
otevřeně,
že určitě musí dojít
na základě těch zkušeností
za ten teďka necejí rok,
kdy vlastně ta pravidla platí,
tak určitě já si myslím,
že v nějakém prvním polotí
příštího roku
dojde kaktulé z těch pravidel,
protože jsou tam některé procesy,
které jsou složitější zbytečně.
Dojde určitě tam příklad
i tady s těmto věcem,
že tam může být vlastně
přímo deklarováno,
že pokud se soutěží
kompletní rozvojová lokalita,
ještě tak to nazvem,
včetně infrastruktury,
tak vlastně ten poplatek tam není
a se nedělají zbytečně nějaké výjimky,
protože každá výjimka
prostě vždycky zbuzuje,
tak tzv. otazník ne-li vykřičník
a každý se ptá proč.
Takže já jsem moc rád,
že ty pravidla jsou,
ale samozřejmě myslím si,
že je potřeba umět reagovat
také na tu praxi
a ta praxa nám ukázala,
že určité aktualizace tam
v těch pravidlech budou muset nastat.
Další se hlásí Kateřina Francová,
tak poprosím paní Francovou.
Ještě jednou dobré dopoledne.
Mně trošku tady zaráží
těch 15 let na čtyřibytové domy.
Opět mi to přijde,
že to je poměrně dlouhá doba
na tu výstavbu,
že jim dáváme celkem velký časový prostor.
To je první věc.
A druhá věc,
my jsme se bavili o tom,
že toto je lokalita,
kde bychom mohli počítat
s výstavbou městských bytů,
tak jaká je představa,
protože tu tady nemáme
z hlediska výstavby
městského bytového domu?
V té lokalitě je to nastavené tak
a je to vlastně zase,
myslím si, že to bylo publikováno dál,
ale možná neúplně dostatečně.
Ta logika je ta,
že více měně si ta město nechává pozemky,
ale nechává si pozemky
na dva bytové domy.
To znamená, bavíme se zhruba,
uvidíme podle těch dispozic,
to bude nějakých 50.
My všude obecně píšeme zhruba 50 bytů,
díky těm dispozicím se může stát,
že to je 50 a 60 bytů.
To je ta logika,
co vlastně říkáme,
že naše rozvojová společnost
musí začít od něčeho menšího,
to znamená,
budoucí vedení města se rozhodne,
jestli to bude řešit tento projekt
prostřednictvím této soukromé městské společnosti,
nebo si to bude chystat přes odbor,
prostě nejakým způsobem
se to bude financovat a tak dál.
To znamená, jsou ty věci k tomu otevřené,
počítá se s ním samozřejmě
a je to jen otázka toho,
že jsme nechtěli tou cestou,
že bychom soutěžili včetně těchto domů
se závazkem investora,
aby městu následně ty dva domy
vlastně bytové převedl,
protože by to byla relativně výrazná
smluvní komplikace vlastně
a celé té soutěže,
takže jsme si touto cestou,
která přijde pro nás jednodušší,
jak z pozice pro toho investora,
tak také pro město,
aby vlastně ty dva bytové domy
mohlo stavět nezávisl na tom investorovi
a v čase, kdy prostě je samo chce.
Takže není prodáno všechno,
zůstala tam lokalita
a konkrétně na dva bytové domy.
Jestli můžu takovou drobnost,
my to teprve teď prodáváme,
já už jsem viděla,
že realitní kanceláře to nabízejí.
Tak to mě docela překvapilo.
To jsou jiné pozemky.
Tam jsou pozemky...
To je to SMO?
Ne, ne, ne.
Tam je společnost AIP,
která historicky v těch...
To je to, co tady zmiňoval pan náměstek
před nějakou chvíli na zastupitelstvu,
že se historicky tam v té lokalitě
prodávaly pozemky.
Za dnešních očích
velmi směšnou cenu zcela otevřeně,
protože tehdy se rozhodovalo,
jestli město bude, říkajeme,
důvědějorný partner
anebo trošku jako řekne,
že to je nesmysl.
Tehdy se rozhodlo,
že chceme být důvědějorným partnerem
a prodalo se to opravdu tehdy za částku,
která vycházela ze smlouvy,
která byla zase datována ještě dříve
a prostě ta částka nebyla úplně už tehdy.
Úplně jako...
Ještě vnímáno,
že ta, která by měla být vyšší,
stala otevřeně.
To se řešilo na zastupitelstvu.
Já si myslím,
že to bylo takový...
protože to bylo vlastně v zastupitelstvu
v tom předchozím,
ne v období 2014-2018.
V tom období se to prodávalo,
tuším, za 2000 za metr čtvereční,
dva a půl, něco takového,
mezi dva a dva a půl tisícema,
protože tam byla smlouva
se společnostní AIP
a smlouvy budoucí.
Tato společnost vlastně tam postavila
ty dva bytové domy
a stejná společnost tam vlastní i další pozemky
a vlastně přistoupila na urbanistickou studii města
a staví vlastně dle tady toho té architektury,
to, co tam chce město v té lokalitě
a tyto objekty již má v nabídce,
protože si řeší financování toho celého projektu.
Tak, další sehlásí náměstek Pavel Breda.
Já ještě jenom doplním pana primátora,
teď on řekl téměř všechno,
co jsem chtěl říct,
jenom zhodnu ještě ten projekt.
Prodáváme 7575 metrů čtvereční,
dosažená cena na metr čtvereční
prodávaného pozemku
33 544 z SDPH
plus investice do infrastruktury
dalších,
tři nás nebo 14 tisíc,
to mám tady přepočtené.
Vznikne tam 260 bytů,
226 parkovacích míst,
v té lokalitě je cenová mapa
přibližně 4000 Kč na metr čtvereční.
Udělal jsem si teda rešerš,
jak se vlastně v eře stanu,
nebo do toho roku 2018
prodávali ty pozemky,
bylo to 2100 Kč za metr čtvereční
pod prodávaným pozemkem,
takže ne celý pozemek,
ale čistě pod tím bytovým domem.
Nebyly tam tehdy žádné parametry,
ani indexace a ani tam nebyl žádný příspěvek
na infrastrukturu a do veřejných prostranství
a nebyl tam žádný vliv na architekturu.
Takže to je jenom takové srovnání s tou eurou
do toho roku 2018.
Takže za mě je to zase velmi dobrý dosažený výsledek,
který se téměř blížní část se za Březnickou.
A potom ještě teda řeknu,
doplním tu informaci,
kterou tady zmiňoval pan primátor.
V té lokalitě z toho výnosu té čtvrtí
chceme vybudovat 50 až 60 bytů podle skladby
a chceme, aby to zůstalo jako nájemní bydlení
pro občany z Lína.
Myslíme si, že to je funkce města.
A ten důvod, proč jsme to původně zamýšleli,
že uděláme po rakouském vzoru soutěž,
že developer nám vlastně ty byty vybuduje,
ale z hlediska českého právního řádu
s tím byl docela problém.
Takže jsme šli takovou jednodušší cestou,
že si to město z výnosu té čtvrtí
vybuduje samoté nájemní byty
a zůstanou v majetku města.
To je kolik asi komentář tady
ponětskému rybníku.
A Pavlo, panu Hermanu, taky zase děkuji
za spoustu práce a s tím výsledkem
já jsem jako osobně velmi spokojený.
Já bych tam doplnil jenom jednu věc.
Dneska tady zaznili nějaké počty bytů
a podobných věcí.
Tam samozřejmě se to bude odvíjet od dispozic.
To znamená, investor zvolí nějaké dispozice
a těch bytů tam může být méně,
pokud ty byty budou větší.
V některých oběchtech naopak těch bytů
může být trochu více,
tak jenom poprosím,
berte ty čísla trošku jako orientační,
protože určitě ten investor
potom bude řešit dispozice
natových objektů dle jeho volby.
Takže jenom ať se teďka pak netáháte
někde do budoucna
nebo my všichni jsme řekli,
že tam bude takový počet.
Prostě bude to otázka toho vývoje.
Toto jsou orientační počty
dle nějakých předpokládaných dispozic.
To by v těch objektech mohlo být.
Jenom ať si to tady ještě řekneme.
Poprosím Kateřinu Francovou.
Jenom ta historie byla taková složitější
na spoustu věcí
a my jsme mají tak na starosti neměli,
ale to bych teďka nechtěla zmiňovat.
Jenom 260 bytů,
já vím, že to je obrazně,
ale 226 parkovacích míst v tuto dobu.
To nemáme ani jedno parkovací místo
a jeden byt je docela málo.
To si myslím, když už teda se o tom bavíme.
V té lokalitě dlouhodobě
bojujeme s parkovacími místy.
Jsme si to vědomi.
Měli jsme setkání z občany z té lokality
se spolkem, který je tam založený.
My v současné chvíli jsme
neustále tlačili na architekta,
aby se zvýšil počet parkovacích míst.
To znamená,
to je i to, co já říkám,
to, co je dneska řečeno,
není úplně to, co může být finální stav.
Druhá věc je ta,
že samozřejmě je ke zvážení
a je to politické rozhodnutí
do budoucna,
které se tady zvažovalo
už několikrát
a vždycky se od toho ustoupilo
z pozice politického,
čistě politické,
nebylo to nic jako ohledně racionální,
ale politického rozhodnutí
v několikero volebních obdobích,
které tu byly,
kdy z pozice města
jsme schopni zvýšit
na 1,5 násobek požadavky zákonů
na počet parkovacích míst.
Nikdo to tady z politického hlediska neudělal.
My jsme na tím zvažovali,
otevřeně řeknu,
v tomto roce jsme to dále řešili,
že bychom to tady ještě jakým způsobem chtěli dát.
Neříci, že jsme se neodvážili,
ale je to otázka toho,
že v současné době,
kdy ty projekty už jsou v této fázi,
tak už to bylo zbytečné.
Každopádně si myslím,
že to je úvazné,
jak s ním do budou se nakládat,
protože ten zákon
a ty normy,
které v současné době jsou,
tak prostě
nám to selský rozum nebere,
nikomu z nás,
ani občanům,
ale vedle toho máte proti tomu,
že ve chvíli,
kdy toto schválíte,
tak nejeden člověk z zastupitelstva,
ať už současného nebo minulého,
tady výřil logickou debatu,
že pokud toto město udělá,
tak podraží byty.
Samozřejmě ten investor,
když bude mít postavit
víc parkovacích míst,
tak samozřejmě si to do té ceny promítne,
ale pak je otázka,
co říká ten trh.
A vzhledem k tomu,
že ten trh v současné době
není nasycen těch nemovitostí,
tak logicky se to tam promítne.
Takže teď je otázka ta,
že my v současné době tím,
že schvalujeme tady právě
ty dva materiály,
které má přinést na trh stovky bytů
v relativně krátké době,
tak se otvírají dveře také k tomu,
tady znova otvří tu debatu,
jestli pro ty další projekty,
které se taky chystají
a také vzniknou za několik let,
jestli se nemá tady tato,
řekněme, využítné možnosti,
které město,
to je jediné možnosti,
kterou město má
a prostě ten násobek tam zvýšit,
protože v budoucnu,
až se ty byty dostanou na trh,
tak vlastně vzhledem tomu,
že ten trh by měl mít více dobytů,
tak by se to nemuselo
tak moc projevit do té ceny.
Ale toto je realita současných norem.
Poprosím ještě pana Hermana.
Pro paní Francu,
ale jako upřesnění,
tady toto číslo,
to se bavíme vlastně
o podzemních parkinzích.
Není tam teda moc těch nadzemních,
zase ať si teda jako,
když jednou teda mi bylo řečeno
fair enough,
ať jsem fair enough
i po druhé,
jsou tam nějaké jako nížší desítky
těch nadzemních parkingu,
ještě se tam teďka vymyslel,
ještě je něco nového
a je to zase třeba se bavíme
o další deseti,
třeba u dřebnice,
protože zase ta urbanistická logika
je taková,
a teďka nepodezírám pana architekta,
že se tam inspiroval,
ale prostě ono to vypadá
jako jedna čtvrť,
která je ve Švýcarsku
a vypadá tak dobře právě
i díky tomu,
že to vlastně není zaskládané
těmi parkovišti,
tak jak třeba dneska vypadá
jižní město,
ale prostě jenom k tomu,
to je vaši jako fakt správné připomínce,
ono je to jako dopárované
těmi nadzemními.
Dobrá, děkuji za to doplnění.
Níkdo další se do diskuze nehlásí,
takže já prosím,
pojďme hlasovat materiál číslo 20.
Pro 25.
Materiál číslo 20 byl přijat.
Materiál číslo 21
týkající se pozemních komunikací,
to znamená dohody a spolupráci
právě s řešení
pravobřežní komunikace,
jsou k tomu dotazy.
Nikdo se do diskuze nehlásí,
tak prosím, pojďme hlasovat materiál číslo 21.
Pro 28.
Materiál číslo 21 byl přijat.
Materiál číslo 22
týkající se pozemních komunikací,
tentokrát uzavření smlouvy
o budoucí kupní smlouvě,
jsou k tomu dotazy.
Nikdo se do diskuze nehlásí,
tak prosím, pojďme hlasovat materiál číslo 22.
Pro 33.
Materiál číslo 22 byl přijat.
Materiál číslo 23
týkající se tenisového areálu na Vršavě.
Vyřešíme kupní smlouvu
s tenisovým klubem.
Jsou k tomu dotazy.
Poprosím pana náměstka Mirka Chalánka,
aby zlíže uvedl ten materiál.
Ono se to týká vlastně
těch převodů,
které my jsme tady historicky měli,
takže jenom,
abychom byli schopni dostat toho,
co jsme si tady sami řekli v minulosti.
Ale poprosím pana náměstka.
Děkuji za slovo, pane primátore.
Je to tak, jak říkáte,
je to vlastně ten,
je to záležitost tak,
aby jsme strlili pozemky,
pozemky pod sportovní halou,
kterou jsme kupovali
od tenis Vršava SRO.
Čili je to pokračování
v těch sluních ujednání,
které jsme měli na začátku
ohledně tady toho nákupu,
této nemovitosti.
Já bych chtěl jenom upozornit
najednou je,
že my vlastně budeme hradit
ve prospěch sportovních klubů,
kdy částku za ten pozemek
vlastně budeme hradit
ve prospěch sportovních klubů,
které tento pozemek převádí
z hlediska svých zase,
řekl bych, pravidel,
převádí na zapsaný spolek.
Takže my kupujeme od spolku,
ale hradit budeme
ve prospěch sportovních klubů.
Čili to je taková trošku
jako anomálie
nebo výjimečnost
tady toho slunovního stavu.
Mám zkrátka děkuju
za to upřesnění
a otvírám diskuzi
k tomuto bodu.
Do diskuze se nikdo nehlásí,
tak prosím, pojďme hlasovat
materiál číslo 23.
Pro 27, materiál číslo 23 byl přijat.
Materiál číslo 24 týkající se smlouvy
o uzavření smlouvy o smlouvě budoucí
o bezúplatném převodu části pozemku.
Jsou k tomu dotazy.
Nikdo se do diskuze nehlásí,
prosím, pojďme hlasovat materiál číslo 24.
Pro 29, materiál číslo 24 byl přijat.
A já věřím tomu,
že se nám společně s krajem,
se který jsme teďka řešili,
protože se týká tato smlouva,
že se podaří tady ty sociální služby
na území města Zína opravdu dotáhnout.
Materiál číslo 25.
Materiál číslo 25 jsou investiční dotace
do společnosti Steza,
to znamená pro stolečnosti Steza
do jednotlivých sportovič,
které tam máte vyjmenované.
Jsou k tomu nějaké dotazy,
hlásí se paní Kateřina Francová,
které předávám ti to slovo.
Já tady trošku mám zase výhradu.
Zotva převedeme nějaký majetek,
tak opět do něho prostě neustále investujeme.
Já vím, že asi je to potřeba,
ale trošku mě trápí ten tenis.
Myslím si, že prostě je to sport,
který není pro širokou veřejnost.
A když se dívám,
že tady máme 450 tisíc
na modernizaci systému vytápění haly
v tenisovém areálu na Mladcové,
já bych poprosila,
mě by zajímalo na Mladcovou,
kolik už tam šlo investici,
si o nějakou tabulku můžete mi zaslat,
protože mně přijde,
že nás ten tenis to je fakt velké peníze.
A já bych to radši investovala
do sportovišť pro širší veřejnost.
Tady je to velmi sport,
který je individualizovalý,
několik skupinový.
A je to krátká doba,
kdy jsme to sportoviště převzali.
Já vím, že ho chceme zlepšovat,
ale kam až to dál půjde
a jaký tam máme plán dalšího rozvoja
a dalších investic.
Takhle mi to přijde,
že jak to přichází,
tak to tam všechno typeme.
Každý přijde, řekne a jde to tam.
Určitě ten soupis jsme schopni poslát,
takže to udáváme písemně.
To není problém,
co se týká to,
že tenis je velou ústkou skupinu lidí.
I ty rezervace těch kurtů
tomu úplně nenapovídají.
I na té mladcové obsazenost.
Takže každopádně beru to,
že každý má rád jiný sport,
má tu nějaký názor,
co vůbec tady se polemizovat nebudem.
Každopádně já to řeknu
asi v kostce.
Na začátku tohoto volebního období
se nám podařilo udělat
konzolidaci sportovišť,
protože ta historie,
kterou si všichni pamatujeme,
je, že nemálo těchto sportovišť
měl jeden určitý spolek,
případně pár soukromých subjektů.
Vždycky to probíhalo tím způsobem,
že chodí na město
s žádostí o individuální
investiční dotaci,
tak se říká s nataženou rukou.
Dejte nám to,
nebo my to budeme muset zavřít.
Takže samozřejmě
myslím si, že je správně,
že jsme měli tu konzolidaci.
Je to v rukou města.
Na druhou stranu
realita je taková,
že ačkoliv jsme promítli
samozřejmě ten stav
do kupní ceny
a je potřeba říct,
že spousta těch sportovišť
nám bylo převedeno zadarmo.
Tady toto konkrétní sportoviště
jsme vykupovali,
ale rozhodně za nižší cenu,
než byl ználecký posudek.
To je taky potřeba říct si.
Tak jsme v tu danou chvíli
samozřejmě trošku obětí toho,
že ty sportoviště
nejsou jako
obtovědějící
21. století.
A tím pádem
některé investice
do toho jsou potřeba dát,
ale například
zrovna investice
na modernizaci
systému vytápení haly
se nám vrátí,
protože tam opravdu
lítají velké peníze
a dá se tam opravdu
zase
nemalé finanční prostředky
ušetřit.
Takže
souhlasím s tím,
že si postupně
nabíráme sportoviště
a že nás něco stojí.
Naprosto s ním souhlasím.
Na druhou stranu
myslím si,
že město se má
strat do toho
sportovní infrastrukturu,
protože jiný subjekt
na to tady
není.
Ta česká ekonomika
tak to nefunguje,
když se to podíváte,
že by tady byly
soukromé společnosti,
které by investovaly
do sportovišť
a vlastně
žádný biznisplán,
co se týká
sportovišť,
nefunguje
ani co se týká
multifunkční arény,
která se neustále zmiňuje.
Jenom pro vaši informaci
multifunkční aréna,
která vychází
v nějakém lehkém zisku
je více méně jediná
v České republice
a to je v Praze
a všechny ostatní
jsou více méně
v mínusu
nebo jsou dotovány,
což samozřejmě
je i ten důvod,
proč když jsme vyhlásili
průzkum trhu,
případně
ty předběžně tržní konzultace,
tak nám ty firmy řekly,
my vám to strašně rádi postavíme,
ale financovat na tom
nebudeme nic,
protože tam tu návratnost
prostě nevidíme,
ani v dlouhodobém horizontu.
Takže bez těch
dotačních peněz,
respektive peněz
té soukromé
v té státní sféry,
ať už je to municipalita
jako město, kraje
nebo teda náří spoty,
agentura
či jiný dotační titul,
tak ta sportovní infrastruktura
se prostě udržovat
nebo rozvíjet nedá
a to je ten důvod,
proč prostě
prostředí svým stezi
se snažíme
alespoň udržovat
a nějakým způsobem
přidávat hodnotu tomu,
co vlastně máme
na území města Zína
a samozřejmě vedle toho
hledáme další možnosti.
Minulý týden jsme jednáli
s vedením
z národní sportu
agentury
a řešili jsme taky co dál,
takže
není to o tom,
že bychom tady seděli
a jenom si ty věci
prostě
bezhlavě vzali
a teďka se strašně dívili,
že se do toho investuje.
Na druhou stranu
myslím si,
že ta traktivita
města Zína
je potřeba ji udržet
i v této,
říkám,
i v tomto ranku
těch sportových.
Poprosím náměstka
Mirka Chalánka.
Já jenom v rychlosti
určitě tabulku připravíme,
není problém,
ale
pan primátor o tom mluvil.
Já bych chtěl jenom říct,
že vlastně
v tuto chvíli jsme přebrali
dvě sportoviště,
to znamená
mladcovou
a tenisovou halů.
V tuto chvíli
se zaměřujeme
na dvě typy
investis,
které tam jsou.
Do energického provozu,
to znamená
vytápění,
svícení a tak dále.
A potom jsou to bezpečnostní,
to znamená
tak, aby jsme měli všechny revize
tam, kde dochází
k nějakému ohrožení provozu.
Protože nejsme v pozici
jako ty minulý vlastnici,
jsme tady veřejná instituce,
která to veřejně
provozuje
a samozřejmě nemůžeme si dovolit
jakékoliv ohrožení těch lidí,
kteří se tam pohybují.
Takže to jsou
nejnutnější
investice,
které v tuto chvíli
do těch
sportov již dáváme.
Děkuju za to upřesnění
a poprosím
pana Vančuru.
Děkuju, pane primátore.
Můj dotaz jenom směřuje,
jak plánujeme,
co se týče sportu dále,
budoucnost proházenou,
protože tam si mění,
jsme zachytili
její přístup
k tělocvičně,
tak jenom prosím,
alespoň encyklopedické,
jak o tom teď přemýšlíte.
Děkuju.
Já se přiznám,
že jsme k tomu
došli trošku
jak slepí k houslím,
protože já jsem se to
dozvěděl
prostřednictvím
úplně ještě
jiného člověka
než pana předsedy
házené
a někdy
na konci prázdním.
Vzhledem k tomu,
že v té době,
když měl tady
spolek házené
domluvené nájmy
v jiných subjektech,
tak je naprosto patrné,
že tady ten rozpor
mezi ředitelem
střední školy
a, když to řeknu,
vedení házené
nastal,
já předpokladám,
někde na začátku července
nebo více než během
první poloviny prázdnín
a
já se přiznám,
že jakož jsem
u těch jednání
vůbec nebyl,
tak je úplně
nechci soudit
a na druhou stranu
mi to přijde
veliká škoda,
že se nebyli schopni
dohodnout,
takhle bych to řekl.
Aktuálně házená
je saturovaná
jako v jiných
tělocvičnách,
které se jim podařilo
sehnat,
ačkoliv jsou vzdálenější,
to znamená
děti do jíží,
například do sousedních
otrokovic
na některé tréninky,
což si nemyslím,
že je komfortní situace.
Na druhou stranu
je potřeba říct,
že tato situace,
kdy například
florbalisté navštěvují
tělocvičný
v otrokovicích
nebo v jiných
okolních obcích
je u jiných sportů
běžná.
Takže tím já nechci říct,
že to je dobře.
zároveň jsme
zareagovali tím způsobem,
že v době jsme se to
dozvěděli,
tak jsme poptali
kapacity našich
základních škol,
abychom věděli,
jestli jsou schopni
ještě něco absorbovat.
A tento seznám,
já jsem předal
dál na
členku rady
z Línského kraje,
která má v gesty sport,
která vlastně taky
více tento problém řeší,
protože
v třední škole
má v gesty
je ze řizovatelem
je kraj,
nikoliv město.
za mě prostě
se to zašlo řešit
s křížkem po funuse,
jak se říká.
Protože
kdyby se to řešilo
v době,
kdy
se o tom
ještě nezhodlo,
nebo respektive
kdy to pan ředitel
neobsadil
jinými sporty,
tak se s tím
potom je dalo
ještě něco dělat.
Ale v době,
kdy už
tu tělocvičnu
pro jiným sportům,
tak
už s tím
těžko někoho vyhodíte.
Teď je to špatně.
Já jsem moc rád,
že ta házená
se s tím poprala,
ačkoliv je to
samozřejmě nekomfortní
pro mnoho lidí.
Ale
musíme se k tomu
nějak postavit,
ale jenom nám to potvrzuje
zcela otevřeně
ten deficit
těch sportových
sportovních ploch
o rozměru 20 na 40,
který ve zně máme.
To je potřeba říct si,
že o něm víme
a snažíme se právě
například
rozvoje lokalitě
na jižních svazích,
takzvané potorzu,
tak tam vlastně
v rámci zadání
té urbanistické soutěže
je například také to,
že tam má být
sportoviště
o rozměru
20 na 40,
protože jsou to ty sporty,
které jsou,
pokud máte to sport,
protože je 20 na 40,
tak to je vlastně relativně
optimální,
jak už házená,
floorball,
když je dostatečná
výška stropů,
tak také volejball,
takže víme o tom,
máme to vlastně
i v chystané
koncepci sportu,
kterou vlastně
předpokladám,
bude schvalovat
nové zastupitelstvo
někdy v první polovině
příštího kalendárního roku,
protože je nachystaná,
ale je potřeba,
aby se s ním všichni
seznámili
a případně
se vníbějí úpravy.
Je to deficit,
který tady máme,
nejsme schopni vyřešit
krátkodobém hledisku
a všechny akce,
které jsme měli rozjednány
i se soukromými subjekty,
kdy jsme měli například
rozjednáno,
že vznikne jedna,
tak to řeknu,
montovaná hala
a právě se sportu
ještě 20 na 40
a město tam bude v nájmu
a tím nájmem
nějakým způsobem
splácat tu investici,
tak když jsme dostali
pak ty podmínky,
kdy celá ta investice
investora měla stát
zhruba 40 milionů korun
a my bychom za 20 let
ji zaplatili dvakrát,
tak jsme řekli,
že to vůbec nedává smysl,
protože by to za nás
nehospodárne.
Takže ty cesty hledáme
zcela otevřeně,
ale samozřejmě
tato situace nás nejtěší
a budeme ji muset řešit.
Každopádně vzhledem tomu,
že už jsem samozřejmě
slyšel verzi o tom,
jak se
Polek,
ve kterém působě
má spoustu hodin
tady v této tělocvičně,
tak vám můžu klidně říct,
že tam nemáme ani jednu
a zároveň
jsme se to fakt dozvěděli
opravdu pozdě.
Mě to samotného mrzí,
protože s panem
předsedou volejbalu
Hazenkářského klubu
jsem v doběhu
posledního
čtvrt roku,
možná půl roku
jednal minimálně dvakrát
a ani jednou mi vlastně
nějaký takovýto potenciální problém
neavizoval,
takže
nedostali jsme
prostor
k tomu vlastně
ani pomoct.
Došli jsme
až k hotové věci.
Poprosím,
pane Vráše.
Děkuju za slovo,
pane primátore.
Já řeknu dvě věci
a rozdělím je
to,
že by město
mělo mít
sportovní infrastrukturu
souhlasíme
a připojím se
ale teďka
na druhé straně
trochu
k tomu kritickému hlasu
kolegů ze stanu.
Tři poznámky.
Ta první,
mám způsobení
ve steze pocit,
že
v zásadě
cokoliv,
co slouží,
jakémukoliv sportu
město koupí.
To není ten výběr,
demonstrováno to bylo
například u tenisu,
skončilo nám tam judo,
které jako je
využívanou
z půlky
pro skautské voddíly,
skončilo nám
tam stolní tenis.
Vypadá to skoro,
že koupíme každý plácek,
kde se jenom kope do balónu.
Tam bych udělal
lepší
asi možná výběr.
Druhá věc,
není to úplně tak,
jak pan náměste
Chalánek říkal,
máme značné
rezervy
v prověřování
stavu
kupované věci
a její
provozu schopnosti.
Na to narážíme,
z pravidla
to trošičku vypadá,
že teprve až
po převzetí
do zprávy
s tezou
začínáme
v dobrém zjišťovat,
jak dobrý
či špatný
ten stav je
a jak na to má být
reagováno
v tom investičním plánu.
Proto nám
konec konců
teď končí na stole.
Třetí moja
drobná poznámka
na příkladu tenisu
se to
docela slušně
profiluje.
Nebudu citovat
toho vlastníka,
není tady.
Víme,
že je komplikovaný,
mluvím o tenisu
na mladcové
a investice
do té
technologické
části,
do té
úspory,
dodávek,
teplné energie,
zase
souvisí se všechno
se vším.
Vzali jsme to,
nevěděli jsme
úplně přesně,
jak to provozuje.
On to provozoval
ve velmi úsporném
režimu,
byly tam
15-16
stupňový topu,
k tomu tam byly
jako neúplně dobře
nastavené
podmínky
s dodavateli
a když jsme se o to
začali hádat,
že jako tohle
jsme tak trochu
nevěděli
a bude nás to stát
asi více peněz
v tom provozu,
než bychom sami chtěli,
tak jsme se nakonec
jako domluvili,
že to jako
by the way
už necháme být
a uděláme tu investici,
která je nutná
v hlediska toho provozu.
To souhlasím.
Jen prostě
máme rezervy
v tom,
jak ty
sportoviště
vybírat,
spravovat
a dostávat
do té vlastní
zprávy.
Já na tom v koste
zráguji,
že samozřejmě
jsou různé okolnosti,
když se přebírat
sportoviště,
souhlasím s vámi,
že je otázka,
jestli všechna
ta sportoviště,
které jsme převzali,
jestli opravdu
jsou to ta
strategická sportoviště
nebo ne.
Souhlasím s tím.
Kolikrát jsme
vycházeli
i z té logiky,
pokud to nepřevezmete,
zavíráme,
tento sport tady končí
a vzhledem k nedostatku
těch míst
ve Zlíně,
tak jsme
více méně
řekli,
dobrý,
tak to převezmeme,
až ten sport
tady nějakým způsobem je.
Co se týká
toho převádění,
tak konkrétně,
co se týká
té mladcové,
tak tam je za mě
přesně ten krásný příklad,
o který vy zmiňujete,
ale já bych jenom
řekl jednu věc.
My jsme to převzali,
tak tam přesně
ti lidé ze stezy,
kteří nám teďka říkají,
co tam máme udělat,
tak tam byli
a řekli nám,
seznámili jsme se se vším,
je to v pořádku,
je to v dobrém stavu,
žádné velké investice
to nečeká.
A proto říkám,
že pak už,
když ti stejní lidé
dojdou
po nějakou dobu později,
když souhlasím s tím,
že se lépe seznámí
s tím provozem,
tak následně
dojdou vlastně
s těmi investicemi.
Takže
je to pak otázkou,
jestli teda,
a to můžu říct,
jako vlajcky si řeknu,
jestli jsou dostatečně kvalifikovaní
ti lidé v té steze,
teda když na tu první dobrou,
na ten první posudek,
nebo se nechají opít rohlíkem,
jak se říká,
nebo prostě
jsou tam nějaké další,
jiná pochybení,
či nějaké skryté vady,
jak se říká.
Takže
určitě si myslím,
že v tomto
ty mezery
a věci,
které se dají zlepšit,
město má
a věřím tomu,
že se tady z těch věcí
postupně vždycky poučí
a protože
ať se nám to líbí
nebo ne,
tak kdo jiný ještě
tady celé zastupitost
města Zína,
víme,
že město není
jako bezredná pokladnička
a každému,
kdo dojde,
je s nataženou rukou,
ať už je to sport,
či kdokoliv další.
Takže
samozřejmě se snažíme
chovat hospodárně,
ale
někdy to sebou
bohužel nese
i tyto věci,
že po seznámení
ty provozní náklady
posunou trošku někam jinam,
nebo nám to vzpět ukáže
ten provoz něco,
co nebylo předpokládáno.
Poprosím
paní Francovou.
Pane Juráši,
já děkuji.
O tom to je.
Jestliže se to provozovalo
za úsporných podmínek,
tak v tuto chvíli
to nevydržíme rok
provozovat
za úsporných podmínek.
Teď už jako
na jednou z ničeho nic
během krátkého času
musíme do toho
tolik investovat.
To je právě moje otázka.
A na druhé straně,
tak on ten nájem
se potom asi odvíjí
od toho, kolik nás
stojí ten provoz, že?
Takže ten dotyčný,
co tam hraje,
nebo kdo si to pronajímá,
zaplatí nám tu částku,
o kterou my teda
snížíme ty náklady,
nebo teď jsou vysoké,
bude to nižší
a my jim to zaučtujeme.
To se ptám.
Děkuji.
Je to tak,
jenom, že ten nájem stanovuje,
že jsou tam dva snůvý vztahy.
Jeden nájem je mezi městem
a stezou.
Tam je vlastně nájemný vztah
a potom je dál,
kdy steza pronajímá
to další sportoviště.
Takže samozřejmě
tu cenotvorbu té stezy
určuje steza,
ale logicky se taky vychází
z toho dalšího smluvního vztahu,
teď ten steza má mezi městem.
Je to potřeba říct,
že je to tak askádovité,
abych to řekl.
Teď, když to vezmu obráceně
a nemyslím to nějak ve zlém,
té steze může být úplně jedno,
protože ona to nefinancuje.
To znamená,
tam je otázkou,
takže jak ta steza
se snaží nastavit,
teď to řeknu,
finanční politiku takovou,
aby to bylo to sportování dostupné,
ale zároveň pak je otázkou,
jestli ekonomické vůči městu,
což má zajišťovat právě
ten smluvní vztah
zase mezi městem a stezou.
Ale je to asi to podobné,
jak se můžeme bavit o tom,
kolik, jakou cenou,
nebo respektive jakou částkou
podporujeme
nějaké kulturní instituce a podobně,
prostě jak dotujeme,
řekněme, ty netivé lístky,
tak tímto způsobem
v kostce dotujeme
do nějaké míry
i ve výsledku třeba
tu hodinu toho tenisu,
toho pronájmu.
Je to jakoby stejné.
Všichni víme,
že hodina,
když budete plavat do stezy,
tak ten,
to, co zaplatíte,
tak jako není náklad,
že pokryjete 100%
nákladu toho bazénu.
Víme, že ne,
je to dotovaná cena
a tím pádem
je to to stejné
vlastně na těch kurtech.
A teď je otázka,
ale a proto vlastně
ta steza,
neočekávám za sebe,
že ona to promítne
do té ceny
s největší pravěpodobností,
protože to bude bráno,
že vlastně tu nějaká
cenová politika,
ale pokud ten trh to snese,
tak my určitě budeme
méně rádi,
pokud tam,
ale spončástečně
něco promítne.
Asi tak to vezmu koste.
A poprosím,
ještě chtěla reagovat
Katka Francová
a následně
pan Juráš.
Jenom krátká reakce,
když se bavíme
o toho bazénu,
tak v tom plave
více lidí,
než na tom kurcu,
kde cipinkají ti dva
maximálně čtyři.
V tom vidím
zásadní rozdíl.
Na ten rozdíl není
z pozice ekonomiky,
je to úplně jedno.
I kdyby na tom bazénu
byl jeden člověk
nebo sto,
tak prostě pořád řešíte,
jestli ten příjem
ze vstupného
vám zaplatí
ten provoz toho bazénu.
A to já vám říkám,
že ne.
A v tom tenisu
je to úplně to stejné.
Prostě je to otázka,
že něco stojí
provozování těch kurtů
a máte nějaký příjem
a pak se bavíte,
jestli to provozování,
jestli ten příjem
vám pokryje to provozování.
To znamená,
je to dotované
a bez ohledu na to,
jestli tam sportuje
jeden člověk nebo deset,
prostě něco zaplatí
a ten rozdíl
je prostě ta dotovaná cena.
Poprosím pana Juráše.
Děkuji za slovo,
pane primátore.
Já jenom tři poznámky
k tomu,
na co se ptala
paní Francová.
Ten vztah
z té zaměsto Zlín
zkusím takový příměr udělat.
Představme si,
že přijdete do hotelu.
Tak.
V tom hotelu se ubytujete
a někdo vám tam poskytne službu.
Vy si pronajmete to místo.
V tom,
že tam jste ubytování,
přespíte tam,
někdo vám tam udělá snídani.
Takže v této chvíli
jste za bučí městu
ten host toho hotelu.
A teď uděláme druhý příklad,
protože ten vztah je smíšený.
Máte krásný
novogotický dům
na Skocké Vysočine
a jak tam přijdete,
tak vystoupí váš majordomus
a řekne,
hele,
chtěli se tady ubytovat
tři turisti,
co šli kolem,
tak jsem jim ty volné pokoje dal,
vzal jsem z toho výnos,
zjistil jsem,
že máš prasklý potrubí,
tak jsem objednal opraváře,
jo a ještě jsem vzadu vysázel
nějaký kytky,
aby to tady vypadalo hezky.
To je váš zprávce.
On vám to zprávuje
a za to bere úplatu.
A jste zakombinuje
oba, dva ty postupy.
To je číslo jedna.
Takže ona si nastavuje
vlastní politiku zákazníkům
jako zprávce
a současně je ten host
ubytovaný v hotelu města.
Druhá věc,
která z toho plyne je,
že vy jste říkala,
nevydrželi bychom to ještě rok,
no, vytíženost je na zaplať
pán Boh vyšší.
Chodí tam víc lidí teď,
pokud já mám správné jako údaje.
Druhá věc,
chodí tam také proto,
že se zvyšil teplotní konfort.
Jinými slovy,
poslat tam vaše děti,
mladistvé,
aby trénovali v kulichu
a s hůtnými ponožkami tenis
není fé,
jako zase úplně nám nepřišlo,
jako dobrý.
A ta investice říká,
hele, ten náklad,
když tam museme jít stopit,
snižujeme,
z hlediska provozu schopnosti.
Takže tak, no.
Tak, děkuji za ta upřesnění.
Poprosím ještě pana Jandu.
Děkuji, pane primátore.
Dobrý den, dámy a pánové,
skoro poledne.
Já bych v té diskutované mladcové,
prosím,
jenom, aby jsme si uvědomili,
že odhadní cena byla
33 milionů korun
a my jsme to, prosím,
koupili za 15.
Takže samozřejmě,
jsme to koupili výhodně.
Koupili jsme pozemky,
chceme tam něco stmelit,
chceme to dát dohromady.
A že přijdeme s nějakou investicí,
která potom je následně
té rozdílně ceny nutná udělat.
Přece jako správný hospodář
před zimou tam nenecháme topit
v nějaké vzdálenosti,
ztrácíme tu energii.
A ti, co to navrhli,
to navrhli dobře, prosím.
Takže já bych to úplně neházel
na tu stezu jako takovou.
Co se týká stezy,
tak steza, já to považuji,
to, co jsme udělali,
to rozhodnutí v tomto zastupitelstvu.
Že jsme v podstatě zřídili
tuto organizaci pro ten sport,
tak to považuji za jedno
z nejlepších rozhodnutí,
které jsme mohli udělat.
Že jsme vlastně umožnili
v tomto městě,
nejenom tady diskutovaným
tenistům, plavcům a jiným,
ale že jsme jim se snažili
ty podmínky vytvořit
a já považuji,
že steza to dělá tak,
jak to dělá nejlépe
a samozřejmě všechno nejde,
jak bychom si představovali.
Ta firma se zcela určitě
taky nějakým způsobem učí
a ne všechno je tak černobíle,
jak o tom hovoříme.
Takže já jsem jenom chtěl říct,
že tyto věci,
co se týká mladcové,
za mě je to potřeba dostat
do nějaké kondice
a co se týká stezy,
jsem za to velmi rád,
že jsme takové rozhodnutí přijali.
Děkuji.
Morská děkuji za takový příspěvek.
Níkdo další se do diskuze nehlásí,
takže já vás poprosím,
pojďme zasovat materiál číslo 25.
Pro 25,
materiál číslo 25 byl přijat.
Materiál číslo 26 je dodatek
veřejno-podávní smlouvě
ze společnosti STEZA,
to znamená upravujeme
dodatkem věci,
které jsme již mě schválené
a více mě to vyšlo finančně jinak,
případně se ty finance používou
trošku na něco jiného,
tak jenom to máte dneska
v rámci dodatku.
To je k tomu dotazy.
Níkdo se do diskuze nehlásí,
prosím, pojďme zase
v materiál číslo 26.
Pro 29,
materiál číslo 26 byl přijat.
Materiál číslo 27 je předání
dětského dopravního hřiště
Domů dětí a mládeži Astra,
to znamená příspěch
koorganizace města Zlína.
Jsou k tomu nějaké dotazy?
Níkdo se do diskuze nehlásí,
prosím, pojďme hlasovat
materiál číslo 27.
Pro 31,
materiál číslo 27 byl přijat.
Materiál číslo 28 jsou dílčí změny pravidel
pro poskytování finanční podpory ve sportu.
Konkrétně se jedná o to,
že přidáváme program pro sport
handicapovaný, který jsme vždycky podporovali,
ale podporoval jsem mimo tento fond,
což nám nedávalo smysl.
A vzhledem k tomu,
že ty částky jsme dávali vždycky z rady,
tak v současné chvíli ta logika je ta,
a že upravíme pravidla,
aby umožnili i podporu
tady toho handicapovaného sportu
a ty finance, které byly dávány každoročně
pro ten sport handicapovaných,
se přesunou do tohoto fondu.
To znamená, jenom dáváme
tomu logiku takovou,
kterou to mít má.
Jsou k tomu nějaké dotazy?
Nikdo se do diskuze nehlásí.
Pojďme zase v materiál číslo 28.
Pro 33.
Materiál číslo 28 byl přijat.
Materiál číslo 29.
Jsou změny v komisích.
Jsou tu nějaké dotazy?
Nikdo se do diskuze nehlásí,
tak prosím, pojďme hlasovat o tom,
že tento bod budeme hlasovat aklamací.
Pro 32.
Takže hlasování pro střednictví aklamace
bylo přijato.
A teď pojďme aklamací hlasovat
samotný materiál číslo 29.
Pro 28.
Materiál číslo 29 byl přijat.
Materiál číslo 30
pojednává o úpravě jednoho termínu
zasedání zastupitelstva města Zína
v roce 2027.
Je to z důvodu toho,
že je vysoutěžená společnost,
která má stavět nové centrum služeb pro občany
prostřednictvím v ráji
vlastně rekonstrukce nebo víceméně přestavby
celé budovy číslo popisné 10.
Takže prostřednictvím tento dostavby
radnice získají návštěvníci do budoucna nový komfort,
ale vzhledem k tomu,
že to je v těsné blízkosti tady této obřadní síně,
tak během tady těchto hlučných prací
a tak dále se zastupitelstvo bude konat
na hotelu Zlín
a vzhledem k tomu,
když jsme poptávali ty volné termíny,
tak jeden termín byl obsazený
a museli jsme s tím právě o týden pohnout,
tak proto vlastně upravujeme termíny zastupitelstva,
které jsme nedávno schvalovali.
Takže to je ten důvod
a věříme tomu,
že ten komfort bude dostatečně zajištěný,
a takže na hotelu ty kapacity k tomu jsou
i vlastně na jednotlivé místnosti pro kluby a podobně,
takže věříme tomu,
že to bude dočasné, správné řešení
a umožníme tím pádem dostavbu tady
toho objektu sousedního vedle.
Poprosím ještě pana Jandu.
Já se hrozně umlouvám,
nechci to samozřejmě zdržovat,
jenom takový technický dotaz,
protože jednak je to o nákladech,
jednak je to asi o nějaké organizaci,
v sobotu tady jsou svatby,
vím, že to asi chceme dělat,
aby ty věci fungovaly,
rychle zrekonstruovat,
nicméně předpokládám,
že tady nebude zatěkat,
předpokládám, že jde jenom o ten hluk
a nedá se vykomunikovat s těmi stavaři,
že prostě soboty tady budeme oddávat,
protože prostě ta místnost je proto určená
a jednou za měsíc a půl tady budeme zasedat
a v ten den si buď vezmou dovolenou,
nebo ty zbíječky nebudou používat,
jenom otázka, nevím,
pěl jsem se na to zeptat, děkuji.
Možné to je,
ale zastavení stavby aktuálně se jeví
jako finančně náročnější,
než náš přesun.
Takže ta technika, která je tak,
my tak jsme v době covidu
zasedali v kongresovém centru,
tak prostě ty zkušenosti,
a ta poptávka je,
ale se vřeje zastavení stavby
je otázkou, jak si ta firma,
v jakém je stavu,
jak to vlastně zakonzervuje.
Takže aktuálně se to jeví takhle,
na druhou stranu neříkáme,
že se o tom nedá do budoucna dál jednat.
Ale to, co jsme zjišťovali,
tak je to vlastně aktuálně
tímto způsobem,
že to vychází do nás dráž,
to zastavení stavby.
Když je poprosím pana tajemníka,
aby to přesně...
Děkuju moc.
Skutečně to bourání
a potom následně ta stavba
bude poměrně náročná,
co se týká nejenom hluku.
My budeme tady ještě zatloukat
nějaké piloty a podobně
a nebudeme schopni garantovat,
že při těch svatbách,
případně při tom zastupitelstvu,
by jsme byli schopni
tu stavbu prostě v tu chvíli zastavit.
Proto jsme přistoupili pro 27
k tomu, co teďka schvalujete,
plus svatby jsme přesunuli
na kongresové centrum
a do nových multifunkčních prostor,
například v Lužkovicích,
vítání děti do života na Kvítkovou
a velké akce,
které tady připravujeme,
tak budeme mít v náhradních prostorech.
Je to víceméně pro bezpečnost
nebo pro bezpečnost,
je to pro hladký průběh těch akcí,
aby jsme potom tady
ve své podstatě neřešili
třeba ráno,
že nám stavbu hold nikdo nezastaví.
Ty náklady jsou vysoké,
od 20 do 100 tisíc
za zastavení stavby v ten den.
Takže jsme se rozhodli,
že pro nás bude
i pro vás komfortnější,
aby to tady neprobíhalo.
Uvidíme,
kdyby ty hrubé stavby
byly v roce 27 provedeny,
v roce 28 už by se jelo
ve vnitř té budově,
tak bychom samozřejmě
zvážili přesun zpět.
Děkuji.
Poprosím paní Francovou.
Já jsem se chtěla zeptat
ohledně těch svadeb.
My jsme přece zvažovali
využití zámku.
Já vím,
že se připravuje
oprava toho zámku,
ale nešlo pozastavit
tu opravu toho zámku,
tak, aby se tam
organizovali ty svadby,
proběhly tam tady
tyto aktivity,
protože si myslím,
že ten kuc je takový
jako složitý na ty svadby,
to vítání na té kvítkové.
Myslím si,
že senioři nejsou šťastní,
že netleskají.
Tak jenom,
to je můj dotaz,
proč nevyužijeme zámek,
nebo nemůžeme využít?
Zámek nevyužijeme,
protože od března
příštího roku
víceméně bude
celá lokalita oplocena
a vstup na zámek
budou mít pouze
ti, kteří tam mají nájem.
Nikdo další.
Začne kompletní
revitalizace sadu svobody
a tím pádem
celou lokalitu
kolem zámku
vlastně
bude staveniště.
Takže vlastně
vy se na zámek
jako nedostanete.
A takže
ta, že tím pádem
jako přesunout ty věci
na zámek
nedává vůbec
logiku
v současné chvíli.
Takže ta rekonstrukce
samotná sadu,
teda větéce sadu svobody
začne teďka v říjnu
prostřednictvím
jako kopání
víceméně
sklepních prostor
u zámku,
aby do budoucna
bylo možné
ten zámek
jako dotáhnout
tu rekonstrukci
vzduchotechnika
a všechno ostatní
nové normy,
nové rozvody
a ty věci,
co je potřeba
pro tu budovu.
Takže
s tím pádem
vlastně tohle děláme
jako by první etapu
v rámci té
revitalizace
sadu svobody.
Navazovat na to
bude od zhruba
února, března
podle toho,
jaká bude zima.
Očekáváme,
že od března
kompletní
revitalizace
sadu svobody,
která bude trvat
až do konce
roku 28.
Takže
tam vlastně
to je odpověď
proč ne zámek.
Samozřejmě jsme to zvažovali,
ale
nejsme schopni
jako na zámek
se přesunout
z těchto důvodů.
Děkuji za odpověď.
Je to škoda,
protože
si myslím,
že ten zámek by byl
takový jako
reprezentativnější
a
ale to je můj pocit,
že se to takhle
dostalo do souběhu
tady tyto věci.
Ale
chápu, že to nemůžete.
Děkuji.
Souhlasím,
že by to bylo
reprezentativnější,
ale
prostě
neumíme
dělat stavby
jako přes noc
a tím pádem
pokud se ve zimě
má něco dít,
tak
já jsem za sebe rád,
že ty věci,
co dneska schvalujeme,
případně to,
co schvaluje rada,
takže vlastně
proběhnou
a
já za sebe říkám
celo otevřeně,
že jsem strašně rád,
že to bude
a
ve výsledku
jestli
u těch pásek
v tom příštím období
budu já
nebo někdo jiný
to rozhodnou voliči,
ale hlavně, že to tady je.
Takže já to takto vnímám
a
prostě
ta doba je
a ty věci
nějakou dobu
trvají,
ty přípravy.
Jsme zároveň
v některých projektech
výrazně
pod
termíny,
svázání termín
dotačních titulů,
to, že právě
i ten sad svobody
a například
i velké kino,
které dneska máme
ještě na programu,
takže my si tam nemůžeme
moc vymýšlet,
že bychom toho půl roku
pozdrželi a tak dále.
To znamená,
využíváme externí financování,
co to jde,
abychom ty finance
multiplikovali
a vlastně
věci ve zně dělali.
Takže
to je ten stav,
že my za sebe,
já jsem strašně rád,
že se to podařilo dotáhnout
a
že to tady vlastně bude.
Prosím,
náměstka
Pavlábradu.
Já opět jenom
lehké doplnění.
Co se týče zámku,
tak tam očekáváme
úplně během teďka
velmi krátkého času
získání stavebního povolení
a bude na budoucí radě,
jestli tak projekt
relativně velký
jako rekonstrukce zámku
zpustí
nebo v nějaké omezené podobě,
takže
tam to moc smysl
opravdu nedává
a samozřejmě
v souvislosti se stranem
soubury
tak tež ne.
A ještě doplním,
že se tady teďka
připravujou změny,
které jsou asi největší
za 30 let
tady od revoluce,
takže
takže se máme na co těšit.
Máme se na co těšit,
bude to velice komplikované.
Ti, co tu budou sedět
v tom dalším období,
tak si vyslechnou
samé pochválné
řeči od občanů
o tom, jak se
je celé město rozkopané.
Bohužel prostě
zatím nikdo nevymyslel,
jak to stavět přes noc.
A poprosím paní Pešatovou.
Já jsem chtěla jenom
ujištění,
městský majetek
a že nemůžeme zasedat
v městském majetku.
Ano, prověřoval se
kongresové centrum,
zejména zkazen kapacity
vlastně naší velikosti
zastupitelstva.
Jiné čtyřeků
velké prostory nemáme.
Kongresové centrum
je z pravidla pro najato
zhruba na dva roky dopředu,
zejména v těch atrativních termínech.
Tady tomu není jinak.
To znamená
rušení těch jednotlivých akcí
a přesuny,
tak vlastně to finanční sráta
vyšší, než když zaplatíme
pro nájem
u hotelů z dým.
Takže takhle jsme
jakoby uvažovali,
prověřovali se ty kapacity
a ještě tak poprosím
ještě pana témníka,
aby mě doplnil,
protože to řešil
samozřejmě úřad.
My jsme měli takovou
menší pracovní skupinu,
kde byly matrikářky,
šéfové jednotlivých
zařízení
a už kongresového centra.
Hledali jsme ty varianty
tak, aby byly
reprezentativní,
to znamená,
co se týká svadev,
myslíme si,
že kongresové centrum
je dostatečně
reprezentativní prostor plus.
Má veškeré zázemí,
které potřebujeme
od parkování,
přes přípravny a podobně.
Co se týká
výtění dítí do života,
tak na té kvítkové
potřebujeme zase
přebalovací pulty
a tak dále
pro ty mimina,
takže i nám tam zaparkuje
dostatečný počet
rodičů u toho objektu.
Co se týká
kongresového centra
velkého sálu
pro zasedání zastupitelstva,
tak jsme naráželi
na obsazenost
a již na objednávané věci
v kongresovém centru.
To znamená,
museli bych to přesunout
jednání zastupitelstva
nepravidelně,
nebylo by to vždycky ve čtvrtek,
jednou by to bylo v pondělí,
jednou by to bylo ve středu,
jednou by to bylo možná
v pátek odpoledne.
Přistoupili jsme k tomu,
že pro nás je výhodnější
ten sál velkého kongresového centra
pronajmout externím subjektům,
co se týká cen,
a jít právě tady
do náhradních prostor
v interhotelu Zlín.
Tam, jak říkal pan primátor,
to má výhody.
Jsou tam salonky,
zároveň vás tam dokážeme
odstravovat,
plus je tam dostatečná
kapacita parkování
v okolí, kde zaparkujete.
Takže zvažovali jsme to
v té pracovní skupině
asi ze všech pohledů,
co nás napadly.
Děkuji.
To znamená,
je to takto jakoby aktuálně dáno.
Já jsem se bavil
i s panem Hejtmanem,
ten říkal,
že vzhledem té situaci,
která vlastně ve Zlíně je
tady v té stavbě,
takže si to dokáže představit,
že bychom přešli tam,
ale samozřejmě by to nebylo zadarmo.
Takže my na základě tady
těch informací,
kdy si představíme,
že bychom byli nahoře,
co se týká jakoby na 1.20,
ale pak zase řešíte,
jak už bylo řečeno
panem témníkem,
stravování,
řešíte i ty jednotlivé místnosti,
tak už do toho
mířeného diskomfortu
se tam dostáváte
a tím pádem jsme řekli,
že nebudeme vymýšlet
speciality se Zlínským krajem
a půjdeme do,
využijeme nabídku
na interneto Zlín,
která byla,
když to řeknu,
slušně řečeno,
jakoby zajímavá,
prostě nebylo to o tom,
že by nás tady přetáli
finančně někdo ví kam.
Takže šli jsme touto cestou
a zároveň tím pádem
nejsme v té situaci,
kdy jedno zastupitelstvo
potenciálně omezuje druhé.
Tak nikdo další
se v diskuze nehlásí,
tak prosím pojďme hlasovat
materiál číslo 30.
Pro 34,
materiál číslo 30 byl přijat.
Materiál číslo 31,
jednací řád zastupitelstva města Zlína.
Vy si určitě všichni pamatujete,
že jsme v průběhu tohoto
vlebního období
řešili úpravu jednacího řádu.
My jsme ji potom
následně nedotáhli
zcela otevřeně,
protože se řešili
na tvé připomínky
a v současné chvíli,
takže poslední zastupitelstvo,
tak jsme říkali,
že by bylo vhodné
ty věci dotáhnout,
protože tam byly za nás
konstruktivní připomínky
od vás všech.
Stejně tak se upravila
v některých věcech
legislativa,
takže proto vlastně
jsme to předložili,
aby to budoucí zastupitelstvo
města Zlína mělo,
když to řeknu,
ten jednací řád
v souladu
s aktuální legislativou.
Jsou k tomu nějaké dotazy?
Nikdo se do diskuze nehlásí
a já bych chtěl
ještě moc krát poděkovat
za ty konstruktivní připomínky,
které jste nám sice,
není to tak,
sice už je toho něco déle,
ale jste nám poskytli
a jsme rádi,
že tady to jednací řád
zase bude konstruktivní reál.
Moc krát děkuju.
Pojďme tady hlasovat
o materiál číslo 31.
Pro 33.
Materiál číslo 31 byl přijat.
Materiál číslo 32,
rozpočtová opatření,
zase navýšení a přesuny,
jsou k tomu dotazy.
Nikdo se do diskuze nehlásí,
tak prosím,
pojďme hlasovat
materiál číslo 32.
Pro 25.
Materiál číslo 32 byl přijat.
Materiál číslo 33
týkající se pozemku
a majetko právních úkonů,
k němu dotazy.
Do diskuze se nikdo nehlásí,
takže prosím,
pojďme hlasovat
materiál číslo 33.
Doblížíme.
Pro 25.
Materiál číslo 33 byl přijat.
Materiál číslo 34
týkající se projednání výběru
dodavatelé a uzavření smluv
v zadávacím řízení
pro revitalizaci velkého kina
ve Zdíně.
Všichni víme,
že kino je 10 let zavřené.
Aktuálně vlastně
proběhla soutěž,
kterou máme ukončit
vlastně tady dneska
na zastupitelstvu
návrhem na výběr zhotovitele.
Zcela otevřeně ta soutěž
probíhala zhruba
půl roku
z různých důvodů.
Můžu říct si,
že na začátku
projevili zájem,
podali vlastně vůbec
kvalifikace
do této soutěže
pět subjektů.
Postupem času
vlastně v tom průběhu
toho jednaceho řízení,
jak probíhalo,
tak následně indikativní nabídku
podali již jenom dva,
na základě,
kterých potom
probíhalo jednání
s těmito dvěma subjekty.
A pak
tu ostrou nabídku,
jak se říká,
nebo se tu závěrečnou nabídku
podali tyto dva subjekty,
které také vlastně
vlastně dali tu indikativní.
Z nich bylo vyhodnoceno,
že nejekonomičtější
je nabídka
společnosti PSG Construction,
kterou tady máte předloženou,
která v sobě zahrnuje
i stavbu podzemního parkování,
které má mít kapacitu
zhruba 350 parkovacích míst,
z nichž koncesní smlouvou
zavazujeme 260,
protože těchto 260 míst
zavázených koncesní smlouvou
budou povinně veřejná
a zbytlá parkovací místa
bude moci budoucí provozovatel,
potažmo tento investor,
například využít,
kdyby někdo v okolí
chtěl například
dlouhodobé parkování,
tak vlastně tuto kapacitu
nad rámec těch 260 míst
bude moci využít
i tímto způsobem.
Ta cena velkého kina
byla zastropována,
cena je víceméně
takřka zhodná s tím stropem.
Je potřeba říct si,
že máme na rekonstruci velkého kina
dva dotační tituly.
V současnosti ten součet
těch dotačních titulů
vychází zhruba na 192 milionů korun.
A v kina,
respektive ze současného kina,
tak po té rekonstruci tohoto objektu
vznikne opravdu
multifunkční objekt
se dvěma sály,
kde bude moci dělat
takřka všechno,
kdy vycházíme z praxe
z kongresového centra.
Co se týká provozu velkého kina,
počítáme aspoň za nás.
Uvidíme, jak se rozhodne
budoucí vedení města.
My předpokládáme,
počítáme,
že by vlastně vedení
kongresového centra
řešilo provoz také velkého kina,
abychom optimalizovali náklady.
S tím, že samozřejmě
se dějí všechny kroky k tomu,
aby tam byl odpočet DPH,
protože ta položka,
ta cifra, které se bavíme,
je bez DPH.
Co se týká parkoviště,
tak my jsme otevřeně
stala rádi,
že se našel subjekt,
který jde do této velké výzvy,
protože dlouho jsme jednali
s budoucností náměstí práce,
protože náměstí práce
v současné době
je převážně povrchové parkování
a s náměstním to nemáme společného.
Takže jsme udělali
předběžně tržní konzultace,
kdy jsme se ptali firm,
jestli vnímají,
že je vhodné
nebo více méně,
jestli je lepší
stavět to parkoviště
dohromady s kinem
anebo zvlášť,
jestli jsou toho vůbec schopní
i v tom časovém horizontu,
který nám dává dotační titul.
Odpověď byla více mě jednoznačná,
že samozřejmě parkoviště
v budoucnu postavit půjde,
ale za mnohem vyšší náklady,
než když to spojíme
s sestavou kina.
Proto jsme se rozhodli udělat
soutěžným způsobem,
že jsme vlastně dali
i možnost stavět
přímo i s tím podzemním parkováním
a v současné době máme
koncesní smlouvu
na provoz těchto parkoviště
na 70 let,
respektive, že na 70 let
to podzemní parkování
přejde bezúplatně městu.
Každopádně ta koncesní smlouva
více méně umožňuje
tři typy provozu budoucího.
První varianta je,
že investor bude také provozovat,
to znamená řeší cenotvorbu,
má příjem.
Varianta druhá,
investor zajistí provozování
prostřednictví městské společnosti,
to znamená řeší cenotvorbu,
příjem.
A zároveň platí někomu
za provozování.
Varianta třetí je,
že investor vezme
kompletně celý objekt stavby
a tento projme
za nějakou cenu městu,
po případě městské společnosti,
která následně provozuje,
řeší cenotvorbu
a má také příjem.
Tyto tři varianty jsou
v současné době obsaženy
v koncesní smlouvě
a na základě některých jednání,
která ještě probíhala,
za které jsem strašně rád,
protože samozřejmě
se přiznám,
že nemám úplně radost toho,
že to řešíme na poslední zastupitelstv,
vzhledem k tomu,
že se s ním tady řešíme
opravdu mnoho let,
ale ta soutěž se prodlužovala
vzhledem
ke komplikovosti celého toho projektu,
tak jsme diskutovali
s subjekty,
které mají,
kteří jsou majitele objektů
na náměstí práce,
jak to vidí do budoucna,
stejně tak jsme se bavili
právě s investorem
a s největší pravěpodobností
bude využita do budoucna
do celého provozování
jedna z těch,
řekněme,
druhá nebo třetí varianta,
to znamená,
to provozovat bude
buď zcela,
anebo částečně
městská společnost.
Přemýšlím,
na co jsem zapomněl.
Zapomněl jsem na to,
že v rámci té koncesní smlouvy
se zavazujeme k tomu,
že rušíme to povrchové parkování
a je potřeba říct si,
že na základě těch jednání,
které probíhalo ještě včera,
tak je dohodatá,
že není potřeba
případně rušit
povrchová parkování,
pokud příjemcem
parkovného na tomto
povrchovém parkování
bude investor toho podzemního,
neboli konkrétně jsme se bavili
na to, jestli je opravdu potřeba
zrušit parkoviště
mezi obchodňákem a tržnicí.
Současný stav je ten,
že tak, jak to máme dneska
předloženo, tak kde se zavazujeme,
že ho zavřeme,
tak ten stav je předjednaný
k tomu, že tomu tak být nemusí,
pokud příjemcem samozřejmě
bude investor toho podzemí
a tím by ta kapacita
zůstala ještě více navýšená
než v současné době.
To jenom asi, ať si řekneme,
že to má ještě nějaký vývoj
a já předpokládám,
že bude uzavřen určitě
ještě nějaký dodatek v průběhu těch dvou let
té celé stavby,
protože samozřejmě to bude
ještě dost práce,
protože město se bude
samozřejmě usilovně
snažit spolupracovat
na právě vůbec
celém řešení té lokality
a já věřím tomu,
že právě od toho roku
29 se opravdu z náměstí práce
stane ta pobytově relaxační zóna
s dostatkem parkování
a s velmi navštěvovaným velkým kinem,
kdy velké kino v současné chvíli nepočítáme,
že bude konkurencí kongresového sálu,
protože kongresový sál je typově
jiný objekt
a hlavně jeho náplněho rezervace
jsou na dva roky víceméně dopředu
obsazeny
v těch atrativních termínech.
Takže je to zároveň pořád sídlo filharmonie,
s čím vlastně počítáme,
takže samozřejmě i ten kongresový sál
má svá specifika
a tady, co se díká velkého kina,
tak bude to víceméně více
industriální stavba, než kongresové centrum,
které je zase více reprezentativní.
Toč asi za mě v kostce
dlouhý krátký úvod,
otvírám diskuzi.
Nikdo se do diskuzi nehlásí?
Zkusil jsem.
Říkal jsem si, že nikdo nic.
Byl jsem pomalý.
Poprosím pana Vančeru.
Dobře, děkuju, pane primátore.
Já na úvod, dovolte
smělou otázku na vás všechny,
kdo z vás dokázal
přečíst, neříkám
prostudovat
všechny materiály
na dnešní zastupitelstvo.
Ten původní materiál
několik set stran
a pak jsme přidali
dalších 31 souborů,
538 stran textu,
215 tisíc slov
a ještě 21 příloh
s téměř 9 tisíci buňkami.
A týkající se
samozřejmě toho
klíčového
rozhodování dneska,
který se týká
Velkého kina
a parkoviště.
A připomínám,
měli jsme 6 dnů na to,
abychom se rozhodli
o závazku
na dalších 70 let.
My jsme, musím říct,
dělali všechno,
co bylo v našich silách,
co jsme mohli.
Víte, že jsme adresovali
radě více jak 50 připomínek.
Měli jsme několik schůzek,
ale stejně musím říct,
že nebylo zdaleka
v naší moci
postihnout vše.
Nebudou o tom mluvit,
mý kolegové myslím.
A proto se dneska
k tomu materiálu
zdržíme přihlasování.
Ne, že by nebyl potřebný,
ale je to i pro vás
vysvětlení,
proč jsme se zdrželi
i v dalších bodech
týkajících se investice,
protože opravdu jsme
nebyli schopni
pojmout vše,
tak, jak jsme zvyklí.
A jak jsme
konec konců zavázáni
i slibem města,
městu a občanů.
Co se domnívám ještě
do této diskuze patří?
Je evidentní,
že nám v oblasti
velkých investic
schybí zkušenost kontinuita.
Je to prostě jasné,
my jsme vlastně poslední
takovou soutěž organizovali
nebo takovou přípravu
organizovali před vlastně
20 lety, když jsme stavili
kulturní a univerzitní centrum.
A je jasné,
že to je proces,
který je náročný.
Nejenom pro vás radní,
ale taky pro naše úředníky,
kteří vlastně všechny ty materiály
připravují a chystají.
A myslím si,
že je opravdu potřeba,
aby jsme na to mysleli.
I s hledem na to,
co nás čeká.
A to je ostatně i to,
po čem už jsme dneska volali
pro tak významné věci.
Je potřeba,
abychom byli schopni
zkoncentrovat potenciál,
který máme na zastupitelstvu,
protože přesvědčovat se o tom nemusíme.
Jsou to vážná rozhodnutí,
chyby jsou drahé,
takže poprosím,
až budeme dělat něco příště,
abychom se poučili z chyb,
které třeba vidíme,
především ty procesní organizaci,
abychom z tohoto příkladu vyšli,
co můžeme,
doufáme nakonec vítězně,
ale především poučením.
Děkuju za pozornost.
Určitě děkuju
a já tu připomínku naprosto beru.
My jsme si to říkali
a jak jsem řekl,
já taky zaště nejá sám,
mě se novináři v rámci tadyto volebního roku,
já si mě v únoru se mě ptali,
že nás opozice viní z toho,
že schválně všechno budeme dělat
jako před volobama kvůli kampaní
a to všechno ostatní.
Já jsem mi odpověděl tehdy na prostřednu duše.
Já jsem říkal,
já bych byl tak strašně rádi,
bychom ty věci schválili už v listopadu
a v prosinci a mě na všechno klid.
Takže určitě to není na schvál,
jenom za sebe
a chtěl bych moc krát poděkovat všem,
kteří vlastně tomu věnovali
spoustu svého času
a poslali nějaké připomínky
nebo otevřit nějakou diskuzi
a myslím si,
že já jsem se osobně snažil
udělat maximum tomu,
abychom si všechny ty věci vysvětlili
se všemi, kteří jste se mi ozvali,
se všemi dotazy, které proběhly.
Organizoval jsem různé schůzky
a tak dál,
takže snažil jsem se tomu pomoct.
Ale já tady jenom řeknu jedinou věc,
kterou si myslím,
že je právě tou otázkou,
že v případě,
že budou nějaké takovéto větší projekty,
jako jak to dobloucna řešit,
co se týká opravdu toho procesu,
protože co se týká velkého kina,
tak o něm tady mluvíme roky.
Tam, když to je ani samotný projekt,
tam není nic nového,
co bychom teďka,
že bychom vysoutěžili,
že místo dvou sálů tam budou čtyři a podobně.
Prostě více véně víme,
jak to má vypadat.
A jenom se nám podařil
tady ten malý zázrak,
že k tomu budeme mít rovnou
i to podzemní parkování.
To znamená,
tak jak my jsme viděli
ve všech těch architektonických,
jako říkajme, návrcích,
které jsme měli
od vítězného studia,
kde před kinem není žádné parkoviště,
ale je tam ta pijaceta
a navazující na pobytové relaxační zónu,
tak se nám to vlastně podařilo udělat.
Ale co se týká toho procesu,
tak to je to,
co vlastně nás správně,
nám správně vytýkáte za mě,
ale zároveň já říkám,
že dneska vlastně uzavíráme
tu veřejnou soutěž.
A já vlastně sám teďka
hlavě a ji přemýšlím,
jako v jaké fázi
my jsme schopni zveřejnit ty smlouvy,
abychom je vám dali k dispozici,
ať si dám udáte připomínky.
A netýká se tam toho kina,
je to to stejné,
co jsem říkal,
u toho Boněcké rybníku
a Březnické.
Protože vlastně
ve chvíli my rozjedeme soutěž
a je tam nějakým úsobem mluva,
je ta soutěž je veřejná,
ale potom už následně
samozřejmě dochází
k nějakým jednáním
v rámci té veřejné soutěže.
Tak vlastně to vím já,
tak my jsme se nedostali k tomu,
kde by byl prostor to někde otevřít
jako ještě nějakému širšímu fóru.
Takže určitě si myslím,
že toto je to ponaučení,
že to musíme najít,
protože když to nenajdeme,
tak se stejně dostaneme do situace,
že potom bude předkládána
hotová smlouva,
bez té možnosti,
aby bylo možné upravit jinak,
než dodatky.
A to je to,
co vlastně dneska tady řešíme,
že ať už Boněcký rybního,
Březnická,
tak jsme mě nějaké připomínky
za mě konstruktivní
a tady určitě taky.
Ale myslím si,
že ta soutěž,
že vlastně ta legislativa té soutěže
umožňuje některé vstupy,
ale není jich úplně mnoho.
Takže tam já souhlasím s tím,
že se na to musíme
do budoucna podívat,
nebo respektive budoucí vědení města Zlína,
aby ta informovanost zastupitelstva
byla co největší.
A díky tomu potom,
samozřejmě jste všichni věděli dříve,
co vlastně ty smlouvy obsahují,
protože byste byli nějakým zem součástí
toho připomínkování
nebo toho vyjednávacího procesu.
Ale je otázkou,
jak to nastavit.
Takže tady to za sebe vnímám určitě,
tak jako ten správný podnět,
že do budoucna
si tohoto musíme zjít po naučení
a hledat tu cestu.
Takže děkuju za to
a i za tu aktivitu vašich,
za ty dotazy
a za všechno,
co proběhlo v tom mezidobí.
Poprosím paní Francovou.
Já bych chtěla za nás říct,
že ano,
chtěli jsme velké kino.
Deset let je zavřené,
jsme za to moc rádi,
i když teda cena se
vynásobila,
která se předpokládala dříve.
Zase na druhé straně je skvělé,
že teda máme tam dotaci
těch 192 milionů,
to jsme rádi,
to oceňujeme.
Ale také nás trápí,
množství materiálů,
trápí nás těch,
ten 70 letý závazek.
Je pravda,
že teď tě můžeme říct,
tady všem,
ale nám to jedno není.
Trošku mi tam vadí třeba
jenom 3 parkovací místa,
které tam máme zdarma.
Vadí nám tam,
nebo nám obecně,
protože jsme se o tom bavili
také dohromady,
strávili jsme nějakým spoustu času.
Zákaz parkování v okolí,
jak je to okolí široké,
zákaz vybudování,
jakéhokoliv našeho parkovacího domu,
to znamená,
ta březnická tam neplatí,
to je v pořádku,
asi ano,
ale nenašla jsem tam nikde mapku.
A další věc,
co mě trápí,
tak přemýšlím,
kde budou parkovat teďka občany letné,
když začneme budovat velké kino,
začneme budovat vlastně březnickou,
tak tam je odsuneme,
myslíme na to,
když nebudeme moc parkovat na povrchu,
takže je tam spousta,
jako kdyby neznámých,
je toho fakt hodně,
je to velký projekt,
to určitě,
je to projekt,
který asi všichni chceme,
ale zatím teď se musíme zdržet.
Co se líká těch parkovišt,
tak je tam vlastně v příloze byla mapka
a ono je možná tím,
že ta přílohy byly nahrané bokem,
tak to vlastně jste si možná nestáhli úplně v pohodě.
Mapka říká to,
že, a ty to řeknu v kostce,
povrchová parkoviště,
která jsou právě v okolí,
to znamená,
bavíme se konkrétně místa za závorou,
která jsou součástí parkoviště Velkého kina,
mimo parkoviště nad obchodním domem
a v rámci té mapky
jsou také místa u hotelů Zlín,
které jsou na pozemku města Zlína,
které tady nejsou za závorou,
ale jsou nějakým způsobem teďka,
nechci jít poplatněna,
ale jsou v nějakém vztahu s hotelem
a je tam také to parkoviště
mezi tržnicí a obchodním domem.
A to bylo,
když se řeknu,
tím největším tématem,
co jsme víceméně řešili.
Ta logika byla jednoduchá
v rámci investora,
protože,
ale když se řeknu,
další lokality samozřejmě,
toto je celé,
tak já to řeknu,
protože my samozřejmě víme,
že máme stavět parkovací dům
na Březnické,
kde ta logika naše je ta,
že první,
co v té lokalitě vznikne dřív,
než se začne cokoliv tam rušit,
je ten parkovací dům.
A to je to,
co musí z pozice města,
musíme hodně spěchat,
abychom právě tu kapacitu tam řekneme,
tam je se skoro zdvojná sobí
proti tomu,
co je tam teď.
Takže ten parkovací dům
jako naprosto zasaturuje
vlastně to povrchové parkování,
které je teďka na té rozvoji
lokalitě Březnická
a samozřejmě pomůže,
jak lidem z letné,
z okolí,
ale případně i těm,
kteří vlastně budou mít pak dobrou snad
v nějakém čase
do nějaké míry omezené
to parkování u velkého kina,
kdy je snahou
a bude vlastně na to vytvořená
také dohoda
o maximalizaci počtu parkovacích míst
v průběhu stavby toho velkého kina.
To znamená, aby to nebylo,
že si investor to oplotí
a nic mě nezajímá,
ale aby to bylo opravdu
jenom na tu nejnutnější dobu,
aby prostě by ta maximalizace míst
byla pod sourobu té stavby.
A ta debata byla o tom,
že aby to nějakým způsobem vycházelo,
to znamená,
my jsme v průběhu,
my jsme měli předběžně tržní konzultace,
tak jedna s firm,
která se nám tam přihlásila,
tak sama napsala,
že má například
koncesní smlouvu s Prahou.
Koncesní smlouva je na to,
že vybuduje a bude provozovat
obchodní dům
s parkovacím domem pod zemím
a ta smlouva je na 50 let.
To znamená,
vy v tu danou chvíli
vlastně máte ale příjmovou položku
v rámci toho obchodního domu.
My jsme začínali tu soutěž s tím,
že jsme říkali až 70 let,
protože jsme sami doufali,
že to někdo zkrátí.
Zcela otevřeně nám chodili
jako informace ve stylu 70 let,
na tuto stavbu jste se zbláznili
jako 80, 90, 100 a podobná čísla.
Takže my jsme z tohoto neuhli
a zůstali jsme na těch 70
a proto říkám,
že je to za nás úspěch,
že se někdo takový podobně znašel.
A zároveň na druhou stranu
té investice,
která není malá pod stůzem,
tak vlastně vychází ta logika,
že byla ambice přesunout
to parkování opravdu do toho podzemí,
aby vlastně nahoře byl opravdu
pobytový a relaxační prostor všude.
A více méně na základ těch jednání
jsme se uhli do té pozice,
kdy naprosto se rozumíme obavám
některých těch soukromých subjektů,
které tam jsou.
A vlastně otevřeně dnes k dnešnímu dní
můžu říct,
že vlastně je dohoda,
která není v té koncesní smlouve,
protože v ní nemůže být obsažena,
protože to nebylo součástí soutěže,
ale že samozřejmě ty parkoviště,
teď to řeklám příklad mezi tou tržnící obchodňákem,
nemusí být zrušena,
pokud ten příjem půjde,
ale tomu investorovi tedy postaví to podzemí.
Je to i z důvodu toho,
když se podíváte na obsazenost těch parkovišt
aktuálně,
tak vlastně kdybychom to nechali z provozu
s tím, že to není příjem toho investora,
tak samozřejmě ten odliv
finančních prostředků,
že mu jako není úplně malý
a pak vlastně mi vůbec nevycházela
ta ekonomika toho parkovacího domu,
takže je to nějakým způsobem něco za něco,
na druhou stranu ten počet se tam navyšuje,
protože za mě je to podstatné
a za mě jsem strašně rád,
že máme i seriózního partnera,
který vlastně opravdu je odzkoušený,
že v té lokalitě,
v Zvezlíně a okolí,
prostě když něco dělá,
tak to dělá postivě, pořádně
a zároveň je ochoten vlastně
jednat o čemkoliv,
takže to si myslím,
že ve výsledku je to velice dobře.
Ačkoliv to má samozřejmě rizika,
já jsem si nedokázal nikdy představit
před těmi osmi lety,
kdy jsem nastupoval,
kdy jsem sám nadával na smlouvy,
co se týká nájemní smlouvy,
podchodu na desítky let
zášílených podmínek,
když jsou dnešní optikou,
tak jsem za sebe říkal,
že si nedokážu představit
jako takovéto smlouvy uzavírat.
A věřte mi,
že jsem byl ten první,
který nejvíc prskal,
když jsme se až ty bavili
tady v těch desítkách let,
ale prostě ta čísla,
ta ekonomika tam je
v současné chvíli jakoby jasná.
Poprosím pana Jandu.
Děkuji, panu primátore,
nechci dlouho zdržovat.
Za mě je jenom podpora
těch velkých projektů,
které sice vypadají,
že se vlastně řeší
až v závěru volebního období.
Nicméně podívejme se
na rozvoj okolních měst,
ať už je to kromě říž,
v Setín, Hradiště.
Myslím si, že po těch 30 letech,
kdy se nám podařilo
kongresové centrum,
jedna z největších staveb,
tady tyto staveby by měly být zelenou,
město by mělo jít nahoru,
mělo by být moderní,
ti lidé si to přejí
a za mě mimo deficit dopravy,
který je ještě vážnou otázkou,
tak si myslím,
že tyto projekty by měly být
jednoznačně zelenou.
Děkuji.
Moc krát děkuji
a další se hlásí pan Juráš.
Děkuji, pane primátore.
My jsme si asi už to podstatné řekli,
já jenom i pro kolegy zastupitele,
protože se to zaslouží.
My jsme nad tím strávili
poměrně hodné času.
Prostřednictvím pana primátora
jsme radě města Zlína
zaslali 56 otázek,
z nich sedm jsme považovali
za natokritických,
aby jsme vůbec souhlasili
s projednáváním toho materiálu.
A zbytek nám bude zodpovězeno.
Odpovědi jsme dostali,
já se k ním jenom ve stručnosti vrátím.
Dokonce jsme si našli i prostor
sestkat se ze zástupci investora,
aby jsme vlastně slyšeli tu jejich optiku,
jak o nějak tím smýšlí.
A myslím, že tady máme zástupce
investora dneska
a uvidíme, co nám k tomu poví.
My doufáme pevně,
že to, co povídal nám,
když jsme se ho na to ptali.
A to území není jednoduché.
Je tam povrch.
My jsme sledovali cíl,
že uděláme rekonstrukci velkého kina.
K tomu jsme přidělali ten parkovací dům,
aby jsme odebrali to parkování z povrchu.
Jestli jsme to měli soutěžit samostatně,
nebo ne, já nechám bokem.
Jsme tam, kde jsme.
Ale to, co my víme
a co nám brání o tom odpovědně hlasovat,
je, že ze všeho, co jsme my viděli,
tak plynou celkem tři věci.
Ta první.
My nemáme zpracovánu žádnou variantu
pořízení a provozu toho parkovacího domu,
kdybychom to dělali sami.
To znamená, kdyby to stavilo město
a provozovalo to po tu dobu.
Nemáme zpracované žádné jiné varianty
délek koncesní lúty.
Těch 70 let samo o sobě není problém.
To si myslím, že může být,
i když se to zdá dlouho,
problém je koncovka.
Jak z toho modulu vyskočit,
když to budu chtít.
A to je ta poslední připomínka.
My to máme trošku nastavené tak,
že pro město to bude náročné
z toho modelu odejít v této chvíli.
A to je to, co nás na tom zamrzelo.
A to je všechno.
Děkuji.
Poprosím pana Simkoviče.
Já bych navázal,
asi přednáště panu Juráš,
že je to podobně.
To vnímáme my.
Je to stejně jak u té březnické.
V rámci těch pojistek
a té pozice toho města
v tom projektu,
jak je nastavený.
Jsme velmi rádi,
že tamto parkujiště
vybuduje při tady tomto.
I to, že je to lokální investor,
který do toho jde
s velmi dobrou reputací,
se vším ostatním.
Tohle všechno jsou pozitiva.
Na držostanu mám-li rozhodovat
s pozicem města,
tak potřebu uznát
tu sílu i toho modelu,
jak to bude,
jak bude nastavené parkovné,
jaká je ta možnost města
vstupovat do regulaci toho parkovného.
Oblivnit trošičku politiku
toho parkovného.
Je to jedna z věcí,
která nám, řekl si,
jede za námi,
protože úplně nechat to
líbovolně zdivočit
by asi nebylo optimální.
Takže to tam nikde nemáme.
Jsme nejaké tak jako ukončení,
případně předčasné vypovědní smlouvy,
jaké bude technické zhodnocení těch budov,
jaké tam mají nějaké parametry
technologické a podobně.
Tohle všechno vlastně netam,
anebo jsem nenašel,
pomlouvám se v tom krátkém čase,
tak to je taky věc,
která nám trošičku v tom brání,
aby jsme tohle podpořili,
takže se zdržíme,
tak jak jsme říkali.
Jasné, já vám rozumím prakticky.
Já odpovím,
že sehlásí ještě
pan námestek Rechalánek,
která vám asi řekne,
co se týká těch financí,
týkají těch modelů,
proč mě například nemáme,
protože na to nemáme,
asi v koste.
Ne na to,
že nemáme peníze na to,
abychom si nechali udělat model,
ale nemáme na tu budoucí realizaci.
To je strašně neduché,
ale on vám to vysvětlí mnohem lépe
a konkrétněji.
Já jsem to vzal po loupatě.
Každopádně cenotvorba
naprosto s vámi souhlasím,
my jsme to řešili taky.
To je to, proč jsem říkal,
že jsme nějaké tři modely,
ve kterých jsem i říkal,
kdo bude určovat cenotvorbu.
Každopádně cenotvorbu
můžete říkat,
že bude určovat jeden nebo druhý,
nebo nejdebo, že nějaký třetí a tak dál.
Prostě ta smlouva něco umožňuje.
Ale zároveň
tím hlavním hybatelem
té ceny parkovného bude trh.
Protože nikdo není takový blázenový
postavl parkoviště,
které tam kde nasadí takovou cenu,
že pak bude prázdné.
Takže v tu danou chvíli
naopak bude motivace
ho mít co nejvý splné,
takže samozřejmě se budeme bavit
v těch dalších letech
a já si myslím, že
tak jak jsem řekl,
že vzhledem tomu,
že to spíše inklinuje
k těm variantám
nějaké spolupráci s městem,
tak se toho nějakým
se neobávám,
protože ta lokalita
vlastně v současné době
je hodně navštěvovaná
a myslím si,
že toto tomu jenom pomůže.
Takže obecně,
když se hlavně podíváte
na dopravu ve Zlíně,
je to téma,
které tady řešíme
ve volbách úplně všichni
a zcela otevření,
že vezmete,
že Zlín je v údolí,
máme tu třílu Tomáše Vati,
několik let
tady do Božstna
nebudeme mít
nějakou novou propojku
mezi dálnicí D49 a D55,
to nebude za rok hotové,
budeme rádi,
že to bude za deset,
si pojďme taky říct,
pokud to mám jako kompletní propoj.
Takže dostáváme se do situace,
že město Zlín je počáteční
a konečnou stanicí
pro většinu dopravy,
transitní doprava je tu asi 12%,
takže vy se dostáváte do situace,
kdy hledáte řešení,
jak ta auta s tady má vlastně vytěsnit.
Řešení jsou relativně ne,
že jednoduchá,
ale jsou více mě politicky nepříjemná,
ale potom,
co se zavedou modré zóny,
to znamená podpora rezidenčního parkování,
tak vám to umožní udělat případně další krok
a to je ten,
že rapidně zdražíte parkování
a nebo snížíte počet parkovacích míst
v těch ulicích,
u těch rodinných domů,
kde nám všichni stojí různě zadarmo
a díky modrým zonám už ne zadarmo,
ale pořád tam vlastně nějaký poplatek
nějakým se můžou stát.
To znamená tady tou,
můžeme říct tím navýšením,
tím krokem,
to můžete ve výsledku
ten počet automobilů snížit,
protože existuje městská hromadná doprava,
existuje integrovaná doprava z lindského kraje,
máme to víceméně provázané,
stále více,
ale samozřejmě,
když už se mě dojede,
tak by měl mít kde zaparkovat.
To znamená,
když mu to za to stojí,
tak jak se mě dojede.
Ale samozřejmě ten krok
případného zdražení
bude nepopulární
a bude to nějaké politické rozhodnutí,
stejně jako je politické rozhodnutí,
například cena městské hromadné dopravy
a podobně,
na kterou doplácíme
prostě přes 200 milionů ročně,
aby lidé mohli cestovat
za tu cenu,
za kterou cestují.
Takže já tím jenom chci říct,
že ten trh něco řekne,
ale zároveň
i vlastně ta situace
v těch budoucích letech
bude nějakým způsobem
motivovat
budoucí vedení města
nějakým způsobem
tu cenu tvorbu určovat
tam, kde může
a když ji bude určovat
tam, kde může,
tak pořád je to převážná
většina parkovišť
v rámci města Zdína
a tím pádem
tady to parkovišť
například
bude v největší peněstí
v nějakém vleku
a uvidíme.
Nemyslím si,
že by,
nemám obavu toho,
že by jakýkoliv investor
napádl cenu takovým způsobem,
že mu tam nikdo bude parkovat,
protože ekonomicky naopak
bych se bál toho,
že bude se snažit
mít tu cenu nižší
než ty okolní parkoviště
a být naopak
ty auta tam měl.
Aby vlastně
a tím si navýšil příjem
na úkor příjmu města.
Ale myslím si,
že ten trh
to pak rozhodne.
Poprosím náměstka Mirka Chalánka
a já pak jenom
Pane primátore.
Já pak jenom ještě
pro něj to skočím.
Tu mám opravdu zástupce
společnosti PSG Construction
tak já potom bych ho vyzval,
jestli by nám k tomu taky řekl
nějaký svůj postoj
nebo vizi,
jak to aktuálně vnímají
ať i vy také víte,
jak se k tomu vlastně staví
a to je to,
co říkají pan Juráš,
jestli vlastně
ať tady mám
nějakou reakci
toho,
jak to vlastně
k tomu přistupuje
ten potenciální investor,
protože do dnešního dne
aktuálně není schválený.
Tak poprosím Mirka Chalánka
a pak musím jenom.
Já děkuju za slovo
na primátore.
Já jenom v rychlosti.
Chce poděkovat všem,
kteří se na tom projektu podíleli
a včera jsme ště
některé věci dohlaďovali,
vzájemně si vysvětlovali,
takže já chci poděkovat
za tu aktivitu,
která vzdychla,
protože
jsme si některé věci,
v některých věcech
jsme si ujasnili,
některé jsme si potvrdili
a to je vždycky
jako u takového velkého projektu
dobré.
A nebylo to jenom
v rámci politického spektra,
ale byli tam i zástupci
vlastně těch objektů,
kterých se to dotýká soukromých,
takže jsme si některé věci vyjasnili,
včetně investora skupiny PSG.
Takže za to moc děkuju všem.
Reakce na pana Juráše,
proč ne my sami
a nemáme ten model?
Já to řeknu tak,
my když jsme připravovali
vlastně středně doby výhled,
rozpočet a tak dál,
máme nějaké možnosti
finanční zlízka toho salda
a tak dál,
tak my jsme se tím nezabývali,
protože cena té rekonstrukce
toho kina víme, jak vypadá.
My jsme na to,
aby jsme ITI profinancovali,
jsme vzali úvěr
miliarda, sto milionů,
čili to už vás,
to je nějak určitej závazek
na 20 let,
s kterým nemůžete moc dělat.
Teďka trošku třeba
vývojů rokových sazeb
je nějaký,
my máme miliardu a půl
na dlouhodobých závazcích,
takže si můžete
jaksi přepočíst,
co je 1% to jako na tom závazku.
Ale my jsme to nepočítali,
protože zhledem k tomu,
že prioritu pro nastavající
volební období,
když to řeknu takhle,
nebo na období třeba 4 až 6 let
je doprava.
Jsou projekty nachystané,
ať už je to obchva záležné,
přivaděž, dálniční
a propojení D49,
1 lm 49 cesty,
pravobřežka,
parštenská příčka,
elektrifikace a tak dále,
tak tam jsme v situaci,
kdy jako my nemůžeme říct,
jestli budeme dělat nebo nebudeme.
Tam budeme ve vleku těch věcí,
čili my budeme muset přistupovat
k těm projektům tak,
že je budeme muset realizovat tak,
aby jsme vlastně koordinovali
tu stavební činnost v tom daném území.
Tak to znamená,
že počítáme s tím,
že celý ten rozpočet
a ty závazky stavíme tak,
že prioritu má doprava
a do toho roku 32
to prostě nebude jinak.
Bude to,
ty částky jsou tam poměrně velké,
když se,
my jsme teďka pro vás aktualizovali
vlastně ten preferované projekty,
takže to tam,
to tam vidíte,
některé věci se v čase i vyvíjí,
to znamená,
že kdo jste se pozorně dívali,
tak tam přibyl třeba
odstav pro autobusy
za 40 milionů,
které nakonec zhledem k vývoji
jednání se skupinou zemek,
prostě tak,
aby jsme nebránili té elektrifikaci
a aby to mohlo fungovat,
tak to budeme muset převzít my.
Takže,
aby se ten prostor nezablokoval,
tak to je třeba další výdaj,
s kterými jsme ještě před půl rokem
ani nepočítali.
A musí se stát.
Musí se stát.
Takže je to trošku jako komplikované,
čili ano,
my jsme ho nedělali,
počítali jsme s tím,
že vyhlásíme soutěž tak,
aby jsme tu finanční zátěž
převezli na investora
a ten důvod,
aby pro něho vznikla
jakási komfortní situace
je 70 let
jako koncesní koncese na provoz.
Já chci říct,
že jsem strašně rád,
že nakonec jsme našli firmu
a ještě z hodou kolností
z dománcího prostředí,
která k tomu přistoupila,
protože byla jediná,
která ten závazek akceptuje
a chce do toho jít.
V tuto chvíli je to
o dalším vývoji té situace,
jak to bude dál pokračovat,
protože jak jsme včera jednali,
tak jsme si řekli,
že prostě dneska se stane něco
a potom je zase doba na to,
aby se ty věci dál upřesňovaly
a přesně stanovaly.
Takže to je k tomu kinu
a k tomu materiálu.
Ještě bych trošku navázal
na to, co říkal pan Mančura.
Já, když jsem včera
absolvoval ty tři hodiny jednání,
tak musím říct,
že taky mě napadla otázka,
jestli to nemohlo být časově trošku jinak.
Asi je to na budoucí radu,
zastupitelstvo,
aby našlo způsob,
jak v těchto, řekl bych,
projektech, které přesahují časem
a výší prostě normální standardy,
aby jsme měli nějaký mechanismus,
jak procesně, jak k něm věcem přistupovat
a vzájemně se informovat.
Protože ona každá rada
je tam potom dobrá.
To jsou to věci,
a pan Mančura to opstal přesně,
že není zkušenost a kompetence na městě
prostě tyto projekty připravovat,
řídit v celém tom kontextu.
A já z hlediska financí řeknu,
víte,
jestli chceme zachovat rozvoj
a dynamiku rozvoje,
což je otázka času,
tak my se musíme naučit
daleko víc využívat privátní peněz.
To je strašně důležité,
aby jsme v rámci toho rozvoje
se naučili pracovat
s tím privátním sektorem,
protože tam je daleko víc peněz,
než na tom městě.
Já vám můžu říct,
že možnosti města z hlediska Salda
rozpočtu,
což je rozdíl příjmu a výdajů,
je zhruba někde na úrovni 370 milionů.
Když ještě tam dáte
nějaké mimořádné věci,
opravy, které se vždycky stanou,
čili nějaké operativní výdaje ve výši,
co to město musí držet,
to je nějakých 60 milionů.
Potom máte ten roční
to Saldo zhruba na úrovni
nějakých 300 milionů,
ale pozor,
z toho už budeme mít
jako úhradu dlouhodobých závazků,
takže je to 200.
Dneska, když stavíme jednu,
přistavujeme jídelnu a školu,
tak stojí 180 milionů.
Takže tady je potřeba
se naučit
v tom dlouhodobějším
financování
pracovat i s tím soukromým sektorem
a být pro něho dobrý partner.
Navíc,
četl jsem si volební programy,
všichni tam píšeme o tom,
jak budeme spolupracovat
s tím soukromým sektorem.
Ano,
musíme se to naučit,
je to otázka
hledání nějakých průsečíků
a samozřejmě i rozložení nějakých rizik
v každém projektu,
protože nikdo vám nepůjde to dělat tak,
že veškerý rizika převezme na sebe,
takhle se ty velké projekty nedělají.
A to nás bude čekat
v tom nadcházejícím období.
První velká zkouška,
jak se s tím vypořádá,
nám bude náměstí,
protože tam nějakýsi potenciál
jako z hlediska pozemků
a možností jsou,
ale je to přesně o tom to.
Může tam něco vyrůst,
může tam něco být,
je to atraktivní klocha
pro i soukromý sektor
a je otázka,
jak to využijeme.
Já si myslím,
že těch příležitostí
bude spousta
a je to o tom naučit se
s některýma věcma pracovat.
Je naprosto přirozené,
že neumíme hned všechno,
ale já si myslím,
že ty projekty,
které jsme dneska
za ty čtyři roky udělali,
připravili,
Březnická, Boněcký, Rybník,
i to velké kino ukazují,
že ten potenciál tady je,
že mnohem jsme se zlepšili
a prostě ty věci
se posunuli dopředu.
Za to všem děkuju
i zaměstnancům magistrátu,
protože nebylo to
i pro ně jednoduché,
jako byly to ve většině
případů nové věci,
s kterýma se museli vyrovnávat.
Takže všem děkuju.
Tak já moc děkuju.
Já poprosto teda zásubce
společnosti PSG
si by nám řekl,
jakým způsobem oni uvažují,
jenom ať teda to není jenom,
že bych já vám tlumočil,
co jsem se dozvěděl
nebo o to jsme jednali.
A pak pustím vás všechny,
ještě co se hlásíte,
a případně možná vám z toho
vypěnou nějaké další otázky,
tak jenom poprosím.
Děkuji.
Vážené zastupitelky,
vážení zastupitelé,
PSG je odhodláno
kvalitně zrealizovat
rekonstrukci velkého kina,
kterou jsme vysoutěžili.
Právě souběh rekonstrukce kina
podle nás vytváří
nejlepší příležitost,
kdy řešit současné parkování,
podzemí a následně
kultivovat celý prostor
mezi velkým kinem,
obchodním domem a tržnicí.
To je hlavní důvod,
proč jsme se do projektu
podzemního parkování
si ho domu šli.
Chci zároveň vyjasnit
několik věcí,
kolem kterých vznikly pochybnosti.
Nemáme ambici provozovat
parkoviště 70 let.
Za vhodné řešení
považujeme variantu,
kdy po skončení
parkovací dům
převezme do provozu město
nebo technické služby z lín.
Koncesní smlouva
takové řešení
výslovně umožňuje
a my jsme k němu připraveni.
Celý model,
tak jak je nastaven
koncesní smlouvou,
je dle našeho názoru
nastaven zcela transparentně.
V součástí naší nabídky
byl rovněž cenový model,
který byl doložen
a průběh jeho naplňování
v průběhu výstavby
bude plně kontrolovan
zástupci města.
Město tedy bude mít
k dispozici doložené
a ověřitelné náklady
na výstavbu parkovacího domu.
Konkrétní podmínky
případného nájmu
dnes prozatím nalze předjímat.
Pokud by město projevilo
o tuto variantu zájem,
tedy převzětí parkoviště
do nájmu,
sjednávaly by se
zcela standardní podmínky,
to je podmínky obyklé
v daném místě a čase.
70 let,
na něž nám má být zřízeno
právo stavby,
nevnímáme jako cíl,
po kterým chceme
parkoviště provozovat,
ale jako maximální rámec
dnešní koncesní smlouvy.
Veškeré nástroje,
jak právo stavby
a s ním spojené vlastnictví
budoucího parkovacího domu
převést městu dříve,
jsou výlučně
vůrkou města,
kterému koncesní smlouva
dává právo obce,
které může město
uplatnit kdykoliv.
Tento model má ještě
jeden důležitý aspekt.
Chápeme obavu,
že při provozování
parkovacího domu
společnosti PSG
je závazek města
zrušit povrchová parkovací místa.
Nicméně, pokud si podzemní
parkoviště pronajme město
nenese riziko jeho využití
koncesionář, ale provozovatel.
To znamená, že PSG pak nemá
ekonomický zájem na rušení
dnešních povrchových
parkovacích míst
kvůli ochraně vlastního
parkovacího biznisu.
Žádný takový biznis
mít nebudeme.
V takovém případě by tedy
povrchová parkovací místa
nebylo nutné rušit.
Míněný osud povrchových
parkovacích stání
upravoje koncesní smlouva,
včetně důsledku jednotlivých variant
a rozhodnutí o něm
zůstává na městě.
Za tuto skutečnost
nepožadujeme žádnou kompenzaci
ani výnosy z povrchových
parkovacích stání
ani jiné protiplnění.
Dopravní řešení,
přesný počet míst
i konečná podoba projektu
se budou teprve dopracovávat.
Chceme je připravovat
společně s městem.
Za PSG tedy nabízíme
jednoduchý princip.
Parkovací dům postavíme
na vlastní náklady,
tyto náklady budou
doložitelné
a městu doložené.
Město je následně
může provozovat
a má ve smlouvě nástroje,
jak si ji převzít
kdykoliv dříve.
Parkovací dům
skončí ve vlastní svým města
tak jako tak.
Děkuji.
Městská děkuji
za to upřesnění
a i za ty deklarace.
Určitě jsem za to rád,
že to potvrzuje
i to, co vlastně jsem říkal,
to, co jsme se bavili včera
a já tímto rovnou
vím, že se hlásil
ještě pan,
původně, tak jenom nevím,
jestli není potřeba
nebo tak, když tak já poprosím,
jestli se znova přihlásíš
a já poprosím teda pana Sáhu,
kdy se tedy přihláším do diskuze.
Já jsem chtěl reagovat
na Mirka Chalánka,
takže to je trošku jiná tématika,
tak jestli někdo chce
ještě diskutovat
tady na tuto téma,
tak já počkám a budu.
Dobře, tak já budu,
že až potom ještě teda
předám zrovna následně.
Až k tomu rozvoji města.
Dobře.
Tak další se vásí pan Juráš.
Teda tři komentáře,
budu rychlejší
a nebudu věcnější,
ani nebudu tak přiléhavý,
jak bývá spravilovaná rozhozáha,
přesto se o to mírně pokusím.
Na tom, co řekl pan Chalán,
já děkuju první,
samozřejmě,
zástupcům PSG Construction
za tu deklaraci.
Vážíme si toho,
že se nám snaží
některé naše obavy
minimalizovat.
K tomu, co říkal
Mirek Chalánek,
no tam není nic,
co bychom nepodepsali.
To jako je v pořádku,
naučit se pracovat
a spolupracovat
za svoukromí penězi
a bavit se o tom,
jak ta situace má fungovat.
nám na tom v zásadě,
a teď si půjčím,
pan Herman tady ještě je?
Myslím, že už a vidím, vidím.
My jsme se bavili venku
a mně se to líbilo,
tak si půjčím jeho přirovnání,
ať to nevypadá,
ať jsem to vymyslel já.
V zásadě on mi to připodobňoval
k tomu, řekněme,
finskému modelu
nebo obecně severských samozpráv.
Když to budu hodně vulgarizovat,
tak se spolu zavřeme do chatek
a budeme pít a vykládat.
Do té doby,
dokud se neschodneme,
nikoli v náslovních podmínkách,
ale v principech.
A uděláme to jako zastupitelé
tohodle období
s těmi relevantními zástupci
těch politických stran tak,
aby u těch projektů,
které se plánují na více let,
byla široká politická schoda.
Tak, aby investor
tady nemusel pak stávat
a vysvětlovat některé věci
s nějakou obavou,
jak ty vlastní investice budou v budoucnu,
ale že je zřejmé,
že si rozumíme,
jak to bude fungovat.
To mám pocit,
že se neúplně stalo
v tomhle projektu.
Druhá věc,
z toho taky plyne
ta diskuze,
která říkala,
no,
pan Chalánek to vlastně říkal,
akorát my třeba vůbec nevíme,
co bude na povrchu.
My ho uvolňujeme,
ale ještě neříkáme,
co tam bude,
jako zpracujeme,
jenom víme,
že to zvolníme
v této chvíli.
A kolik nás to bude stát?
A třetí věc,
která s tím
jako nutně souvisí,
já to beru,
že jste to připravili
a patří za to fakt díky,
že jsou to ty
velké rozhové projekty,
ale to,
že je to na papíře,
to ještě neznamená,
že to stojí.
Na některé projekty
máme nachystáno 15 let.
Děkuji moc.
Tak já už jsem říkal několikrát,
jako my si to nějakým zůsobem
nerozporujeme.
Já si myslím,
že asi tady všichni říkáme
dobrý,
jsme všichni tady rádi,
že ty projekty velké
tady konečně budou.
A myslím si,
že já tam odvedem
dobrý kus práce.
Na druhou stranu
všichni stejí,
musíme jako nijak
nalhávat,
že všichni s toho
máme obavy
a chceme mít
co nejvíce pojištěná
veškerá rizika,
jak samotných staveb,
tak samozřejmě
i budoucího provozování
i z pohledu
svého rozpočtu města
Zdína.
Takže to je naprosto
logické
a tak,
jak já jsem říkal,
jsou věci,
které byly
v nějakém procesu
a tak,
jak jsem říkal,
ne všechno
v rámci výběrových řízení
můžeme veřejně
diskutovat.
Takže to jsou ty cesty,
které my musíme
případně najít,
prověřit,
otevřít
a na základě toho
se prostě
uspůsobit
u těch velkých projektů,
řekněme tu širší diskuzi
v průběhu
a nikoli
jenom ve finále.
Takže to spíš
jenom za mě
a na druhou stranu
se asi nepřejeme
nikdo nic jiného,
než aby ty věci
tady byly rychle
nikoli za 15 let,
ale ideálně například
za 5,
tak jak si to přejí
i ti investoři.
Prosím,
pana Vančuru.
Děkuju,
pane primátore.
My se rovníváme,
že ten zvolený model,
který pokládáme
za vlastně
takový pilotní projekt,
že musí být opravdu
naším velkým zájmem,
aby dobře dopadnul.
My je evidentní,
že potřebujeme
do budoucna,
aby i soukromí investoři
pomáhali
nám s investicemi,
především v oblasti
té infrastruktury,
tam, kde je to možné,
že by nám to velmi ulehčilo situaci
a myslím si,
že tento projekt
je náročný samozřejmě
v tom, že je první
a potřebujeme,
aby v výsledku
byly spokojeno
nejenom město
a občany,
ale také investor.
Takže pokud toho nedosáhneme,
tak si myslím,
že bude velmi těžké
v tom pokračovat
a ta brána se nám zavře.
A víte,
že už delší dobu
se pokoušíme
vysvětlit
vám, kolegům,
jak je důležité,
abychom v oblasti investic,
abychom měli
dlouhodobý plán
a ideálně samozřejmě,
aby ten dlouhodobý plán
byl odsouhlasen
všemi významnými,
pokud ne všemi,
tak všemi významnými
politickými subjekty
ve Zlíně,
tak, aby bez ohledu
na výsledky těch příštích období
ten plán byl zachovan
a bylo rozvíjeno,
aby se v něm pokračovalo.
A já samozřejmě souhlasím,
co řekla paní Francova,
s tím lze určitě souhlasím,
ale mnohem víc věcí
i s tím, co řekl pan Chalánek.
Jenom to potřebujeme
dokázat se realizovat.
Priorita dopravy,
já to slyším ve Zlíně 30 let.
To znamená,
potřebujeme nejenom pojmenovat
ty problémy,
ale potřebujeme mít skutečně plán,
který jsme odhodláni splnit
a splnit ho v čase.
Mockrát jsme se přesvědčili
jenom v tom posledním roce,
jak ten čas hraje v náš neprospěch.
Tlačíme toho před sebou
velké množství,
toho, co nás čeká.
Takže pokud nenajdeme klíček
v tom postupovat,
nejenom efektivně,
ale abychom to správně
kladli v tom pořadí,
které je potřeba,
tak to občanům
budeme velmi komplikovat
a to si nepřejeme.
Potřebujeme město,
kde lidé,
které je přitažlivé pro lidi,
víte, v jaké jsme konkurenci.
Vždyť se to objevuje,
prostě všichni chtějí to tež,
je to boj o lidi,
především o mladé lidi.
Víte, jak jsme na tom
i v pohledu té demografie
a jasné,
že jsou věci,
které sami my nezvládneme.
Potřebujeme být důvěrý
hodný partner,
nejenom pro lidi,
ale potřebujeme být
i dobrým partnerem pro kraj
a samozřejmě
všechny problémy nezvládneme sami
ve Zlíně.
Potřebujeme k tomu
i podporu zvládných míst.
Takže to snad tolik.
Děkuju.
Já se vám naprosto souhlasím,
proto vlastně na městě
máme strategické dokumenty,
jako je strategia rozhovedu města
Zlína,
jako by ten nejvrchlovější dokument,
kde ty věci jsou.
Z toho vám vyplývá
jako by střednědobý plán,
ve kterém vlastně tady mám
předkládán.
A jak v něm vidíte,
to není otázka úplně toho,
že ta možnost,
řekněme,
toho vedení města,
vzhledem těm investicím,
které nás čekají,
tak jako,
že bychom si my tady řešili,
jestli tam dáme jeden druhý
a nebo oba,
tak to ta úplně nefunguje,
protože je to více mě předem stanovené,
ať už jsou strategií,
nebo vlastně také
vlastně tými hlavními potřebami.
Co se zvíká dopravy?
Ano,
naprosto souhlasím.
Bavíme se tady,
já ve svém věku,
já vám můžu říct,
že před těmi 30 lety
si pamatuju,
že se tu bavilo
o pravobřešce,
pamatuju si,
že tehdejší náměstek,
ale já od té doby tomu říkám,
tunel říkal,
že se udělá cesta
pod jižními svahy
a tak dál.
A já vám můžu přesně říct,
co se stalo před 8 lety,
kdy jsem nastoupil
do pozice primátora
a kolega Michal Čížek
do pozice náměstka
pro dopravu.
Já jsem došel za ním
a ptal jsem se,
prosím tě,
v jakém stavu jsou tady
tyto velké projekty,
o kterých se tedy mluví
tehdy to bylo zhruba 20 let,
pravobřeška,
obklad záležné
a další.
Kdy to uděláme?
A já vám řeknu z toho otevření,
v jakém to bylo stavu?
Nula.
Všechno, co tam bylo,
bylo tak možná k tomuto hodit
jako rokoše,
protože to bylo staré,
protože to bylo udělané
ještě z té doby v těch 90.
pomalu.
Anebo to bylo udělané
takovým způsobem,
že to bylo naprosto nerealizovatelné,
jako například
pravobřešní komunikace
přes celý arelá Rybníky,
kde bychom vykupovali
neskutečné množství budov
za neskutečné peníze,
neboli byste se k tomu
nikdy nedostali.
Takže já za sebe
z tohoto místa
jako opravdu
velká poklona té práci
Michala Číška
a všech lidí na dopravě
kolem, kteří se nějakým způsobem
kolem toho točí.
Takže za 8 let,
když se podíváte,
jsme v situaci,
kdy obchvat zálešné,
co znamená
propojení komunikace
D49 z jednalovno,
42, tam městská část,
obchvat zálešné,
zmáme územní rozhodnutí,
je teda napadnuté,
můžeme se bavit
ekologické spolky
a další věci,
ale máme to.
Máme nějaký krok vůbec.
Předtím byla čára na papíře
a ještě blbě.
To stejné bylo
s pravobřeškou,
současné bylo,
řešíme první etapu,
která je v současném
trasování a tak dále.
Bohužel,
a to si tu nemusíme
prostě někde ukazovat prstem,
mně je to v celku jedno,
kdo tady byl nebo nebyl,
ale prostě tady se hodně mluvilo,
ale moc se toho neudělalo.
A to je teďka ta věc,
kterou samozřejmě,
když se podíváte,
tak já taky nemám rádost z toho,
že na poslím zastupitelstvu
řešíme tady tak věci
věci za víc než miliardu.
Nemám.
To bych strašně rád,
kdybychom to řešili
už v minulém volebním období
nebo více méně v polovině tohoto,
protože ty projekty,
ale je potřeba chystat
a ta chystání těchto projektů
prostě trvá roky.
To není jako na jednu volebnou dobí.
Takže jsem za to rád,
že se to daří.
Já přeji všem,
kteří tady v tom vedení města
po těch volbách budou,
aby se to dařilo i dál
a ideálně lépe než nám,
aby se to neustále zlepšovalo,
protože bez toho,
aby se město z ní rozvíjelo,
tak prostě bude opravdu upadat.
A jedna věc je ta doprava.
Když se podíváte,
tak ta doprava,
že se snažíme nějakým způsobem
dělat ty kroky,
já už jsem to dneska zmiňoval
a snažíme to nebude jednoduché téma,
ale samozřejmě vy musíte
udržovat atraktivitu města Zlína
a například to téma,
proč jsou zavřené hospody
ve Zlíně večer,
já to nevím.
Můžu se tady ptát spousty mladých,
jako ptám si jich,
proč nejdete večer na pivo,
jak jsme chodívali my.
Proč ty hospody,
když jdete tam v 9 hodin,
je tam 10,
je tam pět lidí,
jeden stůl,
tak v tu danou chvíli,
prostě to je to téma,
které jako samozřejmě,
proč to v Brně jde
a je tam hromada lidí
a odkazujeme se na studenty.
Vždyť my tu máme univerzitu,
je tu 10 tisíc studentů,
proč oni nechodí do hospody?
Když jim univerzita postavila
univerzitní klub na jejich kolejích,
tak ve výsledku tam nikdo nechodil.
Jako oni nejsou schopni
vydaní tím výtahem od dvě patra,
aby se tam potkali.
Jako teďka samozřejmě ten fenomén
té doby digitální je nějaký,
ale to jsou všechno ty výzvy,
které samozřejmě tady čeká
jak naše budoucí vedení města,
tak i ostatních,
protože my si tu můžeme psát
do programu, co chceme,
ale zatím na to,
jak tady udržet mladé,
jak zvýšit porodnost,
jak ve výsledku tady řešit
obecně ty globální problémy,
tak jako odpověď nemá nikdo.
Ale samozřejmě se snažíme
tomu přispívat
zkazé atraktivitu toho města,
veřejných prostor,
nabídky služeb
a pak ty narážíte
na ty finanční možnosti,
které město má.
Ale za mě to je naprosto správně,
že ať už toto volební období
nebo i to minulé fungujeme
a politicky a snažíme se společně
v těchto tématech najít testu
a posouvat ten zlín
a za to zaslužíme všich,
jako zaslužíte všichni
velké poděkování
a myslím si,
že ta spolupráce města
s univerzitou,
s nějakým mířem,
s soukým sektorem
není na tom špatně.
Vždycky to může být lepší
a je to ta výzva
pro všechny,
kteří teď v budoucnu budou,
ať už v přílišních období
nebo za deset let.
Je to prostě dlouhodobá věc.
Takže já za to moc krát děkuju
a souhlasím s vámi,
že ty věci je potřeba plánovat
obdláště velké.
Poprosím pana Sáhu teďka
nebo až?
Pojďte.
Šměrkovi Chalánkovi,
který jednoznačně prohlásili,
že město má zájem o rozvoj
a to mě velice potěšilo
a ty velké projekty jsou důkazem,
protože přes těch velkých projekty
toho město se samozřejmě nepohne.
To, co mě tam ale trošku vádí,
že ta univerzita tam vůbec
tady v těch rozvojových plánech nefiguruje.
Já chápu, že to je chyba
současného vedení,
ale z toho vás ujištět,
že ta síla v té univerzitě je
a že případně noví funkcionáři,
kteří přijdou, jsou připraveni
a se vrátí k tomu rozvoji,
kdy ta univerzita měla dynamiku,
když se postavil nový objekt
nebo se zřídila nová fakulta
a já bych velice ocenil,
kdyby se univerzita vrátila
tady do tohoto chodu
a samozřejmě jsou připraveny
celá řada, řekněme, směrů,
které se dají dále rozvíjet.
Ale samozřejmě potom taky se očekává,
že pokud ta univerzita
bude mět campus přímo v centru města,
tak je třeba se věnovat
provozovatelnosti toho centra,
že ty situace,
kdy my zaměstnáváme
hodně třeba ženy,
které vozí děti do jeslí
a každý to není boj o to,
kde zaparkují,
protože nikdo si nechce platit,
že první dvě hodiny,
co viděla, dá do parkování.
Tak samozřejmě ten problém
s parkováním je tristní
pro tady zaměstnance univerzity,
ale když se podíváte
i na celou řadu dalších věcí,
které bychom mohli změnit,
tak když jedete na fakultu
manažmentu a ekonomiky
a díváte se, jak tam přiváží
zoufálným způsobem
příbuzní lidi na polikliniku,
tak je to docela nekulturní
a možná, když už se řeší
tato centrum,
že bychom taky mohli věnovat pozornost,
jakým způsobem zlepšit
tady tuto situaci.
Jinak bych chtěl poděkovat
a říkám, pevně věřím,
že univerzita se zpamatuje,
vrátí se zpátky do té dynamiky,
kterého měla a my jsme připraveni
se vrátí k tomu k úvodnímu modelu,
který měl v každém případě
dosáhnout téměř 20 tisící studentů,
protože teprve od tohoto objemu
jsme schopni pronikat
do té mezinárodní excelence.
A pokud nemáme excelenci,
tak prostě padáme dolů
a stáváme se regionální školou,
kterou nikdo nepočítá.
My jsme se bohužel do toho režimu dostali,
tak je třeba najít tu sílu.
A když město a kraj pomůžou,
tak pevně věřím,
že máme tu sílu se k tomu vrátit
a zapojit se do té výzvy,
kterou dělal Mirek Halánek,
vracím dnes se k rozvoji.
A ty velké projekty jsou příslibem.
Děkuji.
Děkuji moc, která děkuji.
A poprosím,
Pavla Simkoviče.
Já bych chtěl poděkovat zástupci PSG
za deklarace,
které více méně trošku rozplynuly
nebo mohly rozpustit některé pochybnosti,
ale možná bych trochu navázal
i na pana Sáhu,
kdy jsem chtěl říct,
že vlastně my tady schválujeme
nějaký dokument,
který schválujeme,
který obsahujeme ty deklarace,
které jsou krásné,
ale jsou následné až potom.
A já věřím,
že ty věci do toho budou zapracovány,
co se týká toho parkování.
Ono to je složitější určitě,
protože samozřejmě my jako město
bychom si možná měli uvědomit
a trošku se podívat na to,
jak to parkování vzniká,
jaké jsou potřeby
a možná nejen občanů z líné,
ale těch, co tady jezdí za prací
a to město jako takové rozvíjí.
A podívat se na to,
jestli jsme schopni to možná lépe
ovlivnit o technologické věci,
které umožňují dynamiku vjezdu,
umožňují si pamatovat,
kolikrát auto kam vělo,
na jak dlouho vělo,
zoptimalizvat to parkováné za celý den
a tímto způsobem trošičku umožnit
a i regulovat to chování těch občanů.
To nutit je nepřímou formou,
je dostat do té městské hramady dopravy
právě přes tady tyto možnosti
toho parkování a tak dále.
Takže tam já jsem spíš směřoval,
že když to bude takhle dlouho
a nebudeme to mít úplně většinově
jako město ty parkovací místa
pod kontenouvé spolupráci s těmi firmami,
a mělo by to být,
to znamená, zaměstnává měli lidi,
potřebuji, aby někde parkovali,
dolížili mi z okolí, nepřestěhujuli se,
tak se o tom bavíme, jak tohle udělat,
jak to zapojit do těch modelů a podobně,
čili trošku i tu dlouhodobější vizi z tohoto pohledu.
Určitě jo, jako souhlasím s tím,
to je to, co si tu říkáme
a je to otázka i toho,
jak jsem říkal, že jedna věc optimalizace
to jde teď a já si myslím,
že ta optimalizace bude ještě mnohem lépe,
bude mít nové možnosti po zavedení modrých zónů.
Protože tam v tu danou chvíli
opravu ti občané města z dína
budou stanovit jinou pozici než ti ostatní
a samozřejmě v tu danou chvíli
se to bude,
otvírají se další možnosti,
jak k tomu přistupovat.
Takže určitě souhlasím,
že ta regulace respektive optimalizace
je naprosto to ano.
Poprosím pana Dudáka.
Děkuji za slovo.
Já s dovolením vrátím
se k parametrům toho bodu,
který dneska schvalujeme
a chtěl bych velmi poděkovat,
že jsme měli možnost o tom mluvit
a dostat zásadní jako odpovědi
na otázky, které nám na tom projektu
vadili nejvíc.
A to je, že se tím projektem,
pokud to rada podepíše,
tak jak to dnes ji zmocňujeme,
tak vlastně vzniká pouze
nějakých nových osnáct parkovacích míst,
což je rozdíl mezi množstvím parkovacích míst
na povrchu, který je tam dneska
v rámci všech těch parkovišt,
který jste pane primátore vyjmenoval
a závazkem z koncesionářské smlouvy
na vybudování 260 veřejných míst.
To je pro nás strašně málo v tom kontextu,
jak a věřím, že společně vidíme to město,
že poroste, že nebude stagnovat.
Navíc v té lokalitě budujeme,
já věřím, že funkční kino,
které přitáhne další lidi,
čili další pohyb.
A navíc tam vzniká projekt
na objekt Prospect,
což je vlastně akce
stejného investora
nebo stejné skupiny.
To byla pro nás zásadní věc,
deklarace, která tu proběhla,
že se nemusí rušit ty povrchové místa,
pokud tedy město bude jednat
a využije tady té nabídky,
která tu padla,
kterou byste umožnili
v té koncesionářské smlouvě,
ale ono se to nestane,
pokud budoucí rada
nebo zastupitelstvo
té nabídky nevyužije
a nedojedná pro město
těch nejlepších parametrů.
Takže bych chtěl jenom vyzvat
budoucí radu,
ať to bude kdokoliv,
aby se tímhle aktivně zabývali
od prvního dne,
kdy to bude možné.
To je první věc.
Otázka, kterou mám
na pana Petra Suroviče
a předchází bodu,
který je v dalších pořadí,
to je prospekt
a naše nějaká součinnost
jako města.
A naše obava,
která byla,
kdy tam hodláte,
na což máte podle
koncesionářské smlouvy,
právo vybudovat
x dalších míst.
Dnes se hovoří
o nějakých dalších
90,
jestli se nepletu.
A vy tím,
že budete budovat
prospekt,
věříme,
že budete,
tak pro ten prospekt
také budete potřebovat
jestli nějaké
parkovací místa.
Jak vy to vidíte,
kolik jich bude vybudováno
přímo v prospektu,
kolik těchto
parkovacích míst
pro dlouhodobé stání
budete si chtít
využít tady
z tohoto parkoviště
pod kynem.
Děkuji.
Děkuji za ten dotaz.
Já jsem záměrně
projekt prospektu
nezmíňoval,
protože jsem to nechtěl
tu diskuzi komplikovat,
nicméně
pravda je taková,
že v tomto projektu
uvažujeme
s 200 parkovacími místy,
které budou
i pro veřejnost.
A tedy počítáme,
že to celkové množství
těch parkovací míst
a lokalitě
by se naším projektem
mělo zvýšit
a ta dostupnost
toho parkování
by se i tím
naším projektem
měla navýšit.
Jiná věc,
která tady až tady
nebyla zmíněna,
tak my se tou
koncesní smlouvou
zavazujeme
v vybudování
260 míst
pro veřejnost.
Nicméně
ten náš model
uvažuje
s celkovým počtem
stáním
350 míst,
protože je to
ekonomicky
zatím nejefektivnější,
je to,
s čím počítáme
a z toho
některé místa
uvažujeme,
univerzity.
Já bych se těl
musel zeptat,
počítáte s tím,
že v parkovišti
pod velkým kinem
bude dlouhodobý
nájem
jakékoliv kapacity
pro budovu
prospektu?
Ano, to je právě
ten rozdíl
mezi těmi 260 místy,
které jsou pro veřejnost
a těmi 350,
s kterými
aktuálně uvažujeme
v tom našem
finančním modelu,
takže 90 míst
teoreticky je
dlouhodobému užívání.
Rozumím,
ale jenom já jsem,
já jenom se chci zeptat,
jestli vlastně
kapacita prospektu,
kterou máte,
kapacitu parkování
v tomto objektu,
tak vlastně
si považujete
za plnohodnotnou
pro ten objekt
anebo
berete,
že
ten počet je,
když to řeknu
na hraně
nebo nějakým způsobem
a počítáte s tím,
že si pomůžete,
když to řeknu,
že si naplno,
že si pomůžete
parkovacím místy pod kinem
skrze investici v prospektu.
Určitě ne,
je to sobě statičné,
je to naopak,
řeknu,
v tomto směru
předimenzované,
chtěli bychom tam
využít dynamického parkování,
to znamená,
že třeba zaměstnánci,
kteří tam budou pracovat,
budou parkovat
v průběhu dne,
nicméně pokud bude akce
na náměstí
ve Velkém kině,
tak budou moct využít
i to parkování
právě v prospektu.
Dobře, děkuju.
A poprosím Michala Číška.
Dobrý den všem,
zšel jsem tady nějaké klíčové slova
doprava 30 let a tak dál,
tak bych na to rád zareagoval,
nic ve zlem.
Jenom jsem chtěl říct,
že ano,
o některých projektech
tady slyšíme 30 let,
nicméně je důležité chápat,
o čem slyšíme,
kdo co jako by udělal.
To znamená,
třeba obchvat záležné
jsme podali v roce 2019,
vlastně všechny vyjadřovačky
na územní rozhodnutí
a v roce, tuším,
22, 24, nevím,
možná David mě opraví.
Jsme vlastně společně s krajem
zajistili financování
této stavby,
takže nevím,
jestli to je málo.
Ano, za 30 let je to asi málo,
ale počítujeme to od roku 2019,
když se skutečně něco stalo
a vlastně máme hotovou
dokumentaci pro stavební povolení
a jenom pro vaši informaci.
Třeba čekali jsme 500 dní
na tom,
jestli nám DESU,
to je specializovaný stavební úřad,
rozhodne o tom,
jestli je kraj podjatý nebo ne,
500 dní.
Doteďka nemáme ještě spis zpátky
z ministerstva dopravy,
bombardujeme je,
takže jenom,
aby jsme získali spis zpátky,
tak jsme dneska už třeba
160. den,
já nevím,
už to nepočítám.
A až vlastně na přímou intervenci
vlastně hejtmana,
přes premiéra,
premiéra jsme se dobrali
nějakému výsledku,
takže takhle to tady funguje,
takže ne,
že bychom nechtěli,
děláme ty kroky jako dopředu
s nějakým rizikem,
že potom budeme muset
tu dokumentaci měnit,
nicméně,
k lednu 207,
máme mít dokumentaci
pro stavění povolení
na obchvat zálešné,
máme zajistěné financování
díky kraji,
a tak dále,
a tak dále.
Co se týče pravobřešky,
ano,
to je takový jako
bajný jednorožec,
který se nám tady objevuje.
Všichni ví,
kdo má být,
nicméně,
dokumentaci pro stavění povolení
nikdo neobjednal
až já.
Vy já toto zastupitelstvo
nebo naše vedení.
To znamená,
k dnešnímu dní
máme připravenou
dokumentaci pro stavění povolení
než povolení záměru.
Čekáme na vyčištění území.
Jsem rád,
že dnešní bod 21
prošel širokou diskuzí
a tam jsme se vlastně zavázali
k steplárnou a spas servisem,
který nám v ozovkách stojí
v cestě této stavby,
že jsme uzavřeli dohodu.
Materiály jsme doplnili
v řádném termínu,
takže jste měli čas
je prostudovat,
nikdo nebyl proti,
děkuju za to.
Ani se nezdržel možná.
A my, kdyby postupujeme
v těchto stavbách,
které se tady údajně chystají
30 let,
není to pravda,
ty stavby se tady chystají
6-8 let.
Zastupce PSG
asi mi tady rozumí,
jak je to s povolením.
Myslím, že 8 let
na takovou stavbu linijovou
je jako docela dobrý.
A samozřejmě čekáme
odpor,
nechci říct to slovo,
nějakých ekospolků.
Vy a závorca
dosaďte si jiný název
a doufáme,
že se nám podaří
to aspoň podat
na stavní,
nebo určitě to podáme
na stavní úřad
a pak je to jako
v díle,
řekněme,
vyšší moci,
jestli se nám to podaří
dotáhnout do konce
nebo ne.
Jak říkal Mirech Alánek,
máme tady
financování
těchto staveb zajištěno
a díky tomu
musíme čerpat
jiné úvěry a tak dále.
Takže děláme všechno
pro to,
hlibi,
ale nějaké zmínky
o tom,
že se něco chystá,
se skutečně jako zrealizovali
a je potřeba se dívat
na uzavřené smlouvy
a ne nějaké proklamace.
To je za mě vše,
děkuju.
Moc krátký za to upřesnění,
ještě se hlásí
pan náměstek Pavel Breda.
Já nechci taky zdržovat,
takže úplně hrozně rychle
řeknu to tež,
že co se týče
mých gestcí majetku
a rozvojových ploch,
tak já taky jsem přišel
a v podstatě nebyly nachystané věty,
že zámek, tržiště,
obchodní prostory,
nikde nebylo,
že bychom převzali
stavební povolení.
Březnická, Torzo,
Bonický rybník,
změny územního plánu,
tady nebylo,
že ty věci byly nachystané.
Prostě kdyby to tady
reálně bylo,
tak já bych byl hrozně rád,
abych mohl předzída
realizovat.
To, co jsme přebírali
od předchozího,
tak prostě bohužel
realita byla úplně jiná,
takže potvrduji to,
co má kolega Čížek
na dopravě,
tak v podstatě podobně
byly nachystané ty projekty
jako v jiných oblastech.
Takže reálně můžeme říct,
že si to projekty
reálně chystají
o osm let, jo.
Takže to je asi všechno.
Dobrá, já bych tady představl
brečet nad tím,
co jsme převzali.
Já si myslím,
že jsou děku z práce,
děkuji za to
a věřím tomu,
že ti ostatní
budou fungovat do budoucna
minimálně stejně aktivně
jako současné vedení
a s tím bych to tak nějak ukončil,
protože si myslím,
že chápu,
že se blíží volby a podobně,
ale nemyslím,
že v bodu týkající se
revitalizacím
rekozuce velkého kina
je debata k tomu,
co jsme kdo převzali,
v jakém stavu.
Takže poprosím pana Dudáka.
Děkuji za slovo.
Já samozřejmě strašně rád slyším,
jak jste aktivní,
co všechno jste udělali
a jsem moc rád,
až vyhrajeme volby,
že budeme mít na co navázat.
Jak jsem říkal,
já si hlavně jenom přeju,
aby se sly nerozvíjel,
ať už tu bude se jít kdokoliv.
Tak, poprosím pana Juráše.
Já se omlouvám,
nedalo mi to,
tak se zeptám pana náměstka Brady.
Pane Brada,
nebuďte slušnej,
řekněte od kost,
a to přebírali.
Já vám řeknu pravdu.
Pan kolega náměstek Brada
to přebíral od náměstka,
zahnutí ano.
Já nemyslím to ve zlém,
ale tak je to fér,
ne?
Tak jako,
když si tu bavíme,
kdo od koho to přebíral.
To je jedno,
já mu říkám,
když si chceme tady poměřovat,
ale jako říkám,
není to o tom,
že myslím,
jako nechci se do té střílet,
ale tady se to krásně hodí
a toto je upřímná odpověď.
Tak,
ne, tak
já si myslím,
že to je fér,
že jak vy znáte,
že já tady nebudu
nějakým znamkovat.
Prostě každý dělá,
co umí
a někomu to jde lépe,
někomu hůře
a nebrečme nad tím,
co jsme,
nebrečme nad historii,
použíme se z toho
a nakopněme ten zlín,
prostě, ať funguje.
Což já si myslím,
že se relativně daří
a věřím tomu,
že prostě
to bude i v budoucích letech.
To si myslím,
že je hlavní pro nás
pro všechny,
protože kdyby nám
nezáleželo na tom,
jak to ve zně bude vypadat,
tak si myslím,
že nikdo z vás
tady v tom zastupitelstvu
nesedí.
Takže
neřečme asi,
nebrečme,
ale makejme.
To je tak asi za mě.
Tak, poprosím
Zdenka Latsinu
s technickou.
Můžu prosím vás
návrhnout
dokončení této diskuse.
Trvá to hodinu
a čtvrtuch
se to rozplizlo
tady věcíma,
které s tímto tématem
už dávno nesouvisí.
Mocka já děkuji.
Já si myslím,
že se tu hlásu
už jeho Mirek Halánek
a
se hned stáhl
a nikdo další
se nehlásí.
Takže
tím pádem
si myslím,
že můžeme hlasovat
o materiál číslo 34
a nemusím hlasovat
o ukončení diskuze.
Takže pojďme
zase přímo materiál číslo 34,
prosím.
Pro 25,
materiál číslo 34
bude přijat.
Já tím toho
mocka děkuji
zástupci
společnosti PSG Construction
za to,
že za námi došel
a vlastně
za všechny odpovědi,
které nám přinesl.
Takže
mocka za to děkuji
a nepřeji se nic jiného
stejně jako
asi vy všichni,
aby se dílo podařilo
ať už kino
nebo všechny ty ostatní,
co jsme dneska schválovali.
Takže mocka vám
za to všem děkuji.
A samozřejmě
tímto práce začíná,
tak jak jsme si řekli,
je potřeba
být aktivní
a jednat
i do dalších
případných dodatních.
Dalším bodem
je bod číslo 35
týkající se
developerského projektu,
skrze plánovací smlouvu.
Je to vlastně to,
co už se bylo zmíněno,
skrze objekt prospektu.
Takže
já poprosím,
jestli k tomu máte
někdo nějaké dotazy.
Poprosím to má
pana Tomáše Dudáka.
My na základě informace,
která tady padla,
že ten objekt
bude parkovací kapacitou
soběstační,
tak z toho důvodu
hlasujem pro.
Děkujeme.
Dobrá, moc která děkujeme.
Poprosím,
jestli má někdo další
nějaké dotazy.
Není tomu tak,
tak já bych poprosto
pojďme hlasovat
materiál číslo 35.
Pro 36,
materiál číslo 35
byl přijat.
Materiál číslo 36
je zpráva o činnosti
kontrolního výboru
zastupitela stav města Zlína.
Poprosím,
otvírám k tomu diskuzi,
jestli jsou tady k tomu dotazy.
Nikdo se do diskuze nehlásí,
prosím, pojďme hlasovat
materiál číslo 36.
Pro 36,
Pro 34,
materiál číslo 36
byl přijat.
Materiál číslo 37
tý kejzí se pozemku,
kdy řešíme se
společností
koma modulár
výstavbu na ježních svazích
a dochází tam
k úprave výměry.
Je to relativně drobnost,
ale vzájemu tomu,
že ty smlouvy všechny
prochází zastupitelstvem,
tak aby bylo možné
v projektu adekvátně pokračovat,
tak se moc omlouváme,
a dají jsme teďka na stůl,
protože další zastupitelstvo
bude až prosinci řádné
a tím pádem bychom
prodloužili celou přípravu,
takže proto jsme si dovolili
toto dát hodně,
bych to nazval hodně na stůl,
ale věřím tomu,
že to nejde zase takový problém,
vzhledem k tomu,
že se upravuje pouze výměra.
Jsou k tomu dotazy?
Níkdo se nehlásí,
takže prosím,
pojďme hlasovat materiál
číslo 37.
pro 36,
materiál číslo 37 byl přijat.
Tímto jsme vyčerpali
všechny body,
které jsme měli
na programu hlasování.
Já, než se pustíme
do diskuze,
tak já si dovolím
využít
tady té
možnosti,
že jsem ten,
kdo má to slovo.
V první řadě bych
chci poděkovat vám všem
za celé hlavní období,
protože si myslím,
že nám můžou závidět
v mnoha městech
v podstatné České republice,
že zastupitelstvo města Zína
je konstruktivní
do značné míry,
než zcela úplně
je apolitické
a jsem za to strašně moc rád
a nepředu si nic jiného,
aby tomu tak bylo
i v budoucích letech,
protože
myslím si,
že do politiky
samozřejmě logicky
nějakým způsobem
občas ty vlaječky patří,
ale určitě za mě
nená komunální úroveň.
Nejradši bych ji neviděl
ani nahoře,
protože všichni mají
mít jako stejný cíl,
to znamená ve městě
posouvat věci
ku prospěchu občanů
a města na kraji,
a kraje
a co se týká
těch vyšších patr,
tak ku prospěchu
rozvoje České republiky
a jeho občanů.
Ať už na to důleva,
nebo zprava,
protože peníze jsou jen jedny,
takže buď ty daně vyberete
a máte ty služby levnější
a nebo je nevyberete
a musíte si je platit.
Takže pořád je to
o nějaké ekonomice,
nějaké makropohledu
a já jsem za to strašně moc rád,
že vy všichni jste
z tohoto součástí
a opravdu si myslím,
že se podařili
za ty čtyři roky
udělat nemalé kroky
k tomu,
aby se město s jím posunulo
a dnešní zastupitelstvo
je tomu jasným důkazem.
Chtěl bych poděkovat
hlavně také panu témníkovi
a celému úřadu,
protože ať už tady ve vedení
může být kdokoliv,
ale bez těch lidí
právě tady na magistrátu
od pana témníka
až po posledních,
jak se říká,
nějakou pomocnou sílu,
tak vlastně by ten magistrát
nefungoval
a můžete si tady bouchat do prsou,
ale ve výsledku
mám to procesují ti lidé.
Takže za to velké poděkování všem,
protože opravdu
za ty čtyři roky
obrovské množství práce
ve velkém tempu
myslím si,
že častokrát nás
proklínali,
ale na druhou stranu
si věřím tomu,
že teďka mají radost toho,
že ty věci se posunuly
v mnoha ohledech
a samozřejmě
je to vždycky tak,
že jsou věci,
které byste chtěli
a nemůžete udělat
z mnoha důvodů,
ať už skrze finance
a nebo taky
kolikrát i ty personální kapacity,
ale myslím si,
že ten rozvoj města Zína,
jak bych tak,
a provoz celého magistrátu
je v současné době
na zrůstající úrovni
a věřím tomu,
že tady ten trend
bude pokračovat
i v těch dalších letech.
Takže za to bych chtěl
moc krát opravdu všem poděkovat,
včetně samozřejmě
i našim městským společnostem,
protože ty udělají
velkou službu všem lidem
a bez nich bychom
samozřejmě
tu atraktivitu ztráceli.
Takže i díky jejich
soběstačnosti
jsme schopni zase
na druhou stranu
dělat i jiné věci,
které nemusíme právě dotovat
díky jejich dobré práci.
Takže za to moc krát všem děkuju
a věřím tomu,
že rádi přijmete
mé pozvání
do vedlejší zasedací místnosti
na tradiční malé občerstvení
po posvím zastupitelstvu.
A chtěl bych vám všem
i z tohoto pohledu
už takto předem
moc popřát,
ať máte úspěch ve volbách,
protože
si myslím,
že si to všichni,
kteří tady sedíte,
zasloužíte,
protože tak, jak jsem řekl,
ten přístup,
který je tady k tomu zastupitelstvu
a k tomu vedení města
jste měli,
tak za mě opravdu
velké poděkování
a věřím tomu,
že budete
na tyto roky,
když to řeknu,
velice rádi,
tak si to můžeme říct,
si vzpomínat,
ale opravdu si je připomínat,
protože si myslím,
že tady opravdu
takováto nálada
v zastupitelstvu
je relativně v zácnosti
a buďme rádi,
že to tady takto máme.
Děkuju moc
a tímto já otvírám diskuzi
a jako prvního
teda dávám slovo
panu náměstkovi Pavlovi Bradovi.
Věřím,
že letos poslední slova
nebo letos
v tomto volebním období
a chtěl jsem taky,
mám dvě věci,
které chci říct
a první je
velké poděkování
vlastně odboru majetku
Evy Husákové
za tu spolupráci,
kterou jsme tady měli
a jakým způsobem
se za ty roky
posunul odbor majetku.
To je neskutečné
oproti tomu,
když jsem tady nastupoval.
Takže obrovské díky
samozřejmě zaměstnancům,
magistrátů,
právnímu oddělení,
kteří taky dělá
výbornou práci,
ale v neposlední řadě
i kolegom v radě,
že jsme tam
nepolitikařili
a že to bylo smysluplné
ta práce naše.
Že to opravdu si myslím,
že takhle by to mělo vypadat,
že jsme pracovali
k rozvoji z Lína
a nehájili
nějaké stranické adresy.
A potom jsem chtěl říct
jednu takovou důležitou myšlenku.
Včera zaněli konferenci Baťa
a tak jenom
jeden takový citát.
Nejznešenějším úkolem
vedoucího sob země
i státu
je probudit a uvolnit
životní síly obyvatelstva
a řídit tyto síly tak,
aby pomáhali sobě
i státu k blahobytu.
A to je to,
co jsme se tady
celé volemní období snažili,
vytvářet takové podmínky,
aby kromě města
mohl dobře investovat
i soukromý sektor.
A tím příkladem je
Šmoulí město,
Poliklinika parkování,
teďka diskutované kino velké,
Bonický rybník Březnická
a pokud my tady budeme se
tak i v dalším období
připravíme plochy Torzo,
Ližarský svach
a další máme plochy ve Štípě
a chceme vytvořit podmínky
pro to, aby tady
prostě chtěli investovat
nejen subjekty odsud,
ale samozřejmě i případně
zahraniční subjekty
a aby to začalo dávat smysl.
Protože bez kapitálu
se tady prostě neobejdeme.
Potřebujeme sem
získat další subjekty,
investory,
aby to město mohlo fungovat.
A rozvoj Zlína ve 30. letech
byl proto,
že tady byl velmi silný
soukromý sektor.
Takže to jsem jenom takhle chtěl,
s tímto se loučím
a taky vám všem přeji úspěch
ve volbách.
A díky za spolupráci.
Tak, moc chále děkuji.
Poprosím pana Jandu.
Děkuji, pane primátore.
Já bych chtěl říct,
že jsem za to čtyřleté období
byl zástupcem pro Nivy a Vršava.
Jsem velmi rád,
že vlastně se nám podařilo
v této lokalitě vybudovat
kancelář místní části
zcela novou,
nakopnout skvělou partu lidí,
která tam dokázala
od masopustů
přes dětské různé setkání,
zabíjačky, koždvína a tak dále.
Se tam podařilo spoustu lidí aktivovat.
Bylo to asi zhruba 100 rodin
a chtěl bych to vlastně využít
jako to poděkování,
že vlastně se v té spolupráci
s radnicí toto podařilo.
Poděkování těm lidem,
kteří se toho účastnili,
protože myslím si,
že to je vlastně ten cíl
těch místních částí,
aby dávalo to dohromady
ty lidi.
Tam do té doby
v podstatě nic podobného nefungovalo,
takže jsem za to rád
a chtěl bych poděkovat.
Samozřejmě jsem chtěl taktež říct,
že vlastně máme
předvolební období
a chtěl bych vyslat
i občanům vzkaz,
aby pochopitelně,
pokud mohou,
ať opravdu k volbám jdou,
ať si vyberou tu stranu,
která jim připadla sympatická,
ta, která pro ně něco udělala,
případně její zástupci.
Takže a vám, kolegům,
jsem chtěl poděkovat
za korektní jednání
po tu celou dobu.
Děkuji.
Právodská, děkuji.
Poprosím Kateřinu Francovou.
Já teda dneska také naposledy,
také za klubstan,
děkujeme všem.
A tak, jak jste, pane primátore,
řekl,
můžeme mít různé názory,
ale komunikujeme tady slušně
a na úrovni,
a to je strašně důležité
a budu doufat,
že si to i v příštím volebním období
tady toto udržíme
a budeme komunikovat vždycky tak,
jak se tady několik let
posledních komunikovalo.
Děkujeme všem, kolegům
i celému magistrátu.
Děkuji.
Poprosím na městka Mirka Chalánka.
Děkuji, pane primátore.
No, já se přidám tomu děkování.
Já bych chtěl taky poděkovat
za ty čtyři roky.
Byli jste dobří spoluhráči,
kvalitní soupeři,
byla dobrá atmosféra pracovní.
To je vždycky důležité.
Já si myslím,
že při tom, jak říkala Katka,
měli jsme na něco různé názory,
což je normální,
o toho tady jsme.
Ale já si myslím,
že jsme si udrželi
dobré prostředí
a to je strašně důležité.
Takže za to hlavně děkuju.
A všem přeúspěch ve volbách.
Tak moc velký.
Chtěl říct, největší než váš.
Jasné, moc velké děkujeme.
Vlastně pana tajemníka.
Tak, děkuji za slovo.
Já moc děkuji za to poděkování,
co se týká úřadu.
Myslím si, že pro všechny kolegy
z úřadu to strašně moc znamená.
A chtěl bych vám jako zastupitelům
poděkovat za korektní přístup
v celé volební období
k nám, k úředníkům.
Takže jsme se vám vždycky předkládat
všechny materiály
v co nejlepší kvalitě obsahu,
tak abyste mohli
o těch věcech rozhodovat.
Vy, kteří pokračujete
a budete soutěžit,
přeji úspěch ve volbách.
Vy, kteří skončíte,
tak vám přeji hlavně
hodně zdraví a spokojenosti
jak v osobním,
tak v profesním životě.
Moc vám děkuji za spolupráci.
Tak, děkuji.
A poprosím pana Vančuru.
Děkuju, pane primátore.
My hodnotíme
toto volební období
z našeho pohledu
za lepší než to předchozí.
Děkujeme především
těm kolegům z vás,
kteří s kterými spolupracovali
a kde jsme si mohli
vzájemně prokázat respekt.
Myslím, že to je důležité.
Budeme si samozřejmě těšit
i příštím období
na to, že se s vámi,
alespoň s některými tady uvidíme.
A na závěr
z toho, že o pane primátore,
co jste dneska pověděl,
my jsme docela disciplinovaní,
ale ten stezk
po té hospodě.
Myslím si, že bychom to měli teď
naplnit a že bychom měli
všichni do hospody.
Tak pokud se nám to dneska nepodaří,
tak možná po těch volbách.
Bude všichni hodně zdrávi
a hodně štěstí všem.
Moc krát děkuju všem
a děkuju za tu spolupráci.
Tak jako je to super
a vážím si toho.
Moc si toho vážím.
Děkuju moc.
Přijďeme se ve 202
a přijměte prosím také
ten malý dáreček
za ty čtyři roky práce.
Moc krát vám děkuju,
ať se vám všem daří
a hlavně ve zdraví vám
i vašim rodinám.
Moc krát děkuju.
Titulky vytvořil Jirka Jirka Jirka Jirka Jirka Jirka Jirka.